[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
cheers everyone welcome back welcome
back it's the me and the lads and we are
commentating the prime card come on I've
got joshia my right hand man with us
we've got joy the finest the kickoff has
to offer Lawrence oy the pro boxer and
of course the creator of YouTube boxing
it's Joseph Wella hello mate all right
mate how you doing uh I'm bloody good
and uh first questions for you bro how
does it feel six years later after you
thought this idea up that it's now
putting on events like this and it's
gone this far me honestly I think more
than anything it's like being proud like
the fact that you know influences are
known well from back in the day of just
like faking stuff you know just you know
pretending like they're the real deal or
you know that they're going to commit
something but it's not legit you know
and the fact that we've got so many that
are like putting their like lives
committing into it now and it's on this
scale man it's unbelievable and it is
like phenomenal to see so yeah man you
started it and you fought obviously you
fought KSI aftera Theo and KSI got the
win over you he's now gone on he's now
fighting a pro boxer L like this like
you said this is another another level
of
fighting is anyone in on the table
expecting him to win or gives him a
serious chance of winning other than me
cuz I have I think the best person to
ask is Joe as soon as You' been in there
with him well this the thing I'd say the
fighter that he was against me is
different to he is now you were kids
right I mean I kind of look at you like
kids back do you know what I mean as in
even when people talk about that fight
now I'm like bro that I was a I was a
little
boy know what I mean it's like a school
fight you know what I mean like well
this is y you this happened to you it's
like mate that I was a little boy back
then and so was JJ right and obviously
the fact that he's now training with
people that aren't just you know
obviously Vidal is a good coach but he's
not professional boxing coaches like
he's got now I think the game that he's
bringing is something that I think he's
got a chance tonight I'm just going to
throw it out there straight up and it is
only by knockout I will say you know the
the thing that uh really dawned on me
when I was making my preview was okay so
he's fought these guys Joe Foria they're
not on the level of Tommy Fury right the
skill gap between Joe for and Tommy Frey
is massive so JJ is multi-millionaire he
doesn't need to take this fight for the
money if anything this is a lot of
hustle when he could be making money
easier ways so in order for his boxing
coaches to go yeah take the fight you
can win that you win that they must have
seen something because if he goes in
there tonight and what Tommy Fury says
will H will happen actually happens and
Tommy Fury is levels above and there's a
gulfing class and he humiliates him well
well then JJ is going to turn around to
his boxing coaches and be like what the
[__] did you put me in there for then if
I if I cuz they must have seen a lot in
training so their
reputations are on the line big time
tonight and cuz he's going to turn
around to them if if if they if they're
completely wrong what do you make of it
LO I can't see him winning to be honest
I mean in the day I see Tommy fur is the
actual professional boxer um I mean he's
kind of not in that world at the moment
but I see as the real deal more so than
KSI um and there's nothing that I've
seen from KSI that's really impressed us
but I suppose the guys that he's been
fighting haven't been that great either
whereas Tommy Fury I just think he's a
little bit more of a real boxer and I
just think how's he going to get past
the job like ksi's got this low guard
yes he's meant to have a bit of power
but is that enough I can't say it but uh
that's just no no that's what most pro
boxing guys are saying and you're the
more of an expert here than anyone right
so and I'm not disagreeing with you in
terms of logic but like that's where my
brain's like what the [__] have these
coaches been saying because they've been
getting them in there with Pros they
have to have but then like there's being
in with pros and then there's actually
like delivering against Pros it's like
you can get beaten up and whatever or
these guys you know being in there with
them but are they really going for it if
they're on a pay roll yeah you know
apparently they were putting bonuses on
the head saying if you if you hurt him
we're going to pay you even more that's
the sort of level we're talking so and I
watched an interview with JJ and you
know how he normally gives it the whole
like
KSI you know he gives it the whole thing
I love it but there was one interview
with talksport it was just dead ass he
was like I don't even need hot for this
one because I've got my game plan I know
what I do to these guys and I know he
won't be prepared for it and it was so
calm and logical I was like what does he
know like cuz why why do you throw your
reputation on the line but that's what
I'm saying it's like that the way in
which he talks it sounds like someone
that is absolutely confident that
they've backed it up but we haven't seen
the evidence yet admittedly that's
because he ends his opponent so early
that we haven't had to see it but like
you know if he's really getting it stuck
on him can he cover up and then you know
counter punch and work on the inside and
do do things like that like we haven't
seen it but he's so confident bro let's
let's pause it here because uh I want to
recap the the prelims fun um we seen the
heavyweight title won by Temple Arts any
one disagree with that decision I
personally didn't think it was going to
go tempo's way at the end of the fight I
sort of looked at it and I thought do
you know what he did really well in
there and actually despite uh physique
and maybe some of the Run of how the
fight went at times he definitely
actually looked like the more
comfortable man in there you see it when
he was backing up on the ropes and he
was trying to roll with the shots almost
like a poundland tyon fury at times but
obviously that shows that you're
comfortable in a ring you're not you're
not massively daunted by the occasion um
but I did think come the end of the
fight I was actually surprised to see it
was a split decision so to then see it
go that way say somewhat of a shock to
be honest yeah yeah I just felt like
even though he was more of a fighter and
Chase didn't really know what he was
doing Chase was just Landing more yeah
yeah he's he's engined and stay with him
did it he kind of ran out after about
the second round it was just he the
batteries had ran out but U he
definitely looked more of a comfortable
boxer in there but just the sheer size
difference I think it was the other guy
was just more of a natural athlete I
don't think there was if if it wasn't
for the fact that that guy was an
athlete he probably would have won the
fight but he didn't have the engine to
stay with him I think that's what it
come down to yeah I think as well like
you see this in say the Astrid wet fight
like where it is a bit messy like it's
not great technical boxing like it is a
bit difficult to go was that a definite
punch that landed was it not and I think
like maybe there's a little bit of that
because I I sort of do feel like Chase
landed more but obviously Tempo did look
maybe a little bit more technical maybe
they were a little bit more flushes
let's what about swarms gets a change of
opponent been training for probably at
least a couple of months uh Ryan T got
arrested in the in the runup to the
fight what do we think about that by the
way like surely you you he must have
known what he was doing in terms of like
getting arrested what was he doing
trying to get into the Big Brother house
it it I don't know what he did but like
if you're look like Misfits have agreed
from a misfit point of view like I
talked to the guys obviously and and
they're like we
paid you a salary to be here you're like
I get you're a content creator but like
this is why you're here and yet you
manage to somehow get arrested in the
Days running up by doing silly content
things when you're supposed to be having
a boxing match I just think he'll kick
himself when he looks at it you know
what I mean like it's the sort of thing
that like when he gets to being an old
man and he's like I had the opportunity
to fight at that venue on that card I
and I just did what I did he'll he'll
kick himself I think yeah like I don't
know how old he is but I think at this
age like from from the age he looks like
I you think he would be over that by now
um and the guy who turns up Ed Matthews
you on the runup on the on the walkdown
you were like he's going to win this
yeah I thought Ed Matthews win like I
look at the fact that haven't watched
all of his fights but I know he was in
there with blue face the rapper one of
one of he very game yeah one of his last
fights obviously he got stopped but he
went out on his shield in that fight and
I sort of looked at it and I thought
right blue face probably 63 a lot more
intimidating and swarms obviously um and
you showed heart against him you kept
coming forward you kept even hitting him
with shots even in the feet and I sort
of looked at it and I thought this is
quite a step down in my opinion from
blueface to swarms in terms of the the
influence of boxing world so I looked at
it straight away and I also think that
when someone does come in at late notice
and you know they haven't had to sell
tickets they haven't almost had to cuz
you know like preparing for a fight
mentally is exhausting do you know what
I mean like as much as anyone can say
yeah I'm able to block it out m I can
only speak for myself I check my
opponent social medias I look at stuff
you know what I mean you do do it people
don't like to admit they do it but it
can be draining you know what I mean and
I think like the fact that you've coming
at late notice it's almost like a free
roll of the dice isn't it and obviously
then you sort of see the character that
we see from him on social media and by
all accounts he is like that in real
life I just sort of thought yeah this
this fell is going to go in there throw
hell for Lever and he's going to end up
he's going to end up beating swarms in
this fight so that's what happened the
saddest thing is is I and my criticism
of swarms in the the runup was he's so
defensive minded like he's he's not
aggressive it's backwards Let me throw
the jab out and just hope you stay away
from me and that's exactly he went
straight back to what he knows and Ed
Matthews threw a few to get him backed
up gets him in the corner and unleashes
him and knocks him out with and for
swarms you got to think to yourself I
didn't even get a shot off I just ran
away and got knocked out for it like I
think Ed Matthews can definitely be in
some fun fights as well you know like
I'm not putting him at a level where I'm
thinking I think he's around the same
weight as like Gibb and people like that
I'm not actually putting him at that
level but I do think so long as he gets
through the ropes he's going to be in
fun fights as well he's good value for
money I think I think the big thing
about him is his game like the way he
comes forward and he's just like I just
want to fight I feel like a lot of these
influenc of fights it is who is the more
aggressive one who's willing to just get
in there and that's you know the biggest
person we've seen so far do that KSI
right and I feel like you know the fight
is like like Matthews like Gibb that are
just going in there like going I don't
care I am going to go for this like they
have a lot of success the mest thing is
is KSI didn't even get swarms out of
there that quick no yeah that is the
thing TR like that is mad mad like
[__] hell so swarms when he's had
actual no training overweight lasted
weight how many rounds two KSI three
rounds similar I think I can't remember
if it was two or three I think it was
third round he got like that and then
there we go 13 seconds against swarms
against Matthews can we talk about that
knockdown though was it was it a true
knockdown or is he is his leg gone so
this is a good point let's talk about it
so this is the thing I've just seen
footage posted by Ki news right that
says that well no that shows a video of
almost his leg or ankle breaking it
literally looks like it snaps and I
don't know whether that's what has
caused him to go down or whether it's
the left hook but what's difficult is
that we didn't really get to see an
angle where you can see if that punch
landed I I think the the hook put him
down on the way down he's gone down
awkwardly and then he's really [__]
the ankle so he was on his way down
anyway he's probably [__] anyway but
the ankles and it really reminded me I
broke my ancle as a kid when I was like
15 16 playing football went in a sliding
tackle and I sat my ass down on my other
ancle and it was just like that so yeah
fair play like it could just be the
uncle but when when you looked and he
went down he he didn't look really hurt
but like he looked like he was in shock
so there was obviously something else
going on which we couldn't see at the
time so I do think it was the anle that
kind of stopped him getting back up yeah
it's just normally like say in football
like you hurt your leg you grab it
immediately like your brain thinks to
grab whatever you've hurt right and it's
way there was it was about two and a
half minutes later he's like oh starts
hobbling and that's why I thought maybe
he's pretended like he's hurt leg you've
been in the ring right you get the
adrenaline when you're fighting do you
is it some of those things you've walked
out of the ring you go oh [__] hell
that really hurts for sure i' say
there's an element of that like when the
adrenaline's going obviously yeah you're
not going to feel certain I think as
humans we're designed for like survival
to not fill certain things when you're
in that fight or flight state so yeah
maybe after a few minutes he started to
feel it but generally speaking if you
snap your ankle
you're
quickly if you break a bone pretty soon
you're thinking oh my god I've just done
that don't feel right but I tell you
what I do feel sorry for swarms in a way
because if it is a serious injury and
that's all the the only reason he's lost
the fight he's going to have a long time
waiting to be able to redeem himself you
know I mean it's not going to be a quick
turn around of that didn't go it's
almost better to get knocked out because
then if if you're committed to it and
you want to carry on boxing then you can
go all right I can't fight for 90 days
or the border of control you can't but I
can't fight for 90 days but at least I
can get back in there that's a that's a
6mon layoff or something if he has yeah
straight up all right let's bring it on
to one of the biggest talking points
going true Jordy what are you saying
Dylan dnis mhm did you go too far I
don't think he went far enough no J no
no no no no no you're not joking because
I you think there is an element where we
all can see how in war well you're
telling me there's actually any rules
there isn't and I think like as you know
lowkey most people are actually like
yeah like take it there what else are
you actually going to get into the head
of Logan Paul with on a lead up to a
fight but I think there's that Unwritten
rule where you kind of stay away from
the family I mean I I personally
wouldn't you know what I mean I would I
wouldn't go near the family but there
are you know if you're talking fighting
can you say that there ever really is
going too far but some you know fight
their s t and spur the moment they get
carried away and then they have a little
thing like they leave it there but this
is a ongoing thing ke go like this is
daily for months da crazy every morning
good morning with a picture of this
man's fiance and then repeated post
later on that day it's commitment it is
can can I ask a question right does
anyone here think the Dylan danis is
anything in this fight a boxing match
but the underdog he's the underdog isn't
he Dyan danis knows he's the underdog so
to an extent if you ask me would I do it
no I personally wouldn't do it right but
can I understand why when he thinks he's
up against it and the odds are against
him why he's gone down this route yeah I
can understand it I'm not saying I do it
I can understand it because when you do
feel like you're the underdog in a fight
any Edge you can get any little Edge and
this isn't just a little Edge this is
completely this is almost life changing
what he's done you know what I mean and
it's a massive thing but I can
understand why he's done this because
he's probably thinking right my best bet
is to make this guy really really angry
he doesn't stick to the almost
methodical style of boxing that we've
seen from him in maybe like the second
KSI fight where he was very cautious
almost a lot of stuff behind the
straight shots and whatnot and Dylan
danis is probably thinking I know we got
a pair of gloves on it's a boxing match
but the last thing I really want to do
with this guy is have a boxing match
because athleticism wise and just the
fact that he's done boxing longer better
Striker he's going to get the better of
me so if he's doing it to gain an edge
again I'm not saying I do it but can
completely see why let me pull you up on
a couple of things though
is Dylan danis uh I don't think there's
anywhere near as smart as you're giving
him credit for like I think you know
remember 69ine yes I think he's the
fighting version of 69ine he just loves
to chat [__] and uh the and this is the
madest thing is is like in so many
different scenarios he proves that
that's just who he is so Logan brings
out the teat a predator guy Chris Hanson
uh at the weigh in and you and and and
Dylan laughs at it and like Fair [__]
play that's good and then he goes to
Chris Hanson you paid your taxes yet and
he straight away goes in on him and he's
like yeah I heard you were going to jail
cuz you didn't pay your taxes the guy
was like oh [__] and he he literally had
him on the back foot and I was like
Logan Paul went to all this trouble and
now Dylan danis is just destroying the
GU put in front of him verbally and so
you're like okay this is who you are
then they put him on a lie detector test
have you ever done a lie detector no
I've done one for YouTube before for a
bit of fun but even when it's a bit of
fun you get the LI te their on B you and
all of a sudden you're like [__] me it's
like uh Who Wants To Be A Millionaire
like the lights come on you or whatever
you know and you feel like okay I can't
[__] bend the rules bend the truth or
anything yeah that man was ice cold on
the LI do you respect Logan Paul he says
no tell him the truth do you think
you're going to win he says yeah easily
tell him the truth like do you think you
shouldn't have said any of those things
no tell them the truth like everything
you'd think that would would be coming
back as [__] all came back as
telling the truth so he genuinely thinks
Logan's a [__] boxer and that he's going
to win tonight like and he barely even
flinched I was like I was kind of like
it's like when you're watching a serial
killer on Netflix and they're like lying
but they believe their own lives well
that's the thing so far like he has
demonstrated like he does believe what
he's saying like you think oh we'd be
able to tell at the press conference or
at the way in or he's acting a bit like
oh he doesn't actually feel it but he's
he's seeming almost like the more
controlling Force the the more composed
the quick witted one that's coming out
with like he's in his FL State yeah do
you know what I mean and as well like
thinking back to well thinking why he
may have done such an onslaught like
he's done with the whole fiance thing I
think this is him well don't know
whether it's his first like proper time
but it seems like he would never have
had it on this scale of getting the
interaction on social media and that so
addictive so addictive that I think he's
like you know that's why he says it's
just business it's not personal this is
just a way for me to get get that
[__] dopamine every day it's probably
it's giving him that good feeling and
the door and the do mate you know what I
mean so I actually think there's an
element of that like he's falling for
the almost social media trap of loving
the interactions do you know what the
funny thing is as well yeah the sort of
Outlook doesn't doesn't align with the
story line here so say we hadn't sat
through this and I just described it to
you and I said right these two guys are
fighting and one has started posting
pictures and everything and bringing up
digging up the past about this other
guy's misses you go Spang out of
and maybe I've just got a sick group of
friends or something but the reaction
especially like amongst my group of
friends I spoke to about everyone's gone
Dylan danis is funny is he I like him
yeah yeah I like him maybe it's because
we got a weird sense of humor or
something but I actually do genuinely
think that it's going down quite well
amongst people like the way danis has
gone on and maybe that's got something
to do with Logan Paul's character and
and potentially for right or wrong
people maybe not warming to him as much
but it hasn't it hasn't been a thing of
like he shot himself in the foot by
doing this actually think he's gained
followers at the start though the the
other Fighters like UFC guys like best
thing were coming out and going no you
don't do that that's out of order and
then a month later B's like God you
can't say he's not funny can you and it
was that change and and and I do think
like it's not just uh Logan's Pro
obviously Logan's pissed people off over
the years and there's the crypto thing
and there's all these other reasons why
people are you know uh don't like them
right now but it's also them as a couple
I think what they represent to a lot of
people is here is two people you'll
never look like them you'll never have
what they have they are perfect in every
way and to watch someone try and destroy
that it it plays into the negative
feeling that a lot of people have within
them that some people just want to watch
the world burn and that's why Dylan
danis is the jokeer of this whole thing
and people kind of like the Scarface
type attitude wild yeah without a doubt
I think people it is sad that that is a
fact but like when people are doing well
like Logan Paul is like no one's doing
better bro like jard going to be a
billionaire there is an element where
where when he like announced oh now I'm
getting you know married to the girl of
my dreams as well it's like [__] hell
what else can he get that's perfect
right so almost yeah there probably is
an element where they're like oh yeah he
[__] deserves this actually you know
what [__] Logan Paul yeah so yeah man
the world is weird I think Dylan is
clever to feed into that part of
people's brains and Conor McGregor I
mean he watched his best mate did it for
years right like not in the same way but
if you watch the way Dylan is talking
[__] now it's quite Conor esque actually
in these press conferences I'm thinking
I'm watching him going you know if you
actually had hands you'd be a a star you
really would be but unfortunately your
thought punch is like a 90-year-old
[__] arthritis patient well that is
the thing like any sparring footage you
see of him throwing hands there's not a
single one that has any popet on at the
end of it none of them snap they're all
just sort of these pushing up sort of
pushing hands to set up almost his
takedowns and you know like you were
saying this morning with Wade his
distance management he just keeps
getting clocked like doesn't know in the
MMA fights he gets caught in that like
MMA fights obviously completely
different distance to to boxing cuz
boxing so close up whereas MMA there's a
lot of jumping in in the middle but he's
always in that dead space and whoa and
like he has to back off and go oh
[__] hell I'm like mate if you're
struggling with MMA distance there's a
reason why you know MMA fighters
struggle with boxers cuz they distance
management is even better so I I
personally think he's getting if I think
he's getting destroyed tonight but if I
wouldn't I wouldn't like the B Logan
right now because it's such a lose lose
like you have to almost knock him out in
the most brutal perfect fashion to
satisfy the storyline 100% let's not get
it WR if he gets out there with the
decision if if Logan Paul does not
humiliatingly knock this man out it's a
loss that's straight up he needs to
demolish this bloke um my thing is
though is I feel like Logan does smother
his work a lot right so look at
Mayweather okay div in a lot and I feel
like with the tangling up that could
play into the jiujitsu side trying to
see how it could work for danis but I
feel like that could be an El he's
convinced Logan's going to G yeah so
that could be a way to [__] him out
if he keeps tying him up and just
getting him in like the slight choke Cs
and stuff like that could actually be
what ends up knackering him out the
thing with Logan gassing though is we're
neglecting a big part of the job someone
can gas you still got to finish him off
youve still got to out box them so I
think we're going to see a hugfest if
I'm honest with you and it doesn't
really sell fight that well but that's I
said that in my prediction I do feel as
well the element of how stressed out
both of these BLS probably would have
been on the lead up to this Logan for
obvious reasons but the lawsuit element
onto Dylan Like if he's really losing
all of his money and some like by
hundreds of thousands like you're not
going to be like [__] relaxed as hell
you know what I mean with with all that
going on so I do feel like we could get
both guys get into actual fight night
and just being spent and it being
actually quite yeah like you say a bit
of a cuddle Fest is it a real lawsuit
like have we seen legal
papers actually happening going for the
life yeah um 150 Grand she's suing for
for damages now there's been a few
people who've passed comment on this uh
other MMA fighters have spoken out
against it and said you know you
shouldn't be doing that uh Brendan cha
did Logan Paul bit backed him chil
sunnon said something funny which he
goes how can you sua damages about your
reputation when no one knew who you were
before this happened like you had no
reputation to damage sort of thing but
to be fair like it's it's not good you
know what I mean so dlan's going to lose
that he's got he shouldn't even show up
for that he should just pay the money
and accept the feed how much he have to
pay 150 Grand but he has my thinking if
someone who knows a little bit is if you
then try and fight it you're going to
lose anyway so you're going to pay a
whole load of lawyer costs and then 150
Grand as well but is there the element
that it's already public content um the
issue is is I feel like they must know
that at least one of you know the video
that went viral I think the the 100
million view video where she's talking
into a camera the claim is that maybe
that or something else was a private
video that was hacked that then was
given to Dylan and Dylan somehow posted
it unaware maybe that it was a private
video right um and yeah but this is when
you're talking about taking it too far
like if there's a legal element to this
that's happened then obviously it has
gone to a level which is not allowed
like it's it's illegal so if he does if
we're saying that he is going to win the
uh sorry that she is going to win the
court case then surely he has taken it
too far by the definition of of the law
like is that not is it not as simple as
that but there is the fact is that the
amount of information that she's put out
there it's like she had no respect for
herself when she's talking about having
you know what I mean she's talking about
I want h a
fat apparently that was a private video
I don't know how you know I don't know
at this point I don't know sounds like
she's talking to the world but what what
about the when she's uh the YouTube clip
when she's just getting a getting a
breast s yeah I mean she's she's got no
respect for awful can you send me
that I've got it save but exactly so I
just think although it's too far but
with her in mind of what she's already
been doing and putting out there I think
fair play really to an extent because he
he's got to get every Advantage he could
and I think it's worked so I personally
think one interesting thing he dropped
on a an interview recently was that and
that look with Dylan you take everything
with a pinch of Sal but that Li detect
the test maybe think maybe he is [__]
telling the truth sometimes he goes yeah
uh I know Leonardo decaprio now Leonardo
decaprio was the most famous of the guys
that she'd been with and he went I don't
want to say too much but he's very aware
of what's going on and I wondered like
did he give you the [__] tip after
all of this and that's when you started
digging did you have a you know what I
mean you know cuz who is supplying him
well I I think at the start it was him
just digging but then I'm pretty
sure he's the king of the trolls right
so his DMS must be flooded with his
minions
helping yeah at that point I would
imagine how would they get them I'm just
sort of like two of youits like in
places like that really I'm just asking
for a friend yeah [__] yeah one
interesting bit was he was out last
night yeah mate I saw that so I I was
saying that to you this morning right
cuz I I saw it and I was literally like
so this bloke is being pictured even if
he's not drinking right he he's
surrounded by shots different random
people different influences out late at
night if he is doing that like surely he
is not taking this seriously and he is
going to get seriously hurt i' I I was
just thinking about there's a bit of
footage that I saw which was Dylan
asking Tommy Fury how to
box I I feel like can't be real that L
that looked a little bit like oh look if
I like taking the piss I can't actually
be be asking how to but this the thing
it seemed so dead he's doing he goes
yeah so can you and and and and and
Tommy goes like well yeah like you know
how some name is
Tyson he's like yeah Tyson something is
cuz I like the you're just watching him
with these 3D glasses on what are we
watching is there a possibility though
that he's got in his head in the same
way that Connor got in Aldo's head and
he just comes out and he just absolutely
just throws a punch and just gets
clocked and done is that not a
possibility Dylan's going to clock him
like Dylan is the Conor McGregor here
okay I think Dylan become the star of
this show I actually do without a doubt
and I believe actually that could be the
thing Logan if he really does lose his
head from the get-go that could be
that's I feel that's his only real down
just a note from the uh everyone
following us don't forget to hit the
like button subscribe if you haven't
already we're underway for the tag team
boxing match uh B Dave starts off
against Nick LMO and uh B Dave lands a
decent shot and Nick actually called for
B Dave to be the first one in there and
he was like the minute I hit you you'll
R out of there and Dave has going the
opposite way he's actually like pushing
him into the corner and and but but um
Nick has actually got a really good win
over Jay swingler um wait did he win he
he beat Jay swingler I think did i s
didn't it officially get announced as
Jay though but it was a robbery oh maybe
but I I remember him beating J just in
my I probably put that right in the head
for can you explain to us who have never
seen tag team boxing before considering
you are a member of The Shadow
government yes Shadow government member
can you explain to us how this fight is
going to work okay so basically one dude
is going to tag out when he's get when
he doesn't want to be in there or gets
tired uh paneda here who was one of
ksi's first opponents on Misfits uh has
definitely gotten a bit better is
basically going to be the one who's
going to try and put the beating on
these two but the issue and Pan's
actually hurting Nick here um Alex
Wasabi who hasn't been tagged in yet is
a pretty good boxer he's got a win over
deji uh which is a really credible win
at this point in uh in
Misfits um and I think he he's actually
from the same part of the world as salt
papy um actually love this concept when
I'm watching this I was about to ask you
do you want to see this in real oh
Wasabi puts him down pan has been
dropped and he looks bad oh oh that
looks oh he's really hurt this is a real
bad knif for previous opponents of KSI
they all get dropped like can you tag
your mate here though and get him in
like yeah yeah you can tag your M but
the problem is is panada was the one
they were hoping would carry the tag
team and he is really uh struggling here
so if your best guy is struggling you
got to worry tagging in the little guy
you know tagged out do you know what
confuses me or I can never get my head
round with a tag team boxing I agree
with you I think it's a good concept I
think it's I think it's a lot of fun
right but a few of us around this table
have been in the ring boxing even
inspiring right sometimes you'd be
getting better at inspiring your coach
goes another round you go yeah I
couldn't imagine being in there someone
fry and punches at me and thinking I'm
going to tag out now yeah it kind of
goes goes against the whole premise of
like being a warrior being a fighter you
know what I mean I've had
enough rolling around you see B Dave
what what B Dave is trying to do is he
knows they're in trouble and he knows he
needs to hold this down while paneda
gets his [__] together so he's just
wrestling these guys yeah it's it's an
eagle thing generally speaking when
you're in a spa and they'll always be
your coach will go one more wrong will
you just do a few with him and you're
thinking I'm absolutely not good here
but you will not see no just Eagle thing
but um
oh he's getting counted so there was a
slip for Wasabi but they they're
counting it as an actual drop it was
just a slip so right now they've had one
a piece in terms of being dropped the
punch how does this get scored then is
it that it's now one1 that is how it
works so knock down for knockdown yeah
yeah so it'll be it'll be what 99 or
whatever I guess uh something like that
so essentially the scoring is exactly
the same okay okay but you don't have do
you have to tag out once you've been
dropped no you can do what you want okay
yeah but I think it's a wise move
yeah uh I'm going to need a whiskey soon
like cuz [__] this is
exciting so Loza would you ever see this
in professional boxing could you see it
happening n It's s for a bit of fun but
uh box like like like you've just
mentioned there you don't actually even
if you're tired you're hurt you don't
want to have to get out and let someone
else kind of finish up for you it's just
not what I feel like it's more I don't
want to say it because it sounds like
I'm sticking the knife in on this I
really like this concept uh Misfits
influen of boxing is in a world of its
own but when you talk about the
professional side of or really sort of
competitive side of boxing I just think
like it's almost worse than taking a
knee if you didn't need to it's but this
is why like you've just said there you
can almost put it in a category of its
own you don't put it as it's its own
thing you know what I mean so you also
don't see the most serious YouTubers do
this well I was going to ask that who's
who's the uh sort of top name that we've
seen compete in one of these you're
watching them right now this is the best
version they ever of it really like
these two guys who are struggling
they're fighting a newly formed tag team
but they beat the [__] out these two
guys last time and what you had was kind
of what you're describing the two guys
who were getting beaten up they kept
getting beaten up and tagging each other
as quick as they could it was it was
funny as [__] cuz you're like these two
are getting battered and when one of
them got tagged the other one was like
[__] I'm back in here you know what the
problem with it is though like say for
example um you liken it to a football if
you're a goalkeeper you could be having
a brilliant match but your defense is at
absolutely rubbish imagine your partners
just getting battered at every
opportunity but you're doing quite well
well I've suggested a new one to them
now I'm on the shadow government yeah
I've said um boys and girls versus boys
and girls so like a couple's version
because I'm just thinking right just go
with us here all right imagine your
girlfriend's watching you getting the
[__] kicked out of you and then you have
to tag her out in shame and she's
beating up the girl for you like that
sort of thing yeah um this has gone wild
so far there been few drops this was a
football tackle here like this was a
slide tackle that he did is another anle
injury this no no it was a slide tackle
he's crying it got stamped on was he
crying did he get stamped on yeah he
literally it literally looked like a
slide tackle the referee I'm not eveny I
feel sorry for the referee because he's
really not in a uh he's literally like
what the [__] am I doing and the funny
thing you said about that referee that's
a British B going to say this is the
real deal he was thinking Grace what am
I doing here I really want a new laws
here seen this guy reing like British
title fights probably higher it is good
fun on all levels this guy's oh alexab
is fighting well on the back foot here B
DAV is getting lit up big time I don't
know how many more of these you can take
and B DAV is he's he his thing is just
to break the rules he's like [__] it I'm
going to tackle you do whatever I have
to do think out the four Fighters that
we've seen in the ring so far Alex
Wasabi is the one that it to me looks is
a sort of level above three yeah he's
legit he was supposed to fight KSI
and then KSI um he pulled out through
injury concussion yeah which was serious
to be fair to him and I I think that was
when they tried to get that natzi
remember that natzi who was coming at
first yeah they they drafted in a new
opponent and he had a big Nazi tattoo
and then they were like oh [__] we can't
get just seen the Nazi tattoo so then
they ended up with two in one night and
that's how that came
about um but yeah I think Wasabi's
decent this is crazy back the head shot
yeah so how long's this been when did
this come in this
te just just in uh this since Misfit
last few uh months and and as a small
council member like there are certain
things I'm a very
serious right as a very member of the
four of us right so do you have any
inside info right that that you could
like let us in on on what may be coming
up like is in I don't know like is there
going to be a triple threat match or
anything just sort of taable Ls and
chair I can I can let you know one thing
tonight exclusive L on this stream was
that true Conor McGregor is in the host
tday and they're definitely working on
things I don't know what but he'll be
involved at something tonight okay so
this right so you've got Connor McGregor
You've Got Jake Paul you got KSI right
surely we're going to see something kick
off and Logan I mean andan how can one
Arena contain those egos I don't know um
I already know that uh wow Pan's just
clocked Wasabi to be fair I don't know
I think McGregor must be aware there's
there's money and entertainment in this
for me in the long term if the UFC if he
goes back to the UFC and the and he gets
clocked by
Chandler this is his next best thing
because there's an actual relationship
there between prime and the UFC they
sponsor the UFC so it's not like other
situations where people have wanted to
make Dream fights with Connor and Dana
shut it down Prim are literally putting
money in the pocket of the UFC so if
they go look let's just put on a huge
event UFC can cuz priman wanting good
advertising right so and McGregor will
want advertising for his whiskey brand
there there's so much opportunity there
for them to create a big event around a
KSI versus Connor or a Jake Paul versus
Conor McGregor I just think that will
happen because when there's too much
money involved like Floyd with Connor it
just happens and you do you reckon in
your heart that Conor McGregor would
take on a YouTuber I do yeah yeah I do
because I think with his leg I think the
reason it's been so long delayed since
he came when he was supposed to come
back a while back they announced the
Chandler fight months ago and it keeps
getting pushed and pushed and pushed I
just think that if it doesn't go well
and and he goes the leg the leg um then
he's going to do what Anderson Silva did
and take a boxing when his leg had the
same exact injury and it makes sense I
mean he loves fighting he wants to have
a scrap but he just can't fight at the
elite level that he was once at and
these YouTubers in theory shouldn't be
able to lace his boots no but yeah I
think you're I think you're right I
don't I don't think he would be in
attendance if he wasn't having the plan
of a bigger picture of that happening
and when he called out KSI I was
like shouldn't it be the other way
around yeah KSI calling you out I mean
that really said a lot about where his
head's at now in my opinion he's
thinking and he's not stupid like in
terms of promoting fights he's one of
the greatest of all time he's planting
seeds like you know when he's given it
couldn't box eggs you said that if he
comes back and get speak by a Chand this
is the next best thing you know quite a
lot of people maybe not the sort of
fighting purists here but quite a lot of
people would argue that this isn't the
next best thing this is the best option
including fighting Chandler if you take
away Legacy I think that okay say for
example if you do get beat by chanler
the next fight the next MMA fight is not
going to pay you anywhere near as much
and you're not going to be in the line
for a world title fight it's not like
boxing where there's different
organizations and different
organizations have got different agendas
that they want to push in the UFC you're
all under one Banner so you're not going
to then go for a title straight away
after that but if you go in here and you
fight let's say a KSI you fight one of
the influencers I just think there's
there's more paydays and potentially in
McGregor's mind for probably a lot less
work and a lot less risk you know you
look at boxing compared to MMA no matter
what sport you prefer you can't deny
that there's multiple ways you can win
an MMA fight there's more risk in an MMA
fight than there is especially in the
training side of it for a boxing match
so I there's only one UFC fight left if
he loses to chandeler and that's Nate
Diaz three once that's over with his
legacy is done you've won two titles two
different weight classes give it up but
um if uh if he loses to Chandler even I
think he should just [__] it off and
come all out a misfit immediately who he
who's he calling out though like if he's
there tonight who's he calling out
because there's a lot of options the
biggest fish is Jake Paul in my
opinion not a Misfits fight that's the
problem with it and I was thinking that
exact same thing and when you were
saying it I was thinking the one I'd
want to see is him against Jake Paul but
that's not actually a that wouldn't be
under the Misfits Banner You' assume it
be under it would be so Conor McGregor
won't do anything where he's not a
co-promoter regardless so it'll be UFC
Conor McGregor sports and entertainment
and then MVP but the reason he's there
in my opinion is uh Doone own uh or have
Partnerships with both M Misfit and MVP
uh The Jig Paul one so and he has
sponsored um Anthony Joshua fights
remember when you've seen him down
he sponsor Katy Taylor so Conor's got a
good relationship with already so it all
just fits in like whoever he chooses to
fight he's he's going to fight them no
one's going to turn it's like Floyd
Mayweather if he wants to fight you
everyone says yes don't they um we're in
uh how many rounds are we I think we're
in we're in the fourth round now uh do
you want another drink Joe another
one do you know what I I'll go with
another beer we'll have another beer
I'll have another beer mate anyone want
Dr anyone anyone I'll have a vodka I'm
sorry vodka good one all right we'll
have two vodar um for the boys um I've
got a super chat here for everyone to uh
answer what are our thoughts on the UFC
so we've had two fights fall through
haven't we recently we've got vulcanos
ski andman stepping in what do you think
about that Brian uh I love it I've uh
interviewed Usman once and he was the
one of the coolest Fighters I've ever
talked to and for him to rock up on a
week's notice against Hamza chamaya
who's like the biggest Rising Star Gile
in the UFC and go yeah [__] it and it's
a number one contenders fight and I give
him a good shot and I thought about um
when you were talking about how it's
nice to come in at short
notice um and also Mike bisbing won his
title on short notice like they often
talk about some people just psych
themselves out and just kind of rocking
up and be and having that when you're
like you know what I've been fighting 15
years what do I need a training come for
really um aside from getting fit but a
lot of these guys like laza for example
you're fit 247 especially yeah if you're
a disciplined guy anyway it's a huge
Advantage cuz I'm exactly like that you
you play the fight over your mind you
over and analyze it and before you know
you've drained yourself before you've
even got in there when whereas if you
just rock up and you kind of just fight
generally speaking you have your best
performances sometimes so just depends
how you are but I think most athletes
become over overthinkers because you
know this game's a science now so people
are looking at the nutrition everything
from the strength conditioning to the
sparring where you just walk in there
there's just no pressure like you say
it's it is like playing the lottery it's
just like it's a a chance for you to
perform and if anything you become even
more of a hero if you win on the short
note listen it's a win-win most of the
time you look like a bad [__]
for short if you lose oh well you only
you only had was short notes you weren't
prepared properly but if you win God you
know what I mean and we answering
questions and that's why I love about
that cuz Hamza is uh dangerous and he
really looks like I've I've never seen
someone so dominant so early in the UFC
and if if if if if he beats Usman like
he's beating other people then we know
he's the real deal but if if Usman beats
him well cuz Usman never moved to
middleweight out of respect for Israel
arisna because they had the three kings
the three kings of Africa being Adisa
and ganu and Usman they've all lost
their titles now so Usman because adisan
has taking a break usman's like yeah
[__] it because he has a win over Shan
Strickland Usman so he's going to move
up the middleweight if he beats Hamza
all of a sudden Usman might be a double
champion because I think he's got a
really good chance against Strickland
it's a cool is it to get that big a name
in on such short notice like UFC I'm a
boxing man obviously I'm a casual MMA
fan if anything but um even in boxing
rarely would you ever see that short of
notice a week not a least F not a least
F you get in the law level but not at
Elite level so even then even then this
what does uh sort of play into what we
saying and what favors Usman is like
when we have seen it in boxing I'm sure
there's plenty of times when the
opponent that's been bought in doesn't
win but we look at Andre Ruiz not that
he won the fight but do you remember
when Klitschko got bought in a short
notice against Lennox Lewis I can't
remember who pulled out now but you know
what I mean that was a that was a fight
when he really made his name and put up
a good performance so it does often
favor and in the advantage often is as
well forgetting your preparation the
other guy's been prepared for someone
completely style in it so like it's
sometimes if you've say had a 12we camp
and you've been Tunnel Vision on a
certain style even though you know
you've got that new opponent it's very
hard to switch up with it because you've
been drilling it in your shadow box and
on the pads with your certain sparing
Partners it's very difficult to change
so if anything that's another massive
Advantage you've got as well I wonder if
that there's an element of that with the
AJ helenius fight where you know
obviously we were very critical of how
he was in that fight but he was
preparing for Dylan white you know I
mean I think we mentioned that on the
stream didn't we it's it definitely
plays a part do you know one of the one
of the main differences I'd say there
though is um AJ had sparred loads of
rounds with helenius and I get sparring
is one thing and and that's another
thing but like
I don't know why but almost like knowing
someone and sparring with someone takes
away that first level of like anxiety
emotional investment just because like I
know this guy you know what I mean I
know he's not going to come here and
start throwing tables and whatever like
you know I sort of know this guy is
fairly cool and whatnot um so I do think
when you sparred someone but I don't
know whether Usman and and uh no I I I I
don't believe so um but on the AJ thing
I think that's a good place to actual
talk we're getting a decision here soon
we're seeing the highlights credit to
all these Lads because I tell you what
if there's one thing this card shown us
so far is everyone feels like I've got
to give everything tonight like Prime
card Everyone's Watching and these guys
are literally like there's nothing being
left in the tank so credit to them um in
the AJ thing obviously we seen uh he
didn't have the fight that we were
expecting against helenus like yeah he
got him out of there in the end but it
didn't look great up till then there's
rumors he's going to be training with
the old coach of Tyson f Fury uh Ben
Davidson really he's literally secretly
training with him because Ben got asked
about it in interview heard you training
Anon Joshua and he was like um well it's
not about that tonight and he sort of
but when you're thinking about it if
your goal one day is to fight Tyson Fury
well who knows Tyson Fury better the man
who rebuild him up to the point of where
he's now training with the K Chim and
don't get me wrong he's a different
fighter now but like Ben spent like
lived with Tyson on the and all of that
so and I think the thing with AJ is he's
obviously got kids in the UK being away
in America it's a lot of dedication and
we're not seeing the results of a brand
new and evolved AJ so I think he's
looking for options in the UK and that
looks likely where it'll probably be uh
what do we make of that and also what do
we make of the fact of the Deontay
Wilder fight has since then being Tu
under the well I think it's mental how
you can have like the UFC doing what
it's doing like people jumping in at
late notice of that scale yet in boxing
like we've seen it for years now where
it's just like the big ones just why
don't they get made like realistically
there's going to you know if it's a
matter of a few hundred thousand or
million like MoneyWise like if they want
to fight realistically surely they can
just make it happen so is there is it
that one of these Fighters don't want to
fight I think I think it's done with the
promoters because they've all got
different promoters managers and they
all want to keep a hold of the uh the
guys who are earning the most money so
they like they're all frightened to take
these risks whereas at least with the
UFC they're all under the same Banner um
so it doesn't really I mean the guy
owning the UFC is going to make money
regardless you know what I mean so
whereas you've got the Frank Warren
you've got all these different a lot of
this is down to Saudi so Saudi was
supposed to be footing a huge bill for
Deontay Wilder versus AJ but it looks
like they've gone in the direction of
let's put everything on Fury versus yusk
we're not that bothered about that and I
do think AJ's performances haven't EX L
like the fact that he's barely selling
out the O2 the excitement for Anthony
Joshua is is going downhill rapidly and
that's someone I really like the guy I
think he's a fantastic fighter and he's
done amazing things but it is what it is
right like tonight is going to shatter
anything and Joshua's done for a long
time so and these are kids here do you
know what I mean compared to him like
the Legacy he's got so unfortunately the
great thing about Saudi Arabia is
they're bringing so much money that even
Tyson Fury is willing to fight yusk
right but now people like AJ and wild I
going well we want some of that let's
hold off let's not fight each other
until we get that but the problem is is
you're overestimating your value you're
overestimating the way people see you
when was the last time that AJ had a
stellar performance that everyone raved
about it's been a while same for Wilder
your value isn't what you think it is so
if what you're selling isn't getting
anyone buying in the market then you're
overpriced so I think uh Eddie if he
really I think Eddie what he wants to do
is manage AJ's career and build him up
and cash out with a huge fight if he WI
wins great we've got another one but if
he loses then we know where we are and I
think that they were hoping for Deontay
wild that be that guy but there's been a
that's that's do we not do we not have
to ask a question here what is going on
with Anthony Joshua's training setup if
he does go
B if he does go Ben Davidson that's what
four trainers in fights I'd it feels
like maybe it's while he's in the UK he
F training with him I don't know I don't
know I don't know if Ben will take him
on if he's then going to go back and
train in America with a different
trainer because one of the main things
of why Ben and Tyson split in the first
place was because Tyson said he wanted
to work with Sugar Hill alongside Ben
Davidson and I know this like for
certain I've had this on inside source
like it was because Tyson said he wanted
to work with them alongside each other
obviously Tyson had spent time uh a long
time ago when Emanuel Stewart was still
with us out in the Cronk gym and whatnot
and obviously had obviously met Sugar
Hill through that and Ben Davidson
wasn't happy with it so I don't think
that that's a possibility I think KJ is
either with Ben or he's not with Ben and
actually when we when we look at Ben it
surprises me very much out of um a
loyalty factor that he would train AJ
especially if AJ could potentially then
go and fight Tyson that's mad but I
think when you look at Ben as a trainer
you shouldn't really look at the job he
did with Tyson Fury because Tyson Fury
is Tyson Fury mate like you know what I
mean a lot of the work then without
discrediting Ben is still um the
foundations laid by Peter Fury obviously
but when you look at Ben Davidson as a
trainer you know getting Billy Joe back
into shape lee wood Josh Taylor when he
was boxing with him for a bit he is a
top trainer and I do think he could get
a lot out of Joshua but it does concern
me how many trainers he's going through
now it it comes back to something that
um Loza said years ago about Anthony
Joshua being unsure of himself and I
think the constant changing of his mind
is a problem and when you look like if
you're training with a coach it takes
sometimes years to feel the full effects
of that if you're constantly uh changing
um that could be a problem I think it's
worrying because like you say um this is
just far too many changes like it it
takes time to build a relationship with
a trainer and to fully understand one
another um so yet another change but it
for the fact that if he's if he's going
towards thinking down the line and would
be fighting Fury maybe that does make
sense but um like you say for the
Loyalty side of things I would be
surprised if that does go ahead um but
that yet again Ben might be think you
know what is he left me for was the
Loyalty for me where was the Loyalty for
me so you know what I mean I'll I'll
help I'll go against that though because
there was loyalty for Ben shown in the
first place because Tyson Fury did not
need to give Ben Davidson the
opportunity when Ben Davidson at that
point was known in boxing for uh
coaching Billy Joe Saunders in obviously
the very flat performance we saw from
him that time at the XL I can't remember
who he fought Ben Davidson was not a
name in in boxing around that time Tyson
Fury as brilliant as I think Ben
Davidson is because I really do think
that I've actually been in gyms and and
seen him at work with his Fighters he's
brilliant Ben Davidson but I do think
when you talk about loyalty here Tyson
Fury gave him the opportunity in the
first okay I I think there's some truth
in that for sure like Tyson made Ben
however Ben was literally like nursing
the guy practically when he was in the
throws of his mental health issues yeah
I think more than anything it's probably
like he was a good friend and who helped
who really at the end of the day Ben
also helped him and look where Fury went
from there so you can look at it from
two angles they both benefit they both
benefit so realistically he doesn't all
Tyson nothing really you know what I
mean he helped Tyson look where T is but
in in life you don't need to owe someone
something to show that loyalty to them
do you know what I mean like and I'm not
saying I'm not this is completely
hypothetical none of it might happen but
I think like sometimes if I want to show
loyalty to you it's not it doesn't mean
you I have to owe you something you have
to owe me something sometimes I just
think n come on I've work with him I'm
not going let's flip this let's say down
the road Ben does get another random
heavyweight is Tyson Fury supposed to
not fight that heavy with because Ben
training the game's the game it's like
Jose mourin go goes and manages one team
doesn't mean he's now not going to face
Chelsea or you know man united it's it's
his business in some way I definitely
hear where you're coming from Jo like
emotionally but also I try and put
myself in Ben shoes and think you've got
the chance to say you coached Tyson Fury
and Anthony like he's also got kids to
provide for and a life
to it is tricky to say no to Anthony
Joshua the the only other thing I would
say with it and again like I don't want
to I don't want to be misquoted on this
cuz sounds like I'm talking about
hypotheticals that may never come to
fruition but the relationship between a
fighter and their coach is not purely
okay once we throw the jab we're going
to do this when this happens we're going
to do this a lot of it is like there's
dark times in training camp and and we
know full well the Titan Fury story
there would have been a lot of dark
times there so if I was Tyson Fury I'd
feel very uncomfortable knowing that
inevitably at points I'm going to have
opened myself up emotionally to this man
I'm probably going to have told him
things that maybe I wouldn't tell 99% of
the people in my life and stuff like
this I'd feel very awkward then then or
very uncomfortable then if I then knew
that the my arch rival most who I've
always been on a collision course with
whether it's you know took detour in the
roads he's then going to be working with
him and coached by that person that' be
painful I think I think as well like
when we're talking about the loyal
aspect it is a business at the end of
the day and Ben Davidson knows Fighters
come and go it's like it's not like
they'll have a fighter and that's their
whole career they'll have another career
with every other fighter that comes
through the door so for him and it as
well you talking about loyalty and and
and emotionally side of things and being
loyal to Tyson Fury doesn't earn him a
wage he's got he's got his own family to
like he's got bills to pay wonder if
suar Hill still even training Tyson
after I things Big John's been saying
and even if you look at Emanuel Stewart
which is Sugar Hills is Manuel Stewart's
nephew he he he trained lenx Lewis then
he trained the Klitschko where so like
it happens all the time in boxing if you
look at the history of trainers going
with different guys who fought each
other it's it's nothing Newan M's done
it multiple times exactly so have you
heard what I mean we're going on a day
toour but the mcgan stuff uh about um
what's his Frampton Frampton's books
come out and he's been saying that they'
took money off him and all of that
that's yeah that's that's been known
ages sort of thing but never I didn't
realize the book would come out to say
that yeah there's been a lot of there's
been lot of legal stuff there I bet yeah
it makes you think though because
there's a lot of people saying the same
things you've got to start to think this
must be true so um yeah well that was a
[__] good fight I I didn't even and
see who the [__] went I think it was a
draw it was a draw yeah both both both
hands [__] what were we watching yeah
yeah wasn't this Geer in the middle like
WWE uh yeah coach Jonathan Coachman yeah
yeah that was a good fight though a lot
of people in the chat are saying like
they really enjoyed that
fight f it was very even you know when
you watched both guys it was very
competitive fight we uh we mentioned WWE
there yes I looked up a few numbers
earlier on right and this is this is
crazy because like I think all of us
around this table growing up probably
grew up through that sort of golden
generation of wrestling WWE and and and
the funny thing with Misfits right and
influence of boxing is like the first
place my mind goes to isn't professional
boxing when I'm when I'm drawing
comparisons it's WWE it always goes to
WWE tonight this this fight is projected
to do over a million pay-per-view buers
right that's a million pay-per-view
buers when we know it's on a prime time
in the UK obviously a much smaller
country than America do you know what
the uh record for pay-per-view buyers on
arrest wrl Mania was okay I'm going to
guess I reckon what worldwide what about
if I give you the show it was 2002 the
rock verse Hulk Hogan oh that's going to
be a nice you know like 20 million 1.2
million shut up 1.2 million pay-per-view
by that's the biggest one ever on on the
biggest WrestleMania ever for a bit of
context you like the last WrestleMania
didk This is reported 50k no we 50k AC
two nights to be a lot a lot of them are
subscription based now the w things have
changed a lot remember this is a
subscription base I know they're paying
for the pay-per-view I just mean like
the we scenario is very in the whole
world in the whole world WrestleMania
only did 50,000 yeah but I don't think
that's like a that might be people who
paid for the pay-per-view alone but
everything else they they're on networks
and the W Network and all of that I
think the relevant one to draw a
conclusion to is more the 2002 I hope
you're happy the car no but no but you
know like when we look at pay-per-view
numbers now a lot of people go that's
mad it only did that amount of
pay-per-view numbers allegedly a lot of
people have you know different ways of
watching fights do you know what I mean
so that that's one thing I'd say ties
him with the pay-per-view numbers but it
goes to show how big this fight is in
the grand scheme of things another thing
right Conor Ben against Eubank I'd say I
know it didn't happen but that was
probably the biggest British fight of
the Year wasn't it scheduled in the last
last 12 months that was the biggest one
we had they did a face off roundt ad in
the middle uh Eubank and Conor Ben um
either side and that did 1.5 million
views on YouTube like as of right now
1.5 million is had 12 months to
accumulate that
number KSI against Tommy Fury in three
weeks has done I think it's 3.1 million
Logan Paul against Dylan danis in the
same amount of time has done about 5.6
million so when it when you look at it
and you see like the reach of these
shows is absolutely actually if you now
look at the likes of Tyson Fury and
Anthony Joshua their their faceoffs
their interviews downward down so then
when we say about the Conor McGregor
thing to bring it back to that why would
it not be the better option in a way
like if you can get some sort of
co-promotion he can say right I ain't
taking a flat fee this is my percentage
on the on the show or whatever you would
look at it and you go well if the UFC
can pay you this speaking of numbers
this is a fight I made shout out to me
Bo going through Jord this is a fight
between a guy called my mate n and
werson Nunes the I think my n is one of
the biggest YouTubers in Asia uh he's
moved over there speaks the language got
her wife over there all of that he's a
huge YouTuber with like 20 million Subs
something like that werson Nunes has 40
million YouTube subscribers he's got
more than KSI and Logan Paul put
together or something like that like
it's absolutely insane how popular these
two guys are like if so the idea is if
winderson wins this fight and it's very
closely matched I'm it's not like I
expect him to win it's like I I I bet on
him to win but it could go either way um
wierson will be setting up a mega fight
in Brazil next year where they'll
probably try and do a stadium in [__]
Rio de Janeiro or something like that
they'll sell it out they it'll be
absolutely Mega because he is one of the
most famous people in Brazil like he's
uh he's a comedian a musician so
everything we see from the likes of a
KSI he does all of that over there why
did he match them up like stylistically
uh they both lost to King Kenny who's
fighting later on and the card and they
both um showed good things like wierson
is kind of like an MMA Style
Muay Tha boxer he kind of leaves his
chin out to bait you in and then pulls
counters and whereas Nate's got a good
job on him and I'm like you know what I
think you you guys should have a close
fight and I I I couldn't like guarantee
that guy could win so it's a good
50/50 uh but also in terms of followers
according to a guy uh according to one
of my mates Wade um shout out Wade he um
has a friend who knows about the social
media analytics and they said that the
face these two guys did was viewed when
you talk about numbers this is a number
apparently 840 million um Impressions uh
were done on that face off something
along those lines so like because you're
covering South America and Asia this is
arguably the biggest fight if you get
what I mean like in terms of eyeballs
there'll be more people that care about
this it might not be as passionate as
the main event but it's [__] huge and
um and winderson uh um particularly has
something uh special about him to be
fair already winderson showing more head
movement showing when he threw the jab
then he got then back out of range two
things that he was doing majorly
standing right in front of King Kenny in
his last fight the thing I really
impressed me about him against King
Kenny obviously he got the he got the
dog [__] beaten out of him uh but
Kenny's very high level got a brother
who trains Pro fighter as so you know
Kenny's evolved extremely quickly and
werson only have I think this is like
his third fight maybe fourth um but the
thing about winderson that impressed me
was he stayed in Kenny's face the whole
time and and never like you know when
you're getting a beaten like that and
there's people around this table that no
like you guys have been in the ring you
know how hard it is to stay with it and
just keep a brave face and and keep
going and I I seen enough to go you're
going to go away and learn after this
you're not a [__] by any means you're
hard as nails but I don't know um he
he's definitely trying to utilize good
head movement there for this level of
fighting especially he he definitely has
all the ingredients he just he simply
was just outmatched like King Kenny was
just a level above that's all it was
Kenny was looking like [__] Eubank in
there was he yeah he was looking good to
be fair I think like what you're seeing
my mate Nate do that maybe he well what
Kenny did that worked was jab and keep
moving forward jab and and dictate takes
enter a ring what my mate n is doing
here is he's going away and I feel like
that is what plays into Nunes that's why
he looked good in his first fight M and
it's that that I feel you need to nfy
stop Nunes feeling like he's going have
Center ring yeah if Nate doubles that
jab up and like gets a bit more
aggressive he might be able to do a
little bit of a job on him but he's so
far he's I think but winderson hasn't
really thrown a lot of power shots yet I
feel like it's more about doubling it as
you step forward as well though because
you can double it off the back foot but
that's one thing that King Kenny has
over a lot of the YouTubers I think um
if you look at all aspects of King
Kenny's games there's a lot of things
that other YouTubers and other
influencers that box on these cars do a
lot better than him but in terms of the
jab stiff jab like good good stiff jab
moves forward with it and I think that's
probably his biggest strength and I
think that actually is so underrated
isn't it like they say the right hand
can take you around the block but the
jab take you around the world and that's
one thing is with a lot of the YouTubers
it's they don't know how no I look at it
and I'm like yeah but what do you like
against the jab so actually I do think
that my mate Nate is uh game plan wise I
think I think he's doing quite well here
in I like his job for sure
um but werson doesn't look too phased by
it and what winderson he's got solid
head movement he he loves digging those
body shots in um but he's too for this
he's carrying a little bit of extra
weight so I think the guys he fights
unfortunately are kind of they're going
to be they're going to have longer arms
they're going to have that reach on him
um but that was a really solid like
technically for this level that was a
really good best we've seen so the thing
I get from him like he's his head
movement's good um he he's his defense
is pretty good but his feet are slow and
I feel as if he hasn't got that Spite he
kind he's kind of just happy to make
your Miss come back with the odd shot he
do he's got no real aggression in him
like even when he lost against King
Kenny he didn't look really upset about
it he just like oh well you know sugly
shoulders it is what it is like he
hasn't got that fire in his belly um and
some of this is down to like how rich
can you be and still have the dog in you
like this man is rich rich Marvin hler
said it he says it's hard to get the
morning uh hard to get up for the runs
in the morning wear silk pajamas yeah
don't know if I said that exactly right
but along them lines yeah he he what he
doesn't want to do is give up another
round like this though like he kind of I
think he kind of got outstruck there I
was really impressed by my mate Nate in
that round yeah I I thought I was very
impressed by him stuck to it well he's
going need good cardio because I mean it
takes a bit less cardio to cut off the
ring than it does to work on the
outskirts like that but I think if you
can keep this up I think that the game
plan's working well and if you're going
to see any man have to go through the
gears it's obviously going to be Nunes
yeah you're right about the Feit though
he definitely need need to Clause that
distance now um we're running a poll at
the moment and the majority of people
are voting for Nunes to win so keep your
votes coming in it it he he he makes him
Miss and then doesn't make him pay for
yeah it's almost like what I feel like's
happen he's looked at the king Kenny
fight and gone I just kept getting hit
because my head didn't move so he's
mastered his head movement but he's not
following up he's not actually gone
right what do I do after that on once I
have made him Miss oh here we go there
we go just as I say that yeah he's
definitely not punishing him enough but
he uh um and because Nate's got the
longer legs and the longer arms he's
getting out of the way and then he's
getting his off and then getting out of
the way and borderline looks too
comfortable you know what I mean you
he's just kind of not bothered you're
like
yeah it's he's in there with a kid who's
like who he's just kind of moving around
with it's like man this is a real
[__] fight you know you better win
this whole thing of not uh that whole
thing of looking too comfortable though
does come from not respecting your
opponent and and and when I say not
respecting obviously the anal the
terminology sorry for that is in a
different way to in life it's not about
not respecting him but it's like when
I'm in there with someone who I think
yeah you're going to land some Jabs
you're going to land some straight shots
but I will get you I will get you you're
not going to hurt me yeah yeah you you
don't pay him that sort of respect
because you know at some point your
time's going to come and you're going to
flip the fight on his head and I'm not
saying that's going to happen but that
looks not he's hammering the body now
even even like Mike Tyson you know he
looked like he was Fearless but he had
that fear when you when you get
interviews now you've got to have a
little bit of fear to give you that
little bit of edge that bit of sharpness
um does keep you sharp yeah
yeah he loves those body almost like he
he does a lot of sparring and you know
when you get that sparing partner
mentality where you're just kind of
doing the rounds you're not really
trying to win them that's what I feel
like Del Boy is like nowadays oh without
doubt yeah well like you used to spoil
the cital and all them you should have
seen him the other day wait what Del
booy Derk chora he's in a [__]
interview with El Brook oh is this the
choking thing and and El Brook's been
getting El Brook's been getting choked
out as like a thing like a gimmick cuz
as you do as you do well you know she's
up for a laugh right so Dylan danis
chokes her out and like um and anyway it
goes viral becomes a bit oh good good
shot from there it goes a bit it becomes
a bit of a meme and then Derek starts
talking um to her and he's like oh so
you're like getting choked there like
and you know when Derek like looks her
in the eyes and you can see he's
thinking all kinds of dark and I'm like
just get out of there alive will you um
cuz you know D actually means big
[__] Francis and garu style hand
around her throat no but like I think he
held her there for I can't I didn't see
the full clip but it you're like okay
mate um he's a bit dodgy and then then
there was talk about she was saying like
you want to come on my only fans he'd do
it he wants just that yeah 100% I reckon
he would go on only fans and
shag 100% 100% wait he had only fans on
his oh yeah stuff last time does he
already do it yeah Brian you're in the
shadow Council can you sort that out
work on it would you do only fans
definitely not say anyone around the
table no one oh anyways uh would you no
no
no no no no I wouldn't what do we think
of this Boke Anthony pry boy
it was a quick one what do we do we
think that um we've got two clear rounds
there in that
fight my I I don't know he's not he's
not he's he's not really Landing
anything I think I tell you what nunes's
nose is bright red right now all yeah
yeah he's and whereas my main8 doesn't
look like he's taking that much damage
so far I'm just
saying was Landing those body shots in
that's all I will say I think he might
have outlined I I think he's got two
rounds here personally I thought nun had
a much better around in that second
round and obviously listen boxing is
subjective it depends a lot of the time
what the judge is like if you like the
man that's moving forward and almost in
some people's eyes trying to make a
fight out of it you probably score the
second one to Nunes that's not
necessarily saying I would but I tell
you what if it does stay in this mold
come the end of four rounds my mate Nate
would be thinking oh my God thank God
for that you know that went exactly how
I would have wanted it
to why is why is he not thrown to the
chin though he he's not thrown like when
you watch wierson you can't of like you
have got some skills there you just
don't really know how to put it together
yet Brian you you made this fight what
um other influences would we know that
are these guys Waits cuz I'd love to see
my mate Nate win or lose in there with a
lot more of the guys that uh that fight
on these shows yeah I think they're 175
so that would be J swingler and Nissan
Gibb uh obviously Kenny and um they not
165 uh
175 um okay yeah um he's boxing pretty
well he he does all the right things
doesn't
he yeah okay so true Jordy are there any
other fights that you've got in your
like fantasy that you would like to
bring to life that's on a DI it's on his
only F we're talking about El versus
jaar
no yeah no I'm talking about serious
boxing right so is there any others that
you want to say actually uh Gibble uh
the winner of Kenny and um and to Y okay
so as a Misfits man do you know if Gibb
is allowed to fight on Misfits because
isn't there beef uh I've spoken to Ms
and he would want to make that I think
Ms is the kind of person where In the
Heat of the Moment he might say things
but like you know Vince McMahon how he
does what's best for business Ms will
always sort of to that good business and
good numbers are override personal
[__] to one side make the fight
right and
also Gibb is just so good you can't deny
him like he's top five in my opinion of
of the the Hall of influen of boxing
right now so who beats him uh who can
beat him who do you think can beat him
uh can beat him or or will beat him in
your opinion can uh I think uh I think
the obvious ones like Logan Jake uh KSI
you think Logan beats Gib I think could
beat him uh I suggested to Logan ages
ago when I did a reaction with him to
the Mayweather fight I said why don't
you fight someone like a Gibb for your
first comeback fight in was like Gibb
I'd smoke Gibb and I was like Gibb's
really good though and since then Gibb
has proven he's really good you know
because I was saying things in the gym
at West Ham with him and I was like I
know that so then he went and smashed um
uh what's his name uh the the dad family
dad thing what's his name Austin mcbr
yeah's yeah sorry he smashed him he beat
Jarvis Comfort comfortably and jvis is
solid yeah man he's good technically z
um and Gibb just has a really
well-rounded game and I think that he is
like a legit opponent for any of these
guys like there's no one I'd go in there
and go I I wouldn't feel aside from Jake
Paul because it's happened before but I
think Gibbs improved Leaps and Bounds
since then loads so Jake so is Jake yeah
yeah and so J so you know how he said
stars make fights I think the Gibb Style
versus Logan PA is all wrong for Logan
PA oh really I would I personally Just
For What It's Worth I'd make give a
favorite in that I think it's a really
it's a great show because it just makes
the fight more exciting that people
believe that you want a fight where it's
doubt but the problem with Logan Paul is
is he fought JJ years ago and then he's
fought Mayweather since and you can't
put anything under the Mayweather fight
cuz you're like okay you've proven
you've got skills like as in but you
can't judge Logan Fairley when he's in
there against the best in the world but
you know the problem how much more do we
find out after tonight well we don't
know how good Dylan is but I think we
get at least an answer of like so this
is the first fight Logan's fought where
he's the heavy favorite 50/50 with SI
definitely not expected to do anything
against Floyd the fact that he survived
against Floyd is a massive bonus this is
the first fight where we're like put him
to sleep so we're going to find out how
much boxing has he been doing you know
he's not been in the boxing World been
flying through the air in the we miss he
potentially could have gone backwards
really he's actually had a major knee
injury and major knee surgery and if
there's one thing we all know is
bouncing around in the ring takes a lot
on your knees so I think that's another
thing of like seeing how mobile but in
the we I must admit what an athlete
unbelievable I think in terms of
athleticism he may be the best athlete
in the whole show tonight yeah certain
looks it he look he looks it I just
don't know how you can be like learning
to be a WWE athlete I think like
especially while he's learning the
recovery he must need must be like they
must say like you're going to train this
hard you're going to get so battered
that you must take these days doing
nothing you can't then just go and train
boxing seriously cuz that will batter
you as well it's like can can he really
when he claims he's been like training
all this time I don't know how legit
that can be I'm not expecting to see
Logan do things completely different
here night because he's training with
the same coach he's had that Milton Milt
he's also his
Gardener he
is Proclaim he is his G Milton's such a
cool guy but the weirdest thing about
Milton is they've sort of adopted him
into the family and and Milton's like
cool with it because Milton's obviously
getting a good wage but also Milton
trained a world champion boxer he
trained Shannon Briggs right or
something like that right so um Milton's
actually like legit as [__] but Milton
has a a very specific style which Tony
Jeff did a video with him about about
the Lan style and why that gives you
advantages and so so I don't I think
we're going to see Logan come out with
his hands down but but this is a
spiteful aggressive angry Logan so he's
in theory should be going out there put
on a show and make a statement so that
everyone goes oh we want to see Logan
again against a credible opponent
what who is that yeah that maybe who do
we do you think Gibb is the the best guy
I I would say for the fans to watch a
fight yes but I think for Logan Paul no
because what does he gain out of he
wants the big names he wants a big name
it's got to make sense I think if
anything he may be a little bit
traumatized from doing boxing again are
you like what he's that to go through
from all of this he's probably like I
don't have to do this and when when he
gets asked why are you doing this he
says for Prime I'm doing it just that's
why it's the only reason doing it cuz I
want to grow Prime it's like is his
heart really in one box that that that's
my worry about all of these guys because
if you're Misfits right you've just
signed a 5year deal with done that deal
is I need to keep providing great events
like this one so that done want to keep
on um oh wion's really uh coming good
now um it looks like I don't could be
wrong this the last 10 seconds of the
fight okay um it might have been a bit
too late could be a draw here guys I
thought it was fairly equal the last two
rounds so it could very easily be a draw
I feel that my main eight he won the
first I would say he edged it he won he
definitely won the first two for me the
the fear with these big guys is if they
all at one point go yeah we've had
enough of this now [__] me what the [__]
do Misfits do yeah like because the real
the reality is is they need to and we're
talking about this behind the scenes is
like growing the stars out but like it
you can only grow people so far right
like you can't reinvent another KSI Jake
Paul Logan Paul there's only three of
them MH and that's it um so you know
when KSI took those two three years off
whatever it was after fighting Logan he
was burned out he lost his passion for
the sport wanted to do music if that
happens again well then the show that
could happen after tonight that could
very easily and this is what is is so
Mega about tonight is the outcomes like
if if KSI wins maybe Jake Paul comes out
the audience you got a face off the hype
is 10 through the roof or if he loses in
bad fashion he might go ah [__] this
what am I doing but this is this is
exactly what's happening in pro boxing
do you know we talking about these
Wilders the furies the Anthony joshuas
all these promoters are terrified of
their guy losing in cuz they carry the
spot they do like Anthony Jos carried it
yeah for the last how since 2012 after I
think it was 2013 by the time he turned
Pro he carried boxing until his recent
year losses so the minute he's gone box
and dies and then they've had like then
obviously Fury Wilder kind of kept
things up there and then once they kind
of disappeared a little bit like you
need the big names and once the goal the
sport essentially does die but with with
boxing when we look at that right it's
not just the inactivity of the fighters
that are still active and still boxing
it's also like you look at that crop of
Fighters especially from Britain like
when we were we were younger sort of
thing or through our growing up you like
you've got B you've got hay you've got
all these names here FR Groves like I
could go on list of Fighters that have
now retired that other Fighters need to
come and take them the mantle but the
only way to take the mantle is by being
in big fights and if the big fights
aren't getting put on it's very hard but
the good thing with Misfits here like we
were saying okay yeah KSI and Logan Paul
and Jake Paul they could all step away
from it but the thing is they came into
this sort of foundation of boxing
through being big names whereas now the
system's in place to make people big
names through fights I've got a bit of
an update guys on the Logan Paul injury
from the the microphone that was spiked
off of him okay uh we're just going to
find out who's won though
um we're we're we're hearing the results
now won's got his hand up he got to be n
surely can someone let us know not
is here we
go I think it's close it sound could
unanimous decision it must be Nate then
yes well done Nate fair play I think
wion's been found out a little bit in
terms of he didn't really make the
adjustments into the last fight with the
job he didn't deal with it it doesn't
mean everything but Nate hasn't got a
mark on I you know it is I think he's
going to kick himself again because it's
he what let him down is his Fitness his
cardio's not there like as soon as he
got to the second third round he was
really you look tired wait is is it true
that that he was smoking this week oh
probably I heard Wade say that yeah
won's a Brazilian though right so go
going back to the Logan injury right we
got guys who shared the ring here
boxers how bad is that pre fight if that
is that a is that just a scratch is that
actually it looks quite
deepest it's more the black guy as well
that is just a more of like a surface
Graz because that wouldn't look like
that if it was actually a cut you what
about the black eye doesn't black gu is
not could he not wor than it is I tell
you the worst thing here would be if
that was above the eye if that was above
the eye then we got a problem because
that opens up pretty soon uh Dylan danis
can open that up in the first round and
it doesn't affect his vision it doesn't
affect his performance what it might
affect is how he's carrying himself
emotionally and and whatnot but in terms
of actually affecting his performance I
don't think that does and the other
thing as well is like even if it's
bruised right we were saying about
adrenaline it's one hell of a drug mate
trust me like you might you might still
feel broken bones but you don't feel
black eyes of adrenaline the only the
only thing that you would get is which
if if it was to keep getting hit it
might swell up a bit quicker you know if
it was if he was getting repeat damage
but in terms of that you know like when
you spawn and you you you rub the ropes
you get them kind of like what friction
I think so but um but yeah but if he's
fighting with one eye does that make him
like a massive impact to fight so say
for instance it does swell up in the
first round does that not massively
impact he's not in a position to be able
to swell up and block his vision it's
here it's here it's not going to swell
up and block his vision it needs to be
there or there just it's not anywhere
Orit all like I'm relieved at that cuz I
don't want any excuses I don't want any
issues uh KSI is on our screens now the
next fight I believe is Anthony Taylor
versus King Kenny king Kenny uh flying
high after a big win over winderson um
although he may like my point when when
Kenny beat werson in the style and the
fashion he did was yeah but the guy in
front of you was nowhere near the level
and that Victory flattered you and
Anthony Taylor is a hard noosed little
bastard you know and he's going to keep
coming forward and if you don't have the
the power to really hurt wierson when
he's a Sitting Duck like that are you
going to have enough to keep um a off
you yeah and he's used to he runs at you
you know mean that's it's a to is he
how's he going to be under pressure when
keep off the jab when you got a man
standing with the foot like stuck in the
mud you know what I mean it's easy but
this is going to be a different I'm
quite interested to see how he's going
to react to be I I kind of feel like
we've seen that King Kenny's got the
ability to learn like the way he's
developed so quickly is amazing and I I
believe the tactics that will be in play
from his coach who is a very very good
coach daily right I I believe they would
have figured out how to deal with the
sort of bullish yeah buing M
mean the only worry is did you say the
rxu fight he ran away from RX but when
was that that that's that was the fight
before wierson yeah but that I feel like
time time has lapsed now he would have
improved IE I think like he yeah I I
can't see itat but the reason look I'm
sure that they've worked on getting him
used to someone running at him but there
was there was two questions in my head
of mhm when it really is getting there
and someone's putting when you're the
hammer when you're the nail and not the
hammer like it's all what like he when I
look at people who style and profile on
like fighters who are Sitting Ducks in
front of them but then when a guy's
running around the ring with zero
technique like rxu does not have good
technique but he's got power and you're
avoiding him in that way I'm like you
can't style and profile and humiliate a
guy and then run when it's your time to
stand up to the fight yeah so that's why
I'm a bit I've seen that in him now and
I can't say it I
can't so I need to see him do the
opposite I need can he stick with it
when the go gets exactly and until he
does that I'm always going to remember
that when someone put it on you you
didn't want to be there and when you
were in a situation where you could have
gotten a guy out of there quite easily
you didn't have the power and you kind
of just you weren't willing to like gas
yourself to really hurt him and finish
him so I'm waiting to see the next
Evolution from Kenny and a being that at
has been in there
with um Tommy Fury he went the decision
with Tommy Fury four rounds he's he
spared Jake Paul he spaed Logan Paul and
the interesting story about Logan is and
this is what gives me a little bit of
well quite a bit of confidence against
Dylan is at is a tough guy he's tough
he's can tell uh BJ Flores was in the
gym one day where Logan Paul and Logan
Paul told me about this and that I was
like wow okay but then BJ was like no I
was there turned up with a hangover
spoed uh a and beat the [__] out of him
and put him down within the first round
and that was when I was like okay well
what we're seeing from you against Floyd
maywe that isn't really what you are
like you are actually a good boxer for
this level you get that in boxing though
like you get people who are great in the
gym but can you do it in front of the
bright lights that's that's the
difference and that's I think Tommy's
like that you know in some of the best
fighters in in my personal experience
I've been around guys who are like
excellent in the gym not so good in the
ring on on when the lights are there and
guys I've seen get beat up in the gym
but on the Night On fight night they
just you know what I mean that's my
Tommy perform and I know that people
might think I'm a bit delusional but
like when you watch Tommy against uh
Jake Paul yes he was the better boxer he
was caught many of times he was very
nervous he he was he cried at the
decision because he was so relieved of
all the pressure that had been on his
shoulders tonight in front of 20,000
people what this this is like what KSI
does like whether it be music or boxing
he will walk out there just like in the
zone Flo three like for for this for KSI
this is as close as anyone can get to
being absolutely comfortable Under The
Lights like he will be far more
comfortable in there than Tommy will and
there was a moment and I don't know what
you guys make of this but the the the
face off they did after the weighin when
Tommy is in that uh cage and Tommy is
boom boom and he's actually screaming
[__] you and there was a point where I
thought this guy's ran out of breath
he's so exhausted from screaming at KSI
and I'm like you know if you're really
confident you're going to knock someone
out you don't act like that like
ultimately if you're not intimidated by
someone like you don't feel the need to
do something to try and level it and it
it seemed very much like he's being
triggered he out stressed and he felt
like he needed to do something the Apple
doesn't fall far from the tree look what
his dad it's almost like this is all
he's seen from being a young man this is
I I don't even feel like he's his own
person he's he's almost like a puppet
like he's just copying what he's always
made a good point there to be fair he
does feel like a bit of a puppet well he
did most of the time he sometimes he
gets asked a question he kind of looks
around as if say is anyone going to
answer for me then John pops up when he
doesn't answer and it's just like but at
the same time what I do think he's
probably learned and probably matured
from that last fight with Jake Paul
because to be honest I think the
pressure there was far greater than it
is for this fight so if anything that
was like his first big test in terms of
emotionally how he was going to deal
with it and I think this time he
actually looks more confident yes he's
shouting a lot more but I feel like he
is a lot more conf for this fight than
he was in the previous fight yeah I
agree I agree with that for sure and I
think like I mean the whole buildup to
this whether it be the face to face even
all the the little the face off he won
Yeah Yeah by a mile and then all these
other sort of buildup bits of content
that Misfits have been putting out he
seems so relaxed and composed and like
matter of fact like yeah obviously I'm
the profession I I I agreed until that
moment when he was panting yeah and I
was like [__] me you're going to need an
inhaler here some and then when the
camera cut the KSI he's like ladies and
gentlemen it's KSI and he just all of a
sudden I was like oh that's the KSI that
I'm used to seeing like uber cool
confident he was in his floor State
Tommy's acting like I R I'm not used to
saying Tommy like this uh we got A's
entrance here with a bunch of only fans
girls and he's wearing pink he comes up
with a cowboy hat on it looks
mental they're all TW what is going on
I'm not mad at it it's fair true J's
dream there's certain
that have so founds on Misfit Anthony
Taylor is one of them John Fury is
another one of them you know I mean like
there's certain characters that maybe
weren't real um like you know real draws
in boxing or whatever or or or yeah real
contenders but in this Misfits World
they have found their feet Anthony
Taylor is definitely one of them if he
was a boxer like professional main
fighter whatever he was none of us know
him but he Misfits he he's a ticket
seller he sells the show and he he's
very much at home here yeah you know he
knows what he's doing he knows how to
play at the crowd he's he looks very
comfortable in this environment he's
he's born for the start the spotlight
but my only thing is is his entrance is
far more entertaining than his fights
his fights he stifles he hugs and and
that might help him in this fight though
I I against Sal papy I was like oh my
God I cuz I was hoping to see some more
highlight reaction from Sal papy but he
fought a really smart fight and I
wouldn't be surprised if he does a
similar thing against Kenny but when
when you look at it right to to see the
other side of that right I think one of
the biggest um things you can have going
in your favor as a fighter is to know
what you're good at and to know what
you're not really good at and if Anthony
Taylor thought you know what everyone
might like to see me use the jab a
little bit more than that overhand right
that I seem to throw whenever someone
comes in if if everyone lik to see me
try and be on my toes a little bit more
yeah okay you might be pleasing uh
pleasing the crowd But ultimately you're
not playing to your strengths so I think
one of the best things Anthony Taylor
has going in his way and I think we see
him do that again again in this fight as
he did against salt papy is he knows
what his strengths are and if it's
spoiling he spoiling cuz at the end of
the day your record just says win if if
you get that win agreed and one
interesting fact is and this is a little
bit of Insider stuff um Kenny's lot they
didn't fancy this the most I'm not
saying they they didn't fancy it or they
didn't think he could win cuz they're
here they thought he could win but it
wasn't their preferred option because of
the style and the just the hustle that
Kenny uh sorry that at brings right um
so I think they're well aware in Kenny's
camp that this isn't um an easy fight
you know so wait so as a small council
member how do Shadow government get it
right how do you know if someone's not
really fancy in a fight like can like
what what tips it off I mean there's
just a bit of chat in the group about
what's happening with negotiation oh
does it come out are they basically like
yeah basically but but but but I'm not
saying that Kenny didn't want to fight
he it wasn't their first choice who was
there's a difference I can't remember if
I'm being honest um it's it's not that
deep but Kenny's here he's happy to
fight it's certainly not a case of the
guy was scared of anything like that it
was just like I think that there's
certain styles that they're cleverly
aware of that would be better for him at
for me is the hardest fight for Kenny if
if Kenny does what he's been doing we're
kind of looking at a new St because he's
with B Squad who are a massive group on
YouTube they like the siden um and and
they're going to have their backing
behind him so they can help the
pay-per-views and stuff and but also the
guy can fight that's obvious and I feel
like in terms of ones to watch an
evolving is there there's not many
people who have improved as much as
Kenny oh he he by far is the stand out I
believe obviously KSI is another one him
and Gibb for me are the natural ones to
meet after this uh if if he wins yeah
that's a but I I want Kenny to win
because I'm I'm very much team YouTube
tonight rather than the pros
and I still View at like at fought Tommy
Fury before he was even in Misfits he
went four rounds with him what didn't
look great but he Tommy looked [__] in
that fight I'm being do you not think
this is one of the things that massively
goes under the radar and this is one of
the reasons I hold simpathy for Tommy
Fury at times is because his surnames
Fury everyone straight away would go
well he's the pro boxer he's the one
that's been doing it all his life I
don't even know how old Anthony Taylor
is but I can tell you what if I had to
put my money on it now my last penny on
it now he's been doing it since just as
young if not younger than Tommy Fury has
but people but people don't immediately
cast their mind and go this fell almost
shouldn't sort of be in there with
YouTube It's almost like because he acts
all silly and acts almost like a
YouTuber it's like oh yeah he's not he
fits it perfectly yeah yeah yeah there's
an element of that but yeah a pro MMA
fighter right yeah for sure and a pro
boxer MH so and that's another thing
when we talk about Tommy here to go back
to it is like look at the look at the
struggle that everyone's H with Anthony
Taylor in comparison to what Tommy did
with him oh by the way oh no uh Logan
did a um Instagram story and it's quite
clear that his his face is really
swollen around here um you can see uh
there guys he's got he's got some he's
got makeup on he's got makeup on there
but who does it looks
lighter but his eyes are
glowing I I think this is going to have
a significant impact on the fight today
cuz let's be honest guys you've been in
the ring right how how do you target
someone like that do you just go
straight for it if you know someone's
got an injury do you just go absolutely
balls the wall to be a lot more equipped
to to answer this question than myself
but I don't really Target anything I
just think let me lay hands on him I
have a little box and I think whether it
hits him on the eyebrow the chin the the
cheek I don't care I'm trying to aim
into that Target have you have you ever
fought anyone that had like a clear
injury oh dur during fights is I mean if
you you see a little bit of swelling I
mean if you don't notice that your
corner say keep dabbing away at that eye
because you know that's going to
eventually before the fight even started
well it's it's very rare that you see
that much damage leading into a fight
generally speaking Fighters are normally
quite careful to wear the right
protective equipment and stuff like that
so we're almost underway here and we're
out oh Taylor runs out and Sprints by
the way guys uh Logan Paul has arrived
with his fiance looking lovely in our
dress so she's showing out she's like
yeah I'm [__] here loud proud oh my
God exactly what you were saying ready
King Kenny's looking very uncomfortable
but if youve done your homework that's
what you would say run at him make them
uncomfortable and this is the thing um
his his big brother said his inside
fighting is a lot better than people
would think well we're going to find out
but when you've got an MMA guy who
literally run at you with the head Lords
like yeah I think stylistically when you
look at King Kenny you're going to
assume that he's only going to be better
at range but there's certain Fighters
like Callum Smith comes to my mind
straight away good inside fighter I
experienced that a long time ago oh
really yeah
I was on GB the first time I I was quite
new to the GB set at the time and he was
boxing at 75 kilos the we below me I
thought I'll get in there I'll just out
strength him I kind of got on top of him
and I couldn't believe how good he was
inside he was catching with shots which
I just wasn't expecting so I went
actually I'm going to have to box a
little bit here I used to think that
yeah but he's he's excellent how are
your arms so long and you're squeezing
body shots it's weird the way he does it
but he's really effective on the inside
see Kenny needs to get that jab going
but he's almost I feel like tentative to
let his hands go because yeah like
Anthony just runs in like that and
there's a difference between being good
on the inside when you've got a guy
who's kind of just standard but a guy
who's running in like a rugby player is
a little bit different is that is that
the it's a five round fight guys it's
for a title all the title fights are
five round as aside from the two main
events or a six rounders so for for A8
to keep a pace up where you're
constantly running he's carrying quite a
lot of muscle there I mean you'd assume
he's trained for it but it's it's a lot
Kenny's trying to push him off right now
and to keep it at range but when it is
at range Kenny isn't even throwing the
jab he's out of his game plan
immediately he's almost anticipating the
running he doesn't even want to throw a
jab in case he misses the guy running in
yeah this isn't what Kenny's team
probably want H for a first round but I
mean it's not like A's done Maj damage
but um the referees separating them and
trying to turn it into a boxing match
good luck with that it's always harder
though against a smaller guy because the
the general public will look and they'll
go well you got to throw your jab yeah
but the smaller guy has fought the
taller guy way more than the taller guy
has fought the smaller guy in sparring
and whatnot and when you look at that
you can throw that jab out there but if
he comes to your stomach which most of
them are going to sit under the jab and
come to your body if he does that you
got two options you either take another
body shot or you bring your arms down
and when you do that you know Anthony
Taylor's going to look to loot that
right hand over the top so it can be a
lose lose at times unless you can stop
him in his tracks with that jab yeah
you're 100% right there is this a see
you right we're got in the referee
talking Lads how long before we might
see a point deducted here do you think
that's an issue or a point for what
would you say well holding and clinching
rather than boxing what I will say is I
think Taylor's looking a little bit
tired already he looks like he's
suffering more for the pace that he's
tried to set so be interested come the
second round how he comes out oh um he's
yeah he's jumped on the on the rops
there as if it's a we celebration I mean
I'd probably give that at round one and
that's the game he plays he's not trying
to knock you out he's trying to win the
rounds yeah is that so he did did MMA do
you know if he was like a Grappler or a
striker I think he was a wrestler
because what we're seeing here is he's
deploying those sort of tactics he's
just going let me just grab you and just
hold look at him that little thick
neck like a wrestler he's never been a
standup guy has that's why it's amaz him
with those short little arms that he's
actually making a go of it yeah I mean
and he he he goes four rounds with Tommy
Fury TR with and the thing is as well
when he's getting up close like that
those shots to the body that's what can
really like that takes it out of you
that takes your confidence that you know
what I mean it's those shots that we as
a viewer can't really see too clearly
but when you're when he's that bullish
in there like Kenny will be feeling that
I just had a flashback though when you
had um Connor Ben hitting you with body
shots mhm I remember I remember that
yeah how was that lad uh oh round two
started and they're going at it again
[__] 100,000 miles an hour Jesus Oh
left hook oh my god oh oh a is actually
doing some work now and and Kenny's
holding on to his arms when we were
talking about uh Anthony Taylor's old
career obviously in MMA it's crazy to
see him fighting guys like King Kenny
cuz do you remember what weight he was
fighting at in MMA competing at about
14750 or something yeah when you're
against wrestlers yeah I mean he he he's
a yeah he's a featherweight for sure
this was at 170 tonight wasn't it 175 I
think they both weighed in under 170
though uh looking if if I was to stand
up next to Anthony Taylor he's taller
than me but he's not not that much
bigger you know what I mean so to see
him in there with these sort of guys
it's m he was in there with Tommy can
you that's I'm saying hold your hands up
and go Fair 5 seven I think he was that
and and it's that [__] Dome head of
his it's so hard to hurt plants the
cranium on the chest and just and I
almost feel like when you come from a
background where you have got experience
over some of the influencers that don't
it's the commendable thing to do is go
straight in there and go all right well
I'll take hard fights then I'll give a
bit of weight away I'll give something
away in my advantage and you can't say
that he hasn't done that so far in the
resume he's got yeah he's kind of built
like that you know volkanovski in the
UFC he's built like that like he used to
be a massive dude before he cut down as
well we've just seen Eddie Hearn come
into the uh The Crowd by no way yeah
Eddie Hearn is there look see him my God
how EDD Hearn feel this is interesting
cuz was he not before this fight just
saying that YouTuber boxing is dead and
that it's over so he slagged it off and
then he retracted that went only Kingpin
actually I love misfitz because D are
his partners and he has I reckon he got
told off for that cuz he was saying how
much he hates it and but yeah it's
directly his you know business almost
but then naturally you'll see the
figures and start he he's he's
IG it's actually quite embarrassing for
Eddie right now cuz if you think about
the cash cows Eddie Eddie Hearn has so
AJ's on the way down Connor Ben his
career has been in absolute turmoil for
the last year and if you look at his
other big stars lost Canelo he lost
Canelo none of his other stars or even
AJ and any of them pull in these kind of
figures so he's the he support he was
employed by Doone as the expert in
boxing to and I'm not saying he hasn't
put on a great calendar like the lee
wood fight the other night was epic
[__] unbelievable we loved it but
Eddie her must be like [__] H these
make them Mak look bad the other thing
as well is when Eddie was with Sky he
was the exclusive promoter so it's not
to say you ever saw a show from another
Promoter on a sky card but if you did it
had to have the okay by Eddie and we
almost were led to believe that that was
going to be the way with the Zone then
Oscar De La Hoya gets involved obviously
Misfits gets involved then a few of the
other influencer boxer type things and
actually now you're seeing it where his
his importance in the company a little
bit is diminishing but what I would say
to to sort of defend Eddie a little bit
there is when we're saying the the
comparison of numbers that's not just
with Eddie stable you know that's with
all boxing really isn't it it is but
when you look at what Eddie's going
through when that Frank Warren all of a
sudden is now the best mate of Saudi
Arabia and he's making these Mega fights
with Tyson Fury you've got a guy in
Mom's Taylor who's never been a boxing
promoter before this is now doing events
like this and and doing bigger numbers
than what Eddie is so Eddie was the king
Undisputed King pper viw and now all of
a sudden he's looking up at Warren who's
doing more than him the misfit's now
doing more than him and he's like I
ain't got Canelo AJ is is on the down
and we're struggling what we're going to
do it and I'm looking at Connor Ben who
was supposed to be my next big star and
no one likes him anymore but not just
that Joshua buatti Lawrence AI to a
lesser level Chris B Smith Eubank was
fighting on Eddie hear cards at one
point you look at the amount of names
he's lost out there Dylan white okay he
was never under contract with him but
his last fight was on the BT show young
up incoming Fighters are looking at
Eddie now and thinking are you going to
navigate my career in the way I want
take a Vidal Riley for example who went
with Sky um you know I I just think
Eddie is in a in a position where he
needs to come out swinging as a as a
boxing promoter you know it's a bit it's
a bit one why is he being so dismissive
of of influence of boxing then well it
was right after the girl flashed the
tits on Kingpin and he was like that's
trash and I don't want to be associated
with it and and I understand like his
point of view on that um I think as well
it's it's not within his interest to be
hyping upti take a different industry it
is it's a separate separate the box and
he he wants the eyes on the box like the
professional box I think we've got a low
blow no no no on the back of their head
was it so this as well right so I feel
like what you were saying about M's
Taylor okay in that he will do what's
best for for business I feel like Eddie
hearn's been guilty of doing what's best
for Eddie Hearn in that he will look if
he can have a platform that can H go to
the whole world unlike Sky Sports and he
can be the in control I think that's
what it was under under the Zone they
gave him all this control and he was
like yes that's that that's perfect for
me whereas in reality it's not
necessarily what's best for growing
Fighters as we've seen good shot by a by
the way a good hook as he was lunging in
there and and and look uh Kenny isn't
timing him Kenny isn't Landing the JB he
isn't Landing the up I could the styl
and profiling against Windon Nunes is
non-existent right now that's because
wierson gave him the time to do that
werson gave him all [__] day yeah man
like and this is the difference like
when you have an aggressive come forward
fighter you can't deal with it when they
know what they're doing it's it's the
way tiller fight he's miles out of range
or he's right on your chest and that's
an MMA fighter there's no in between
whereas so he hasn't got time to kind of
let his job go and then let the back
hand go yeah he landed a nice little up
Kenny but it's been few and far between
so far and if you're just scoring it
based on amount of punch has landed is a
winning I think he is yeah all three
rounds so far it's very hard to score
but uh Taylor's got the the tactics
perfect you mean but but but this is the
thing Kenny comes from a boxing family
his brother's a boxing coach very smart
people right they know what they're
doing they knew what was coming so it's
not like this is none of this can catch
you off God but yeah but on paper it's
easy to say but have when he end the day
King Kenny although he's improved
massively it's still hard to deal with
cuz he's not that experienced so it's
like I've I've listen I've I've been in
there many times I've had a nearly 100
fights and I know what to do with a
little bull but doing it is another
another thing you know what I mean it's
it's a different K it's funny because
yeah Kenny kind of fights your your
style or or I mean not not on your level
obviously bro but like that that big jab
and keeping people in control and
knowing how to control them but to learn
how to control a ball like him it does
take a long time to be fair yeah
confidence is like that's why Tyson was
so effective when he come on the scene
back years ago he was so much smaller
but punching down is so difficult you're
wide open if you miss cuz your hands
naturally come back lower when you're
punching down so I used to spar amateurs
and I'd know that they'd be able to ping
my head off on the outside and I used to
think why am I going to play him at
there game I'm going to have a boxing
match with this fell I'm probably
there's a good chance I'm going to come
off just as bad if I go in there and try
and take the fight them CU they're
highly skilled but I've got a better
opportunity doing that so that's what
I'm going to do I'm going to go in there
take the fight I might be crude I might
make myself look silly at times but I'll
be able to put the pressure on them and
maybe it'll create openings for me and
that's one thing is where we we could
talk about Anthony Taylor's level
Anthony Taylor's skill set one thing we
can't deny is I'd actually scratch my
head to see a fight where I don't think
he's implemented a really really good
game plan okay do you think do you think
Anthony Taylor could actually be a
boogeyman for any of these influences
including including KSI I've got the
antidote for Taylor on then and Nissan
Gibb because he's got that low center of
gravity as well but he's a better all
round box but he's also got an engine as
well and you can see you can't out
you're not going to outwork the thing
that at is doing here is that he's he's
grabbing so it's like yeah it may work
more but if if if an I would have
thought an Taylor is actually stronger
so it can hold on more and if he's
holding on if he's holding on against
anyone at that weight well then it
doesn't matter if you're a better worker
or a better fighter whatever he's old
than you so you can't punch he's strong
but yeah but when you're doing it
against the naturally bigger man you do
TI that's how you always see him start
to Fe slightly so and I think Gibb works
really well in multiple Rangers Gibb
isn't Gibb doesn't need everything here
he can go inside or outside it doesn't
really matter and I also feel as if a
lot of the guys who till has fighting
who aren has experience Panic a little
bit when he runs at them someone like
Gibbs has got is a lot more ballsy and
his willing to let his hands go as he's
coming in and that's the difference and
Gibb's chin actually would hold up like
Gibb is one of the the few chins that
you could compare to a like it's hard to
hurt him a immediately is putting a
beating on uh Kenny again he's he's he's
Landing shots on him and what he does is
he he he goes in the first minute he
goes I'm going to collect enough enough
punches and then I'm going to make sure
you don't do anything after that and
it's it's kind of like what I mean I'm
not comparing him to the skill level of
usk but in the way he manages fights you
does similar thing where he goes I'm
going to win three rounds I'll take a
round off I'll win another three I think
this is where it's difficult though
because this is meant to be misfit's
influence of crossover boxing and
Anthony Taylor is a professional fight
this is why I was against this fight
just caugh there just put that and this
is where I'm seeing like was he playing
POS no I think at got hurt there t got
hurt there I think we might be in for a
treat now okay if Kenny takes it to him
did he get hurt I don't think he did I
don't I don't know whether that was a a
plan possum type thing almost to a next
extent obviously but oh a is All Over
Kenny here and it is a bit like the rxu
thing again that was very that was very
much over the top if he was doing that
but I know sometimes like uh you'd get
hit and sparring and you'd win on
purpose you know they're is landing good
shots on Kenny's chin you're seeing the
chin you're seeing it from the behind
like the
[__]
Jesus Oh Kenny's in trouble by the look
I think the phrase you used there Joe in
terms of Boogeyman that's that's
probably the best way I could describe
Anthony Taylor looking at this fight
especially isn't it crazy though how
Kenny for example like you know someone
can look so good in in one fight against
one fighter and then in another fight
looks so I mean he looks like he a
novice again and it's like isn't that
you know Styles really do make the fight
and the levels and this is what I said
to the lads in the chat was I'm just a
bit worried that a bit like Idris Virgo
against Aaron Chas there's there's skill
Gap there where you've just got too much
experience for these kind of true
YouTube guys like is unbelievable for a
YouTuber but I I mean and the response I
got was a fair one which was when you
look at how many fights Anthony Taylor
actually had had he's not that
experienced like he's just good he he he
hasn't had loads of boxing matches like
he hasn't had that many more than any
other The Lads in here but the toughness
but he's been I always say this it's
like he's had MMA fights how many times
you've stepped through the ropes yes the
the the it's a different art but he's
still being inside the that ropes and
it's a SP the end of the day so and and
half of it is just experience how how
you deal with and that's why I give Gibb
a real chance against him because Gibb's
the type of guy he's a gym Warrior where
he'll G all over the UK he'll walk in
any gym without any fear and he'll spot
anyone and when you're constantly
getting that data and you like that's
why he made those massive jumps from the
Jake Paul fight and that's why I think
and I also rate him is the a better
athlete than at yeah so that's the fight
that if if this carries on the way we
think I'd love to see that so would you
have the power to make that happen I
don't have the power I'm not saying in
the checks however I will strongly
recomend yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
willly recommend that cuz I know um gb's
been on holiday he's been on his trip
and I'd love to see him take that fight
next um where is the next Misfits card
do we know we' we've got one coming up
in London and there might be a fighter
sitting at this very table who is going
to fight on the show shout out to Joey
Joey
wait so what's going on with that Joey
or Joe yeah both Tag Team tag team let's
do it the two Joe's um we we uh we got
in touch with Miss Fitz show Joy skills
from his previous um unlicense boats and
uh there's a slip there from me too and
uh the lads were very interested and Ms
has said yeah absolutely we'll get them
on the card how do you feel you're going
to make your debut on Miss yeah good man
it's been a couple of years since I
boxed obviously the whole lockdown
situation sort of ruined it for me but I
was boxing unlicensed before as I say
fought some good boys fought some [__]
boys but at the same time do you know
what I mean I would uh I relish a chance
to get in there mate it's it's the
bright lights it's what your box for
what the whoa that was an elbow wasn't
it I think there's a little coming the
together there but um we're all right um
I think K King Ken is looking at this
now and he's thinking I've got a around
to seriously do some damage because he
can win this round and all of us sat
around this table are saying it doesn't
matter whether he wins the round unless
he gets a knockdown or something serious
happens he's lost his fight
oh yeah we'll come we'll come back to to
to Joy as we're seeing this round out uh
we got two minutes left and it really
does feel like at has R racked at least
three of the four rounds I'm going to be
real I think it's 5 nil yeah probably 5
agree um I and and it's not even like
it's much like the Sal papy fight where
and to be fair salt papy did a lot more
damage than Kenny has Sal papy was was
clipping him back so can I just raise a
quick question when it comes back to the
way I obviously feel about the main
event and what I think could possibly
play out yeah does it not just open
everyone's eyes up a little bit for
those whose eyes weren't maybe open and
it doesn't necessarily just mean us
around this table to go look at what
Tommy Fury did with Anthony Taylor I'm
not saying he bashed him up stopped him
he nullified him a lot of the time
you're saying this could be a
premonition of what we may see in the
main event when it when it's basically a
professional fighter against a hug
levels are everything I tell you what I
can score some great goals down the park
but if you stick me at Stanford Bridge
every one of them hitting Rose you know
what I mean levels are everything mate
yeah yeah I think that look it's a fair
point and and we're we're hoping uh for
the for the dream to come off KSI to
pull off the impossible um and I think
the only worry is for me is is um a
despite him dominating this fight he's
not a really really hard puncher right
Tommy is a harder puncher and and but JJ
him losing the fight isn't what I'm
worried about because for me I think if
he gets through the decision just like
Jake it was a win and and there's a lot
you can be proud of there um it's it's
it's being finished you know I I think
for him for a proud man and he's a proud
man you know like he doesn't want to he
doesn't want to see see to be losing in
devastating fashion and then and that's
what I'm worried about and you know when
we talk about hard punchers a lot of the
time we're rating that on records and
Records only and I could think of so
many fighters who weren't regarded as
hard punchers and then ended up going on
a spree of fights where they were
getting like Josh warron comes to mind
he he was never getting stoppages in his
first 12 fights or something and then
went on a consistent run of fights where
he was getting them so I think you could
look at and you could go well the powers
of KSI over Tommy Fury records aren't
everything mate trust me speak to people
that have maybe been in with them and
then you might go okay was a funny one
like that as well there was people like
CH son who fought Bisping and were like
one of the hardest punches I've ever
fought in my life yeah he didn't have
the most knockouts you know uh we were
at the uh the decision now um Kenny
clearly knows he didn't do enough his
brother Dy is explaining what went wrong
um but look there's no shame for Kenny
here like I you you fought a proper Pro
there and I think it's quite obvious
that as much as Kenny isn't um sorry as
much as a isn't the most explosive punch
out the most you know entertaining guy
at this level he's just like a Wy old
veteran compared to these guys he he
knows how to manage fight and get and
make the most out of what he's got and
to do enough to win rounds yeah and
ultimately like on Misfits the good
thing is is that it actually doesn't
matter if you take a loss it's not like
your career is done like you could lose
yeah take the UFC honestly like two
three in a row if you're entertaining if
you've got support if you know they're
putting you on you it doesn't matter man
come back and if anything people love
the support um to support you know the
comeback fighter that is coming back
from A Loss you know and and this is
that's another good point when you when
people are comparing to professional
boxing yet again this is where pro boxer
need to look and say actually these guys
are losing they're entertaining and
they're still fighting again getting
more opportunities like it's a positive
thing and this is one thing so much
better than pro boxing like pro boxing
just don't understand like you know like
it's like years ago with the UFC boxer
never really learned from what the UFC
were doing and yet again this has coming
long are they going to learn again and
say look we need to be doing what these
guys are doing like follow a business
plan that's working it's as simple as
that doesn't matter what what it is it
could be a different industry it doesn't
matter follow that formula and that's
what pro boxing are often often missing
basically so shout out to the 10,000
viewers we've got live [__] boy
that is like us being in say the copper
box Arena and it being packed out right
now and I in the middle you've done that
before though to be
fair that was only I think I think 8 and
a half thousand so it's even more that's
pretty decent shout out everyone
subscribe like the video we really
appreciate you we've got the decision
coming over King Kenny uh looking like a
loss to Anthony Taylor no shame in that
and next up it is the lightweights uh
Dean the great versus will
sharks um and we're going to get this
decision now I'm pretty sure it's
unanimous I mean yeah it's it's it's
pretty clear and this is the um
4945 all three judges for the new light
heavyweight champion of the world of
Misfits Anthony Taylor is it uh yep
there you go um play oh and he's just
collapsed um it does mean a lot to him
to be fair Anthony like for him this is
a guy who felt like a bit of a reject in
uh MMA certainly not a superstar in
boxing and he's found a home he's
shaking the ropes he's a fan of the
Ultimate Warrior the old wrestler
Batista um and going back to Joey uh
Joey is actually um going to be fighting
in the division of the title fight
that's coming up next so you're going to
get a closer look at these guys you
might be share in the ring with at some
point yeah hopefully so I mean look both
of them both of them look good you know
what I mean and both of them would look
to the untrained eye like maybe they
were guys that had done some sort of
boxing before obviously the influence of
boxing scene Dean the great if you don't
know he sort of his come up in the
street fighting YouTube tled Kimbo Slice
type [__] really yeah so he was like
brawling and I believe keemstar spotted
him I think someone I don't know if it
was keemstar specifically but they
brought the footage to keemstar and he
he signed him up and he's regarded as
the puncher in this fight obviously he
stopped a couple of opponents stopped
willed even yeah I think the only
credible one you could say stopped is
willed obviously he stopped Arif I think
it is the the first guy was was bang
aage the first guy I seen on Misfits one
didn't look like I mean he wasn't bad
but you know in terms of ticking boxes
as well like he's come back from being
dropped he's been in a hard fight now
where obviously in there the got dropped
in that fight comeback and that shows
heart and that's something that
inevitably going down that sort of
Street Fighter type route you will pick
up very interested because a lot of
people I speak to are thinking that
willed is winning this one so be very
very interest will but Dean's the
favorite by most people um I want to
come back to the Logan Paul Dylan danis
fight there's just a few other things um
I want to cover in terms of just general
questions for the table do we think the
Mind Games will take an impact on Logan
Paul in this fight I spoke to a friend
of the show believing Bruce the body
language expert and he said as much as
he doesn't rate Dylan's boxing technique
the worry is is the adrenaline and the
rage within Logan and the pressure on
Logan to his beautiful fian night I'm
here to defend your honor if he can keep
his mind in the arena well all of that
is going on you know so many people have
been chatting [__] about you like one of
these videos that was tweeted out by
Dylan got 100 million views like this
isn't something you can just have a
spliff and a whiskey and ignore you know
what I mean speaking from personal
experience like for that it's it's a
whole another ball game so do we think
Logan is going to be able to perform as
he would want to on the night so I mean
I personally think with the WWE
experience I think that will benefit him
massively because when he first started
with that he wasn't used to getting
booed and he actually has said that that
really affected him cuz everyone booed
the hell out of him and I feel like that
whole thing of having to learn to be
totally present regardless of what's
going on over here and if anything use
it to your advantage he's been doing
that for weeks on end now oh wow you're
so right he's such a performer I mean
and I've seen how well he does in those
scenario so now he'll he'll look to the
camera and be like yeah [__] and he'll
egg the fans on so it'll feel like home
for him and that's yeah that's what I
think so I think I think Logan will be
used to it and if anything having his
fiance ringside I think as a man that's
going to that's going to evoke some
[__] Focus testosterone all of it to
go right I need to do the job here and I
think you actually see Logan come out
composed I think he's he knows ah I
can't come out here swinging and going
crazy I think you'll see him be very
composed and I think he's going to do a
job you know if I'm him if I'm him and
I'm in front of the misses I'd rather
than be taken out of there i' rather
[__] kill me before I'm out of here
like if I'm breathing I'm punching do
like I'd be saying to the corner on some
Chris Eubank [__] no towel no tow no
towel what are you saying lad what do
you think I think it's a perfect
opportunity set you right for that sorry
sorry I'm getting carried away the
alcohol's Tak effect now sorry it was
good I just think it's a perfect
opportunity for him to kind of use this
and go out there and do the number
running because dealan like with said he
isn't really a puncher anyway from from
what we've seen so if you can't do it
against him it's kind of where's he
going to go did you see any of Dylan's
actual punching i' I've seen a little
bit of it not much of it but like it it
doesn't look very great it doesn't look
very good you know what I mean but you
cuz you train guys so you you take them
from literally no nothing to the ring
yeah so where would you put him on that
scale pretty low level really like
realistically um it's I just think
realistically regardless of what
pressure Logan's got he should go like I
actually think Logan Paul's quite
technical like he's got quite good
technique good balance and what I've
seen of him he should go out there and
destroy him as you first watch Logan
together mean you said he has the
potential to be better than Jake and JJ
100 I said that from day one cuz I think
when I one thing boxers often look at is
someone's balance and how they move like
when they're move on the front foot back
foot when you're letting your hands go
and he's kind of got that good balance
in I don't know if that comes from his
wrestling background um but generally
speaking he technically looks pretty
good the only thing he was lacking like
Jake was that little bit of spite in
what he does if you could get you
haven't got that tonight you're never
going to have it exactly that's my point
he should go out there and do a number
he's not got he's not like he's in with
someone like a Mayweather who really
knows what he's doing or someone else
who's like a bit of a puncher like when
he fought KSI he's in there with a guy
who's not really from what we've seen
doesn't look like he can punch so he
should just go out there and just try my
only xact that on this is Dylan danis
trains with Big Time MMA guys all the
time he's always in the gym right so
we've seen him uh with Alex Pereira
who's one of the hardest punchers in the
history of MMA and they weren't going
full on but he says on on the on when
the footage stopped we went full on for
six rounds and it's been known that
Conor McGregor basically used him as a
punching bag uh in exchange for um to
teach him teach him how to box while
Dylan trained him how to do Brazilian
jiu-jitsu and Connor hit him so badly
that he broke BR his face he literally
broke his face they had to have like
surgery some stuff like that so like in
my head I'm like if Dylan danis has been
getting beaten up by Conor McGregor for
that long probably not a [__] like
you're probably quite tough so I guess
his hope is to just endure whatever's
coming in the early rounds and hope you
can take them late I think everything
you said there is why I see a a
completely spoiled fight coming up here
why I see a bit of a hugfest why I see
that at times because I think when you
talk about stars making fights they sort
of contradict each other in terms of I
think what you've got to do against
Dylan danis is be really aggressive with
him to be able to put him back in his
shell and I don't think Logan Paul has
that aggression from what we've seen in
his fight so far ironically you can sort
of write off the Mayweather fight
because it's Mayweather but the best
I've seen Logan paol was in the first
KSI fight in terms of in terms of jab
ambition and things like that so I think
that when you look at that from Logan
paol side not the most ambitious and
also not the most ruthless doesn't have
that inner bastard about him type thing
and then when you look at Dylan danis
you think someone that's probably going
to miss a lot of punches and therefore
end up hugging a lot and holding a lot
because you're in that range already for
missing those punches so that's why I
could potentially see it being a bit of
a boring fight but I will caveat that by
saying a lot of the time I think fights
are going to go one way and they go
completely completely the fact that he's
like and this has been a regular
criticism like people are like weird of
criticized Logan for not having the
spite the bastard this has got to change
tonight you have to nail this but it's
knowing how to utilize the bastard right
because he could do that in a way that's
just like tense up throw really stiff
did against Floyd yeah you know what I
mean and you just gash yourself out
whereas he needs to if yeah but
basically he just needs UTI harness the
bastard and it'll be all right you you
you know uh obviously Logan on a
personal level Brian what would you say
like out of the two of them when we were
speaking about to build up who do you
think's being more of themsel do you
think they're both just Level Playing
Field both being themsel or do you think
that it's coming a little bit less
natural to Logan than it is to to Dylan
cuz that's how it looks from the outset
looking in I think when you I mean Logan
has like like all like we all do we have
several different versions of himself
when you're hanging out with Logan it's
just like anyone anyone here chill guy
shoots the [__] quite laidback actually
really laidback in conversation um but
strategically he's he's quite a
reptilian person he's very thinks the
long term thinks business plans he
thinks how am I going to get the most at
the end of the day um and I think uh
he's quite cold blooded like that and
that that that should help him like you
say in but the only things that haven't
helped him in the past is there was just
this moment in the KSI fight he says he
was ill I sneezed three times uh that
that that line but JJ's just got more of
the dog right and that just took effect
in that fight um and I think he
sometimes they say you need a you need a
killer in front of of you to become a
killer like to actually channel that
from your go I need and I'm not saying
Dylan's a killer in terms of physically
but he he you got that man if he hasn't
brought the dog out of you and brought
the killer out of you nothing will like
this is the worst buildup I can remember
in a fight ever that's why this is going
to do the biggest numbers it is is cuz
Dylan's went the places you never ever
should fact we've got will Le sharks
walking out now wearing a Halloween mask
Frankenstein sort of or is it no who's
that that's the guy from Halloween right
the one the who chases you down and
kills you in the lake strange but also
wait following that but following that
Anthony Taylor uh Kenny fight do you
think if Dylan danis applies the Anthony
Taylor tactics maybe that could actually
be a way in which he can win could
definitely be a way in which he wins is
he skilled enough to do it that's what
i' be unsure of because you can look at
the Anthony Taylor one and go well it's
not much skill trust me there there is a
bit of skill there to be able to do that
is crude or not that's another question
but it is there is a noow Jan inspiring
he looks quite passive he looks yeah
yeah yeah he very you it's very flowy
it's like Conor McGregor St then the
other thing I would say with that is all
likelihood is that most of the footage
we've seen of Dylan danis has been not
necessarily released himself by Dylan
danis but has been given the okay has
been given the go- aead so it could
again be a master move it could be a
master stroke in only releasing the bits
and pieces from sparring from PB work
that make him look absolutely rubbish
yeah but surely you would have at least
seen at least once in a fight him
display some sort of striking ability
the fact that like we've never seen it
surely means that like we we we've seen
him get tagged a lot you get hurt I've
got a quick shout out shout out to John
Fury who's donated 1010 with the I'm
machine I'm machine um shout out to Big
John what do we think of Big John in
this building he's been [__] value as
always crazy I mean I think he's well
funny but I understand how at times it
can can be a bit like oh can he just not
for this moment so that the guys that we
want to hear talk can talk there was a
moment the other day where um KSI was
trying to talk and like you're like this
is the main event the man who's paid
everyone to be here and all you can hear
in John in the background like you can't
silence me and and he's like well
someone shut that [__] up the best thing
was after the first press conference
where John Fury's flipped the table done
an Instagram story do you remember it
and he said I'm sorry for the way I
acted shouldn't have acted like that and
then literally K eyes talking John
Fury's just got his ass out slapping it
oh John's ass yeah there was this moment
where so John's being held back sort of
in the corner while this all goes on and
there's two like young ring card girls
next him and like they're like and he
starts shouting and they start sort of
like backing away and then they get
another angle where John bends over and
gets his ass and you're like oh those
girls I feel sorry for you I hope they
weren't too CL you're not the next step
for John is though oh he's already said
only fans you got to be in it You' got
to be in it you're selling yourself as
the star of the show we need to see you
in it mate and do you know what like I
do think that as much as we can have
opinions on it I think we're all very
much in the same boat of saying this is
not professional boxing this is this is
WWE but not fake it is WWE but it's real
and people can actually get hurt wait w
is
fake um because of that I do think that
a character like John fury like I said
about Anthony Taylor and a few of the
other boys on the show very much who the
f fights John Fury though if because
he's he's mentioned Mickey F wanted it
no he didn't I don't know joh answered
the call you know surely wait surely
there's only one man Mike Tyson yeah
[__] my dad maybe I put money on my dad
I don't know who can actually face John
Fury first he's about 60 you know what
was mad is I I was wondering like how
good was John so I see in the footage of
him when he was a young right it didn't
look great right but the point the point
was he was always um he was always
called Gypsy John and he would like as
in he was he was taken quite lightly as
in we'll need a last minute guy he'll
turn up no training put the gloves on
have a scrap and they will put him in
with high level guys to make them look
good so John was kind of set up for
failure really um but then I seen
Dominic Engel talking the other day uh
from the famous Engle J who trained so
many world champions and he went oh my
my my dad said if you took John Fury
when he was young and trained him he had
a lot of natural ability and he was
actually a very talented boxer but just
could never dedicate himself cuz he was
always on the piss and he was never
actually giving it the real one you know
the guys that you saw him get stopped
against in them clips that have cated
online they were they were they were
good British level Fighters like
Henry was obviously a good British level
fighter and you know you see that and
you think okay but one thing I would say
about John Fury and I I listen I love
Tyson Fury I hope no would hold it
against me but you know when he hit that
perspect glass is it called perspect
glass the glass in the cage he
definitely thought he was smashing it
with that first pun didn't he's gone b
boom and then it just sort of stayed
there and he thought for [__] sake
I'll go again 20 minutes later still
there this is the thing with John know
he's so unhinged like imagine he smashes
that glass and the glass flies into KSI
and we got a fight off like what are you
doing like I mean I just think his brain
goes into ultimate like animal Instinct
like it does not matter any of these
human things that are occurring around
me irrelevant it's just I am a lion and
I am trying to kill and that he Lally
said to KSI I will bum you he was
literally looking up at KSI as KSI was
on this St and he was like I [__] B
you and you're like 57 that is paper
view though yeah it's like how
outrageous he's he's trying to do
everything in his being to try and get
to you and it's yeah that is his thing
did you see him start on Logan Paul's
dadone cuz Greg Paul goes over to him
goes oh yeah nice like go to shake his
hand and then he just randomly goes will
you fight me I'm a fighting man and you
fight me now do you know what's funny
about that has anyone ever been in
situations when uh you you've got a bit
of a beef with someone you think when I
see that fell I'm going to [__] let
him know and then you see him and they
catch you off guard they go mate you go
right and then you walk off and you
think oh why didn't I say something that
was what that was John Fury goes Greg
Paul how you want to fight me like
straight away just he goes within two
seconds then it [__]
insane and um you know if that happened
in real life I think Greg Paul cuz Greg
Paul he's like a wildly Southern geizer
right he he ched out Jake and Logan he'd
have pulled that gun out he would have
blown John Fury away and that would have
been the last we heard of John
furyx we're we're under way here uh we
got the lightweight Misfits boxing World
title on the line uh Dean the great with
W shocks the rematch
Oru what a shot from a left hook from W
my money's on this Giza I need him to
come through oh my that was off the bat
left H Rock You know the thing that
became really apparent in the first
fight is wed reads Dean so well and he
just got cocky and switch up is Dean
just replied with the right hand Jes the
funny thing there is like there's
obviously the aspect of catching someone
cold and it's not like Dean went down
but what we've seen so far from Dean in
his fights is as explosive as you can be
and as dangerous as you can be doesn't
always look like he takes a shot well
you know he's the [__] he's the
misfit Amia con like fast but he's very
vulnerable uh good followup by W there
with the the step in um but they're both
so quick with the
hands um and Dean has recently changed
training CS to a more professional
training camps so you'd think they'd
really be getting him and he's actually
started to step in do his work and jump
out and uh get out the way of w I think
ironically it won't get the flowers that
maybe it deserves cuz the lighter
weights don't always get as much
attention but these are two of the best
boxers you can see the quality in these
two oh this is yeah this is probably the
highest level boxing match we'll get
yeah what is good is that we're getting
two guys that are both engaging as well
like you know what I mean I think that's
what's being great across the card so
far in total like everyone's come to
fight wellow except for
swarms [__] hell poor guy but these
these guys are doing high level stuff
you know what I mean these are they're
trying to draw each other in using the
job they're not just running at each
other throwing punches yeah this is real
good stuff for uh for Misfits and I
think a lot of the the like the lads the
higher ups at Misfits are kind of proud
of this one to be one of the ones where
cuz they're very aware like this is a
lot of people's first introduction to
Misfit so what they want to do is go
okay yeah we got the gimmicks yeah we've
got a lot of fun fights but there's some
quality here as well and that you'll get
a bit of everything on a fight the other
good thing in W shark's favor here is
like once someone's beat you okay yeah
it can happen again but at the end of
the day you've already experienced the
lowest of the low here
ohot shocks has pinned him into the
corner firing back but maybe that's not
the most sensible thing to do here maybe
you should look to roll out to his left
and take a second there's no
in giving up one exchange to be able to
come back stronger in the next one
rather than trying to fight fire with
fire all the time not many of them shots
were Landing clean he was kind of just
rolling them
the I mean the beauty of this is is
there's some real bad blood between them
it isn't just oh we want to compete for
the title these guys hate each other you
talk if you talk about checking each
other's Instagram and stuff like just to
them yeah it's all well and good doing
that you need to be up in a fight to be
doing that sort of stuff in my opinion
remember when um Madonna versus what do
you call him want to be Mayweather what
do you call him
um what's the guy who thought he was a
Mayweather oh Deon Alexander was it no
no you're not having a drink I'll have a
drink oh sorry yeah always getting
nicked yeah what's his name vodka get
groomed fine I'll go vodka
and BR did exactly that go for a week
soda do you want to drink Lo want to
drink
yeah why not yeah whiskey so we got two
VOD two uh two whiskies uh and whatever
Josh is having what you having I'm fine
I've got a lovely Diet Pepsi so I feel
great can we just uh while there's a
round uh being paused here just want to
tell you that the uh the bid for Man
United has been uh withdrawn so they're
now not going to be bought out the
glazers have rejected the last offer and
so um sh J simmers has informed them
that he will no longer be fans are going
to be covering that on the kickoff don't
worry we'll be we'll be getting back
we're under way for the second round
here but we will be covering that on the
kickoff don't forget to like And
subscribe to everyone who's watching
appreciate you all uh we're underway for
the second round Dean the great w shocks
do you know what I found really
interesting here did you see both uh
both men's weight when they were when
they were lining the tail of the tape up
both were under under
£130 which is making me worry a little
bit thinking have I got to make 130
instead of 135 no it's definitely 135 I
just think a lot of these guys like with
it being you know influencer boxing yeah
it it's a broad you know way category in
it it's it's it's lot of like the UFC
early days where it was like okay can
you get under this way okay you're
fighting for that title then oh a knee
that is a knockdown that's a legit
knockdown that no that's a legit
knockdown it was a balance issue maybe
rather than the shot being so hard
putting it though but wed sharks has
come in and he's been caught with a
short right hand from Dean the great and
as much as I think think sharks is the
better boxer out of the two of them it's
a real power when you've got a man in
front of you that you know you can hurt
he's also slowed down a little bit will
and he's he's his legs off he's gone
he's gone he's gone he's going to [__]
me accumulate I right up uh he he's
definitely gone he come his defense is
gone no and the problem with him is is
is is Dean's just hits harder in it it's
oh yeah he's a he's going oh oh yeah I
don't know how he's going to he looks
like Amia K here you know when the Bambi
leg St going he's still throwing I'll
give him that I think I think he's going
to come through I'll be stunned if he
gets through this I think he's going to
come through I hope he does though one
clean shot mate those Bambi legs mate
they skinny tiny little legs man wait
who who's got the Bambi legs uh W chop
he's been dropped and he's he's been
rocked after that as well he was having
a bit of success against Dean the great
he's gone in and on the way in he's been
clipped of a short right but you know
when their coordination goes in their
hands as well he his coordination
absolutely gone he's pushing forward
give that ran it was funny you said
about you know Dean the great being able
to read well sharks I think both men can
read each other you I really do think
that but in the first fight it was all
were lead until it turned and once it
turned it didn't but in this fight to be
fair to Dean he's he's actually really
being the great lovely little right
uppercut you know when you're watching
this Joy obviously you'll be competing
at this we class are you seeing anything
where you're like or do you fancy do you
fancy it with these oh and he's down
again
the lead sh is down again and this is
pretty much game set match in the second
round it's hard to see a turn around
after a bad second round yeah where
you've been dropped twice there's only
20 seconds left in the round can he
survive yeah I think Dean is tuning up
the switch in music oh oh and that upper
cut lands body shot I mean he's a
Sitting Duck hour lead I mean he's
throwing these Jabs but there's nothing
behind him he needs to hold it the factu
is is once he been dropped the first
time his punches just looked completely
gone he went to 50% speed it was just m
so robotic so uncoordinated I'll tell
you the problem with uh getting the
finish here for Dean the great watched a
bit of Dean the great and obviously when
I look at him he's actually not the best
finisher when it needs to finish in
terms of off the front foot so far in
this fight look the big highlight real
knockout we've all seen is when he walks
towards wed shark bomb one shot puts him
over but actually his best punches
always come off the back foot they're
always counter punches he counter
punched him with a right hand that Drew
the drop knee for the first knockdown he
counter punched him there with a
straight right hand off the ropes and
one thing that a fighter is always going
to be weary of when they're fighting
someone like that is that if you do get
him under a bit of pressure let's say
for example you're in there with him you
push him back to the ropes you start to
think R can unload him a little bit here
you always know he's got that danger
being able to clip you and what that can
do is it can buy in time and it can also
stop him taking you're you're not going
to get Crea when you know that there's
something behind it playing possum here
you're going back to the ropes cuz
you're about to throw that short right
hand yeah we're underway again for the
third round it it it would take a
Monumental turnaround at this point and
I don't I'd be shocked if it happens
with two drops in the first two rounds o
well he'd still pushing forward but he
hasn't learned his lesson no he's still
he's his reflexes still aren't there he
he he should be taking a round off oh
look at the wobble there oh he's gone M
his legs are absolutely wobbly man he
looks like Amia cor going into South now
which means he is finding it easy cuz
that's not coming as natural to him oh I
mean this he can't see where the punch
this is embarrassingly easy for Dean to
be fair I mean uh will when he watches
this back the there was there was
dispute after the first fight the
referee needs to come in here now the F
the first fight was was controversial
because will dropped him twice and when
he got dropped the referee waved it off
and didn't even though he was up and he
was ready to carry on the referee waved
it off there's no controversy here like
this is [__] a beat down
I mean he's still going credit to him I
mean the heart of wi is unquestionable
I'll give him that like it's it's not a
case of this this is where the corner
should take over and Chuck the toin
because he's defenseless right now yeah
would you be happy with your your corner
chucking in the tow at this point though
it depends on what it's for like this
there levels what the competition for
he's still Landing shots he's still
Landing as a fan and obviously then I've
not got an emotional connection to the
fighter I'd like to see
Dean is running away all of a you'd want
to see three or four clean more blows go
in before you go right that's enough CU
if it was to go in now there's going to
be question marks there really are I've
seen and just to give a little bit of
credit to Misfits though as much as you
know it's it's been a great performance
by Dean I've seen worse pro boxing
matches at Pro on pro events than this I
think this is a a good representation
for Misfits well look at Eddie hearn's
face ringside smiling like why do you
know what I mean and that's what I'm
saying like look at it like this this
isn't a joke this isn't ridiculous this
is boxing mate and I feel like you know
yeah it is a good representation but to
give credit to the opponent in wed
sharks also we say about the level of
the fight the level of the fight can
only look that level if you've got two
dance Partners who are both skilled yeah
I think will might be getting a bit of a
um a bit of a second win I'm not saying
he's ready to win a fight by any means
but but he's he's coming in and he's
actually having a little bit more for
osity in his punches a lot of people are
saying sorry Jo a lot of people are
saying that Dean has hurt his left hand
oh really yeah interesting yeah we all
do injuries man so we'll see we'll see
if he throws the left here cuz great and
there and that was that was the sort of
shot that first in the first
fight jab come on jab son he's not
throwing the left though is he like what
I said earlier on when uh W sharks was
looking in a bit of trouble there that I
expected him to come through that little
moment and that's because from watching
the one lik on the on the with with a
Keen Eye I must say he's not a great
finisher he's not a very good finisher
you look at the finishes he's had it's
usually been one single shot not him
dropping and hurting someone and putting
the accumulation you'd have thought
you'd got him out of there by now for
sure I want you to talk all that [__] Jo
on the on the build at once you're
fighting him you say you can't finish
you couldn't finish your dinner lad um
but no it's been a good fight I I'll
give credit to W I thought he was
absolutely out of there and it's part of
his heart that's got him through and
it's partly the not being a great
finisher Tommy's on his way in puffer
jacket not my choice got to back it up
now play um he said something to uh KSI
he was like I've had to be away from My
Wife and Kids for or whatever for three
months and you're going to pay for that
and I was like oh it's a good line
though that is a good line yeah he's
getting better his trash talk in the
face off was I was really impressed with
it was quick witted it's weird it's he's
developed skills that we've never seen
from him KSI looked a bit shocked in
that he was like and I was like
shouting at the TV like you know
question his ability question you're the
pro fighter why did you not manage to
stop Jake Paul why have you not you know
what I mean but it was all Tommy was the
aggressor in that face off that gave me
a bit of I was like I don't like this CU
this is your Arena this JJ the thing is
so though like I almost feel like in all
of the buildups of JJ's fights like
there's always a moment that he does
something that everyone gets on him like
oh you lost that whether it be like the
issue with the you know the the incident
leading up to the Jo fight whatever it's
like where the World Turns on him or or
everyone says you lost this you lost and
it gives him a kick and we've seen him
now come so strong as we get closer to
fight night that you know but ultimately
I I do want to say at the same time like
this these things leading up like they
don't actually like we tried to read
into it but they actually can't they
don't give away as much as we like to
think we can actually gauge from them oh
no they're intangibles like and and this
is the thing is the reason I like to
look at them is cuz I think is the skill
Gap close enough where these things
might take so with with Logan and and
danis if the skill Gap is close then all
of oh Big Shot will is in
trouble oh he's really in trouble and
they should throw the tow in stop it
stop it ref referee needs to stop this
right now you're oh he held him did you
say that he held him and then was
digging him that's not [__] legal
that is a [__] point deduction you
can't do that that's a [__] point
deduction that you can't that's what
Logan Paul got deducted too Point
against K yeah
that's the doctor is
involved that is uh put his gumshield
pack in the referee hasn't even said a
thing about the fact that he held his
head down that is wild man what was the
corner saying to him in that moment
there were they saying just give it
everything you can he's out on his feet
is he not I don't know were trying to
delay put the gum shield in as long as
possible wasn't have any of it to get to
B them a bit of time apparently holding
the guy's head down is fine but taking
too long to put the gun shield in isn't
the ref's like oh out [__] oh is
surely
that's oh how is he still in
it you know he's starting to he'll win
fans out of being just a gutsy
performance here Willie to be fair to
him but he won't help my
accumulator um he can't find that one
punch you right he can't quite find the
Finish yeah we're seeing a little bit of
like I don't know if I'm you Joy I'm not
M at what I'm seeing right now are you
feeling a bit more confident out of this
I think looking at it I think that Dean
the great has done really really well in
a fight that obviously as we say a lot
of people thought that he would struggle
to come through so I want to give him
props for that I don't just want to be
the guy that wants to fight him and then
for example I'm going to trash him
because at the end of the day why do I
want to fight him because he's because
he's probably the best one there around
my way so I think he's doing really well
I think he's got to raise a sharp right
hand at times but what I would say is
whenever I look at someone and I'm
looking at them as a potential opponent
I don't really look at what they're
doing so much I try to look at what the
opposition are doing and think well what
would I do there what would I be able to
exploit what areas would I be able to
expose in a different way so there's a
lot of things that I probably won't say
on here that I'm looking at here and I'm
thinking I could exploit you back I was
just going to ask the question how would
you deal with him mate I could box him
on the back foot the front foot or one
foot it doesn't really matter to me
[__] W is really putting it on him
fair play still [__] can go in that line
deserves a what a [__]
Warrior like for him they still push him
in the corner and dig him like that
after all the punishment he's taken and
this is what I'm saying this is why it's
brilliant because if this is the pro
ranks if we're watching a BT sports card
a matchroom show whatever it is we're
looking at the guy that's losing right
now and we're only focusing on the guy
that's winning the fight and we're
thinking ah well he's on the scrap after
this but after this you would genuinely
love to see W shark in there with so
many other Fighters and that's the
beauty of it like that's why it has got
that MMA UFC Vibe about it but I tell
you what that right hand from Dean the
great is a really really beautiful shot
it's yeah I don't know how he's still on
his it's almost like he's become immune
to the power shots now
it's take your power yeah you literally
yeah you'll feel it tomorrow but not not
he's not feeling much now like when he's
trying to these conflicts in the morning
yeah poor bastard [__] what a fight
man you know what's funny is the last
fight was viewed as arguably the best
influence of box fight today and I think
it's that was more competitive than this
but they they put on a great show here
for everyone I think you got to sit on D
the Great's chest a lot more than he's
doing right now a lot of the time he's
throwing that lead hand leaving it out
there with the opportunity to be counted
with that right hand I just think you
got a tuck up tight get on his chest and
try and make things Anthony Taylor him
almost you know or or potentially and
this is you know I'm I'm not saying that
this is the way but like youve said
Dean's best shots are often counters and
and uh well lead has been a come forward
fighter this whole time you know maybe
draw him out let him be the aggressor
and see where his holes are in his game
from throwing punches and counter him a
bit because wed has really in my opinion
been too predictable in this fight that
single counter right hand off off a lazy
jab that's that's the main shot he's
landed he's not really landed much else
to be honest when you're looking at
Dean's Jabs they're almost non-existent
mate so if you go on the back foot
against him and I'm not going to give
any game plan but if you go on the back
foot against him and you throw that jab
and you get the better of him on that
jab he's got to come on you he's got to
do SS and maybe try and make him fight
in a way that he's not used to it yeah
it I'm not it's giving a bit one trick
py right now and it's a hell of a trick
but it's not even one that has been
enough
to end the fight yet um despite how much
damage it's done time and time again
what I would say is at n and a half
Stone give or take very OD to end a fire
times you know what I mean it's I I hear
you yeah they probably depleted
themselves quite a lot as well to get
down it's been quite a high Pier to be
fair as well been a lot of punches
thrown very good level Yeah by a mile
the most like we've seen tonight [__]
oh oh D Hurt No
Way what a what a comeback that would be
minute of one minute left as well and de
Hur right on him M my money's on Joy if
this ever
happens I mean mate Dean's holding on
for de life and he's out of the ring
mate that is humiliating after the way
you've bossed him all over the [__]
you can't be doing that lad you're
crawling back into the ring with a
minute left to go get up he is hurt you
know no he is he's doing everything he
can to not engage taking his time yeah
yeah ifan will I'm going [__] 100 m
hour go on lad dig him dig
him oh he's H him you [__] how are
you doing this and and DM the great is
holding on for de life come on Dan what
how is this happening Dean is begging to
stay in this fight de needs to not step
forward you got to get on your bike this
out now man don't try and engage with
him oh oh another shot another do it
Dean oh and Dean is just holding on for
Di lifia after all of the dominance he
is in trouble what are we watching oh
he's in big trouble oh he's in massive
trouble [__] you [__] this this is AB
mental this is what the
Dean is backpedaling he wants nothing to
do with UT from hell and he takes a knee
does he does he no this is crazy mate oh
oh my God wed is the man to come back
after all of that you've got my respect
this what what you were seeing earlier
on about when you get if you land one
shot it's like Super Mario you just get
that energy boost 10 and and look it's
not about me here it's not about me here
but this is what I can see stuff in this
fight I've watched him a few times
thinking right I want to fight this boy
I can see certain things in him and it's
just played out there like Dean ain't
great when you're able to hit him with a
shot and not only do that but then come
with actually you know intelligent
things to counter that off intelligent
moves to be able to bring on to that he
doesn't Fair very well under that so I
think both boys have done them proud but
it was a great fight how I just can't
believe he's still in the fight after
being hurt was it the third or round was
it it was the third yeah yeah we were
saying to throw in the tow like I
literally thought that was him done he
he was wobbling around like Bambi um for
not just one round off one shot for
about two rounds so at this weight right
obviously they get rocked
but is it is it enough to be able to you
know when we when we like oh he's gone
back this has got to be done like is it
that yeah they're at a weight where
they're not able to really no if you can
you can listen if you can punch you can
punch it doesn't matter what the weight
is but generally speaking the heavier
weight you have more bigger punches
where cuz once you get to a certain like
once you get to around the 11 stor Mark
if you can you can knock any size man
out if you can punch a little bit you
know what I mean naturally at the light
of weight you don't have as many punches
that's all it is but you definitely do
see punches at this we M the factu that
they like the part of the beauty of the
lighter weights for me and that's why
people do like y Mani Pacquiao Floyd
maywe the T is like you never done are
you like action packed is it [__]
hell it's just nonstop I think as well
as you light guys the the cardio because
of their pace is so high they've also
got such a great recovery as well when
they get hurt so yeah it's unbelievable
sometimes M that was that if if people
are watching Misfits for the first time
that's where you're like [__] this is
actually [__] right oh thus far this has
been actual like full value for money
and anyone that is on the fence and was
like you know tonight let's check this
out like surely you know it's it's
normal that on well on standard boxing
cards it's nearer the main event like
co-main main that you're really
interested in thus far everything's been
quality liing entertaining in different
ways as well where about uh were're
potentially about to step up a level in
terms of in terms of like the biggest
stars created on misfat it's been slim
and salt puy they're the ones who've had
the highlight real moment they're the
ones who were no one knew them and then
they Rose to uh the the occasion salt
puy um has had viral viral videos 2. odd
million on a fight um some of his
Knockouts have gone so viral it's unreal
and him and slim have always been
friends and now they've moved down to a
better weight for them we've seen a body
transformation in salt papy where he
went from this you know fat kid who now
shredded and Slim's never been uh body
beautiful but he has these big long
levers and he knows how to grit it out
and and knock people out we're going to
be in for a real treat this next fight
um and I think slim is generally the
favorite but what against salt papy I
think he's the favorite yeah in terms of
betting wise um but Sal papy is the Puna
the one who people are he's got a bit of
magic about him and that's kind of why I
picked him I I acknowledge like if
you're looking at the game plan of what
Sal papy struggled with against a was
being roughed up getting on the inside
and someone not smothering him one two
hug slim does that well so I think this
is a really hard fight for him as well
the other thing like slim is is
more oh wait we're just getting the the
results in
quick yeah it's pretty conclusive yeah
Dean the great with unanimous decision
Dean the great um and you know what um I
feel for w because the effort was there
for for a win um I mean just to fight
back in the way that he did like it's
just absolutely commendable yeah you
can't I know he's going to be bummed out
but like a lot of people should be
patting him on the back yeah for real
Yeah well yeah what I was what I was
going to say about salt papy is that
obviously slim is so much more natural
at the weight that they're going to be
fighting at in terms of like in recent
time yeah salt papy's just got to this
weight and it's you know is losing all
of that weight in such a quick time
going to going to drain a man yeah your
your body's not used to being a
competing at that weight it could be a
totally different experience like you
certain you often see this with Fighters
when they lose a lot of weight they lack
the power that the resistance isn't
quite the same so that's what I'm
worried about because his thing was
Flash Knockouts and that you know but I
I think he's got a solid chin so if it
he does lose it's going to take a decent
shot but the weight loss could play a
like it sometimes takes your resistance
away when you lose all that weight so um
it's interesting to see how he's going
to be I was worried that he'd lost it in
the wrong way and he would look bad but
he seems to look he looks solid he looks
strong does it doesn't look like you
know when some people look gaunt and
doesn't look like he looks great for it
actually I'm looking at him thinking
what the [__] have you been eating like
I need a he said he's been eating
chicken watermelon and lettuce that is
apparently the secret yeah I guess we
know what I'm doing next part of me's
thinking well he's not getting the
nutrients so that sort of adds to why I
think like he may be depleted come fight
night
yes uh he was holding his shoulder here
by the way and he apparently he said
that I feel like I might have dislocated
my shoulder he's dislocated it
previously twice is this his left left
hand um and once you start throwing his
shoulder out that's a problem and it
because it it becomes easier and easier
he might need surgery in the long term
for that um yeah anyone who dislocates
their shoulder it's it's a [__]
nightmare for like it keeps popping out
a lot of the time once it's come out on
apparently it happened midf fight Brian
apparently he it dis pop popped it back
in carried on fighting to be fair though
he did was predominantly throwing that
right hand he stopped throwing that jab
he wasn't throwing a left hook so it
would make
sense I mean if if look it Misfits
they're bound to be happy like the guy
talks a load of as [__] he looks good he
sells the fight he has he has that star
quality like uh like an old style pretty
boy style um arrogance about him you
know and I got no doubt the more the
money comes in we'll say more jewelry
we'll say that Swagger so he's going to
be a very hatable but lovable like
champion and um you know I think they're
hoping that they can build him up and
and build him into a star and and that
was it was a star maker performance so
congrats to him man would you want to
see a Trilogy of this or do you think
it's done Joey in there with him next my
guy he won't be a champion for long then
yes come on get me a truck suit with
kick off on it or something yeah kickoff
tracksuits um but no I I I mean look it
it's one of those where there'll be a
lot of eyes on that fight mate and uh
you know it'll be a fun time right yeah
100% look you heard me at the end of
that fight I was cheering for Dean at
the end of it because out of the two of
them that's the fight that's more
exciting and I I'll lay my cars on the
table that's a much more winnable fight
you know I think I beat Evil Boy but I
think the fight that I got a bit more
cryp tonight for the opponent in is
definitely the fight thing about you is
you're a good talker and Dan's a talker
and what you want is to Hype the fight
and you want people who are going to
talk a lot and I think youed two will
clash in a good way and it'll make for
exciting moments thing is that I think
like in terms of making the fight happen
if you got a plan of how you're going to
give him no choice but to accept the
fight because that's the biggest thing
and now he's going to have so many with
the Matchmaker so that's it no uh at the
end at the end
ofs few Brown envelopes under the table
never going to miss but no like look I
would say this I ain't going to be able
to have the same sort of poing turns and
numbers on social media and things like
that as de the great but what I would WR
there by the way you're wrong there yeah
you're already like your audience the
Chelsea audience absolutely love him so
they're already massively engaged what I
would say is if you look at the fighters
we respect the most we respect KSI
massively tonight much more in a way
than we even respect Logan Paul as the
general boxing fan because what's KSI
doing tonight he's fighting a real boxer
why do we respect Jake Paul so much he's
fighting real boxers and I'm not saying
I was a professional boxer because I
wasn't but I'm someone that's had a
handful of fights and I've won a handful
of fights and I've done you know half
decent things in boxing on the
unlicensed scene and whatnot so Dean's
gone above the level now where you're
looking at him against other Fighters
and you're going you know really like
who on Misfits do you think's really
going to give him major issues he's
knocked out more or less everyone he's
been in the ring with he's dropped
everyone he's been in the ring with so
I'm not saying go and fight a pro boxer
I'm saying go and fight someone who
knows their way around the ring and can
have a fight and isn't going to get in
there and play to your tune so that's
the only thing I could say with it
whether he chooses to do it or not who
knows well he will he will because I
think you'll win your introduction fight
and then that's when You' you've got the
case to make oh okay so you're doing a
fight before that yeah so the Joy's
fight will be this year Misfit and then
we'll look to hopefully make a t we
haven't got an opponent yet but it's
either going to be elbrook or arms arms
Kone for my first
one yeah um so next up yeah so puy slim
I can't wait for that don't forget guys
if you could hit the like button and
subscribe shout out to everyone watching
uh we've got the most [__] annoying
Advent on right now protect this house
[__] made this who made this Advent
honestly I know under ARA paid some
middle class [__] pretend that they know
what the [__] happens in we protect this
house no what I mean just protect it
protect his house the [__] are we
talking about there Alex Ferguson
imagine him giving that speech at all
traa [__] God yeah in it oh it's so wa
Roy ke mate
prot honestly who the [__] thought that
that was what people say at football man
no I've never heard it
[Laughter]
ever I'm starting to get excited okay
can I get some cheese
yeah Josh we to some cheese mate there's
some cheese over there there's some uh
we got a shuty there um what do we uh
what do we Okay okay let's talk about
the skill Gap in tonight's uh fights do
we think it's close enough that we in
either fight if one guy has a bit of an
off night the other guy or or the
pressure gets to them or do we think
that in both fights the skill back skill
Gap is just too much cuz I think the
intangibles are the most exciting bits
but they only they only come into effect
when it's close for me personally I
think obviously the Logan P against
Dylan danis fight is the one that's a
little bit closer in terms of if one
over performs one underperforms then you
can maybe see something happening there
I think even if Tommy Fury and this is
just my personal opinion for what it's
worth I can't I can't lie because you
know I want to suit a narrative I do
personally think that even if Tommy Fury
underperforms a little bit in this fight
I still do only give KSI A Punch's
chance in that fight but that's it's
just my opinion listen and I've been
wrong before I could be wrong again I
agree I think I think he's got all the
advantages in the actual boxing
experience he's got the naturally bigest
size uh the size advantage and I just
think if we getting experience just
skill level I mean I I personally
haven't seen anything from KSI where I
think yeah you look like a good fight I
know he's knocked a few guys out but I
can't kind of say to what level because
the guys haven't been great so until I
see him fight someone which we're going
to see tonight that's when I'll beat say
how good he is or how good he is yeah a
lot of my prediction video was a
struggle because I was like he's never
fought anyone with anything coming back
yeah yeah since the Logan pole fights so
I'm going off of a lot of guesswork and
estimations and a lot of emotion as well
obviously I want the guy uh to win um
and I I I've picked them to win because
I'm just in this YouTube mode of belief
and and praying oh you got your cheers
lad no no I'm good I'm good you sit
yourself down you sit yourself down um
but uh we got Logan Paul on our screen
quickly how he looks in amazing ship
he's in great ship yeah he just showed
off the cuts can he pulled to the to the
left hand side showed his cheek it
didn't look too bad but it's definitely
swollen a little
bit under the eye looks a little bit
yeah um and look I I I'm I'm going with
KSI and and until he loses I'm I'm going
to continue to um but in terms of let's
play matchmaker and I want the audience
to get involved as well because
obviously can't actually help with this
sort of stuff so in the event of a look
we'll use the first fight Logan Paul
Dylan danis If Logan
wins who do we think he should fight
next it's a tough one there's options
out there you've got a lot of Big Time
MMA guys Tommy Fury yeah I I was going
to say Tommy Fury Tommy I mean
regardless of whether Tommy wins or
loses to KSI I think yeah Tommy fury
because the natural fight I guess to if
KSI wins is Jake Paul 100% like no more
bollocks what if what if KSI loses even
Jake Paul then yeah because then we both
lost to the same guy the problem I think
we have here is if Tommy Fury comes
through tonight comfortably Logan PA is
not going to want to fight Tommy fury
because because I think that Logan PA
like you know like if KSI loses I don't
at all think that he's just going to
step away from boxing that's him done I
think he'll five more fights I think
even if Logan wins I could put my money
on it that he carries on boxing because
with Jak Paul and recently with KSI we
sort of think like they're fully they've
got both feet in this boxing pool right
now and they're doing this boxing thing
with Logan I've never felt like that so
I think that obviously the only way that
you make Logan against Tommy is If Logan
comes through with flying colors or
maybe Tommy comes through in a way that
maybe we saw him come through against
Jake where maybe he suffers a knockdown
but gets over the line maybe he
underperforms a little bit but still
gets the job done then I think we could
potentially see that fight if there's
chinks in the armor the only thing is if
it isn't a conclusive Tommy Victory I
think KSI will do everything in his
power to make the rematch if he loses
and he has that power and he has that
power because he won't be able to live
with that I don't think yeah mean um
interestingly Tyson Fury yeah Tyson is
there oh [__] um he he he doesn't he
hasn't he's forgot to zip his jacket
down he was just showing off his stomach
his his belly so he unzipped it belly
was out not joking he looks Slimmer
there like compared to when we saw the
last face off between him andu he looks
a lot Slimmer yeah he's in fight camp
now for Inu which is a really
interesting fight if I'll be honest if
there's you know how you have that
moment where you think if I could just
go in time and make a make a fight
change direction I'd love and gone out
and knock that [__] clean out I
would laugh in his face so hard because
the thing is his greed is what is given
him that fight his Greed for an easy
fight for the biggest amount of money
and just to have the usk fight lined up
already it's so overlooking it's so
disrespectful and I'm not saying it's
going to happen but to land flat on your
face is that big huge Fist and I'll be
honest there is no man I've ever shared
a room with who's more intimidating than
Francis andu like if you if you set me
real real fight no rules Francis and
garu would leave nothing left of Tyson
Fury we'd be picking the bones out of
like francis's teeth at the end of that
night you know what I mean so I just
love that moment it' be like yeah you
asked for this did you and you lined up
you sck neck it' be great it' be great
it ain't going to happen cuz he's going
to get his head jabbed off but I'm just
saying it would be lovely I mean yeah
there is that element cuz like when when
a fight is predictable especially when
there's a lot of money involved it it
there is a bit of a bad taste in the
mouth and then add on top of that
pre-planning the next fight yeah what it
it just shows that there is no fight
this is anyone who really buys up it
with you or you got got to think about
it what you yeah it takes the whole like
substance and almost like morals of what
fighting is about it's like the winner
of this gets this person or the winner
it's not supposed to be predictable at
that level yeah do you know what I mean
it's not meant to be predictable let's
do this whole pre-plan like that ruins
the whole almost story The Magic of
fighting you know the reason people are
upset with Tyson Fury in my opinion
around this Francis and garu fight is
because the way that Tyson Fury has
obviously spoke in the past about um you
know being the man that can beat anyone
in his era and whatnot the way I see it
is this Tyson Fury whether you think
this is right or wrong has seen his as
Anthony Joshua usyk Deontay Wilder maybe
one or two others right so the upand
comers that he could have potentially
took on maybe a herovic maybe Aang
someone like that instead of the Francis
in ganu fight he's looking at and he's
thinking okay tougher fights for nowhere
near as much money and as much as we can
sit here and go well no give the fans
what they want at the end of the day you
could say to me now you got a decision
to make do you make the fans happy
people who yes have supported your
career and helped you get to the
position you're in or do you make your
family financially stable I am going
with with the latter option so what I
would say here is when you look at the
Tyson Fury thing you know at the end of
the day whether he fights in garu or not
we got to really wait until all is said
and done because that man is the best
fighter the best heavyweight that we
have seen of this current generation it
is a great point if he hadn't just
fought Derek chisora for the third time
when you're fighting Derek chora for the
third time which is a pathetic fight
like you might as well just pick anyone
at that point and you then line and so
we all hear that and he goes no but I'm
fight we're fighting Youk next okay
still ridiculous but okay then you fight
a guy who's never even had a boxing
match it just makes a mockery out of it
so like and I don't even mind the Naru I
think the Naru fight's a fun fight right
like the rocky uh Apollo story almost of
like oh this shouldn't really be
happening it's the fact that he hasn't
fought Jang he hasn't fought YK he
hasn't fought so many of these top guys
of his era and then parzer I'm calling
the great but then come the end of his
career if we go and I know this is
hypothetical we can't necessarily do
this but come the end of his career if
he finishes his career having fought usk
and Anthony Joshua no herovic no Jiang
no Joyce none of the other contenders
just those two yeah and obviously the
three fights against Deontay Wilder do
we then sit back at that and go yeah
well you didn't fight this up and com
upand Comer who eventually down the
line's probably going to get beat by
someone else or do we go okay there's a
question if you say you're the greatest
heavyweight of all time but if we look
at that individually for that era from
the the mid to late 2000s up until 2022
2024 whenever he retires and then go you
are undoubtedly the best heavyweight of
your time if he has got those wins
against those Fighters and the way that
Fury will look at it is he's going to
beat those Fighters I personally also
believe he's going to beat those
Fighters so I think that that's the
question there when you look at it at
the end of things and and as a fighter
especially someone like Tyson Fury who
we all know is very Savvy when it comes
to managing his career that's the way
he'll look at it that is the way he'll
look it as well I I also think there's
an element of he's looking at stuff like
this Misfits and going there's all this
crossover happening there's always these
guys are all breaking the rules of
boxing you know traditional they're not
real boxers yeah yeah but he's prob
going well why why can't I do whatever
the [__] I want cuz you're the
heavyweight TR of the world you've got a
responsibility to the belt and to the
but there's almost an element of like
yeah I'm I'm the champion of the world
so therefore I can do whatever the [__]
I want and you know I mean I I almost
feel there's an element as well where
he's like I've gone to Deontay world as
backyard I've gone to klips Coast like
let me do something where I go and earn
like this amount I think he's going all
yeah I deserve it that that is a thing
got a mention there and it's a massive
point in terms of like recency bias and
I'm not accusing you of this but what
I'm saying is when you look at Tyson
Fury's career everyone will go to the
most recent things so they'll go you
know you haven't really fought anyone
who's been a real challenge to you since
before the Dylan Wyatt fight but at the
end of the day when you're looking at
the bigger picture and you go you took
that Deontay Wilder fight when everyone
around you apart from your promoter who
wanted the D there told you not to take
that fight yeah you went into the
rematch fair enough then it's another
story but when you first first at that
fight the odds were stacked against you
when you went out to dorf not only were
the odds stacked against you with The
Bookies you saw the tricks that
Klitschko was trying to pull with the
ring mat and all these other things and
different times in his career when he
has took you know fights that he didn't
have to when he rematched John mderma
after a controversial decision he's done
a lot of things in his career that at
this point now although we've got this
recency bias and people are go we want
to see you in there with the topy bias I
think it's called accountability so if
you want all the credit for fighting
Klitschko you want the credit for
fighting Deontay Wilder you also get the
credit criticism of taking a third easy
like the most easy fight known to man
against chisora um and and that's just
the way the game is like you can't
expect and that's why he's been caught
out here with his reputation his
reputation is suffering because he isn't
thinking logically in my opinion he's
thinking all about himself what do you
think lo I I just don't think like I
know what you're saying there but if you
look in recent years we've discussed
this before the only real big fight that
he's took is being the Wilder fights but
other than that he's not had any really
not notable fights really and in recent
years when he's had the opportunity to
fight Joshua he put a time scale on
signing a contract he done the same with
USIC I just think in recent years he's
had every opportunity as the Gypsy King
the fighting man what he's meant to
stand by to kind of cement his legacy
and he's done everything to make it
difficult for his opponents to make them
fights happen so to your point law
Anthony Joshua has way more World title
defenses than than Fury has so we're
talking about Legacy you're talking
about at the end of the day but even
right now in the grand scheme of Legacy
all right Fury hasn't taken a loss but
if we're talking about a defending
champion and and what embodies the word
Champion Anthony Joshua was more of a
champion to me than Fury and only when
Fury proves that point eventually will I
acknowledge that but even then we're
going to be looking at a career where
you go God it could have been so much
more like you're meant about what what's
it called um yeah like I mean these guys
aren't really World level you're
talking you're talking about on his way
up some of his fights but when he's
reached the top I can't think of many
fights that are are notable other than
the Wilder fight klitsch fight was a
ballest he kind of I think he fought a
Klitschko what which was at his worst he
underperformed on the night and I just
think when you look at Anthony Joshua
how many times he's defended against any
anybody he's always took on whoever's
been in front of him In fairness to him
even when he was quite a novice Pro
really when he won his world title I
just think like Anthony sorry Champions
are supposed to be brave there something
I look at Tyson Fury I go when it when
it comes to you being brave in the face
of you've done it before with the Wilder
fight when you were overweight that was
Brave but we haven't seen enough of that
because you're supposed to set an
example we're supposed to live through
you and go wow look at what you when
you're beating up an old fat like you
know with all due respect a guy who's
not in the best shape in chazar
no threat to you what is a chion about
that I'm not it when when you talk there
about the the risks he's taken and and
the thing you mentioned there is the
Klitschko fight right I understand that
and I understand that we then saw
Anthony Joshua go and stop Klitschko two
years later by the way that was two
years later and when you look at that
Klitschko fight when he fought Klitschko
Klitschko had been G to points with most
of his opponents he then had went out to
the states and had a career best
performance maybe not the best of his
career but best in recent years of that
time stopping Bryant Jennings in the KN
round or whever it was really putting a
beat down on him so actually when you
take yourself back to that time that
klitch Co that went into the fury fight
was regarded as being really well and
someone that has box to a high level
yourself you'll understand that there's
there's a fine line between someone
underperforming and someone being
massively nullified and I think that
when you see the amount of success that
Klitschko had against Joshua two years
later okay Joshua's stoppage was more
impressive but you got to give Fury
credit for the way he dealt with
Klitschko in no no agreee with you to a
point I think for whatever reason
Klitschko he' never fought a man that
big and I think In fairness he kind of
did get nullified and I think whether he
just he wasn't used to fighting a bigger
man whatever the reason was he
underperformed and I think the Klitschko
who fought Joshua was a much better
fighter whether that's because like
you've just seen Fury nullif fight him
and didn't give him the opportunity to
perform it's really hard to say but them
are the only two fights I can honestly
say of Fury's main fights which are
notable um we've got Slim coming out now
Lads and he is performing he's giving
the big the the Pereira uh bow and arrow
look um he's a good answer yeah I like
this guy a lot he is so charismatic and
uh a hell of a puncher um and so papy is
waiting for him this is a title fight
for the middleweight belt
165 um slim is not the favorite in terms
of the votes on Doone uh let us know in
the chat what you think is going to
happen The Lads will tell us but to be
honest he should be he's the one only
one out of these two is undefeated and
he is massive for the weight you know
he's got 6' one or something like that
he's very tall yeah for real I mean I
think like he's used to I know it sounds
weird but like he's used to his body at
this weight and I think that is so vital
it's like Anthony Taylor against Kenny
like he's used to performing in those
conditions in that body that he's in and
I think like whoever's got the more
experience in those circumstances is
going to have an advantage can I also
just say like these shots of the Arena
like it's hitting me like
this this is actually mental like how
big this is bro this started in a
warehouse this started in an actual
Warehouse bro you know how I commentated
the first fight I'm not joking I put I
got he sent us this link right we
transfer I was like okay I'll download
this fight Theo looks [__] mad jesz in
boxing gloves and then I was like and
we're under way and I just pulled my
phone up video recorded RI the video out
of it and just sent it to him and he was
like yeah I'll slap that over no problem
[__] mental and now we since then
we've gone on to say Floyd me where
they're fighting this whole scenario got
Eddie Hearn ringside Chris Eubank Jr
Tyson Fury just doing a speech like this
is boxing now and it's actually is the
biggest boxing event of the Year man you
[__] created the whole thing you
should have put [__] 20% on the whole
thing that is the biggest thing is it
that is the biggest thing you know
obviously we didn't do pay-per-view for
our fight so we didn't earn the big the
big but this is no surprise though
because if people who know Joe know like
you're a extremely creative guy and
you're Innovative right so like you
always come up with new Concepts that
people don't do you do things in your
own way and uh you should be proud man
yeah man for real for real like
obviously like I don't like to go around
like my mom tells me like you should you
should take more credit you should tell
people but I feel like you just seem
would seem a bit of a [__] being
like Oh by the way that's that's me that
did that that's me that did that at the
end of the day like yeah we started it
but like credit to the guys that have
now taken it to where it is you know JJ
Ms as much J Paul all of it like as much
as I've had my beef and whatnot like
they've made this from obviously the
seed that was planted you know so like
Fair Play Man think you'd being
extremely humble yeah you wouldn't catch
Carl froch being that humble m i met
call recently and he pulled his Hall of
Fame ring out and he was like what
that so you know what he was like he was
like I'd love to smash Jake Paul's face
in you and in my head I'm like well why
don't you then like as in like that is
such a fun fight Paul froch at his age
obviously is still a threat even at that
age you spot him right he's an absolute
Legend but those two would make magic
happen they're such [__] talk and I
think Call's actually a better [__]
talker than he's ever
been he's a bit more he was funny then
but he's he's way more of a showman now
he's grown into it did you see the video
when he said I will send your Jan a
[__]
ore when he grit and he he he goes he's
in his gym and he's got these two WBC P
like you see them you'll never [__]
have them you it was so good man he beat
us a poker by the way we're saying there
we're saying there about you know
influenc of boxers boxing other xboxers
and things like that we were talking
earlier about the roots for both men you
know Win Lose or Draw I've said it to
you before I I feel like I've come up
with a brilliant idea here Tommy Fury
comes through with flying colors do you
know what the fight from is David Hay
wow and people are go people are go what
are you going on about hear me out right
David Haye is in the in the get quick
predictions for everyone uh SL Sal
puy salt papy want slim slim yeah I
think salt papy but he's light at the
weight I really want Sal papy to win so
I'm going to go for salt papy yeah I I
like I like salt papy because of the way
transformation and he's like G yeah he's
inspired all I feel like he can get down
lighter though I feel like he could go
down to I just feel as if the weight
loss is going to be negative yeah I
could beong I'm to see I think either
look I think slim should be the favorite
but the thought's got something special
so David here because of the beef with
the furies maybe right David a obviously
had the canceled fight with Tyson Fury
David Haye actually fought in the grand
scheme of things not that long ago on a
thriller card against Joe fornier yeah
David Haye completely outclassed him KSI
also beat him David Haye in the best
possible way is an ego maniac and David
way two [__] girlfriends of course
yeah David Haye would look at that and
he'd go I'd beat a Tommy Fury and
obviously the buildup with John
everything that goes into it I could see
that being a yeah that that would be a
good Misfit Sal papy just leaps in there
uh with that left hand he's obviously uh
a Southpole uh he he looks sharp uh
obviously it's early in the fight but
like he's he's he's not looking like he
did against at so far he looks like he's
got a bit more Fitness about him he
looks like he's hitting hard still
though doesn't he when I was just even
them little short shots yeah you know
what he's just got that thing where he
just when he connects I might have to
retract my uh prediction then my
favorite thing about uh so papy is is
um he he he just has a a natural
understanding of boxing and the madest
thing about it was when he first burst
on the scene people were like no way
have you just started doing this and he
was like no I've I've oh good good hooks
from so puppy and he he said he taught
himself how to box by watching man p his
countryman and salt is in the in the
corner here and he is putting it on he's
smiling speaking about watching money
back he's a natural killer look at the
gloves he's got on he's got the CL Ray
on we always saw Patman he's literally
doing the belt sign um and he's smiling
um and it was such a nice moment when he
came out and said uh Manny Paco had
followed him on Instagram made his whole
in the air basically you know what a
massive credit to Salt papers right I
was uh listening to a bit of the talk
sport boxing coverage of this the other
day Gareth DAV he was actually wrong on
what he said but he went not for the
first time yeah yeah he went the thing
with salt puy is he had 60 amateur
fights right now that's completely it's
completely wrong and it's it's it's poor
research on his behalf however it's a
back-handed compliment to S papy because
he wasn't going how he had 60 amateur
fights he was saying it and he thought
that it had a lot of weight to what he
was saying he actually thought it was
true so just for someone that's been in
boxing that long where how how highly
you regret U regard him whatever but for
someone who's been around top level
boxing to have been told had 60 am
fights and then believe it it shows how
good that f is compliment is it what are
we saying here Loza can I get your
opinion on the way salt is sort of
entering in here he's he does seem to be
trying to set set it up and he's
definitely lining the left hand he just
looks like he's got the better timing
and distance he's kind of looking to
counter him and catch him yeah we're
seeing a lot of faints from slim but
it's almost like yeah do the faints but
to set something up don't just faint get
the respect for the faints to actually
you haven't landed anything um slim is
he's grimacing here and he looks a bit
hurt I don't know if he's ready for that
power and it was funny because we had a
little bit of a an issue with slim
taking this fight initially didn't seem
to uh what he wanted more money uh which
is quite public at this point uh but
they managed to get him to take it and
credit to him for taking you know the
fight but you do wonder when someone is
a bit iffy about taking a fight where
you're like like I mentioned earlier on
with Kenny wasn't as First Choice
against Anthony Taylor swarms with Ed
Matthews didn't really fancy it and now
we're in a situation where are we seeing
let protect this
house are we seeing this again where
we're looking at a go I can see why you
weren't Uber keen on this fight you know
what it is I think it it sends an an
internal subconscious message to
yourself when you don't don't say yes
I'll accept that challenge straight was
like of course yeah yeah yeah I think it
it tells yourself something when it gets
it's difficult when it you know what I
mean in those moments where you get
really tested going back so slim was at
the
175 pound category he was the belt
holder saw papy was there fighting for a
title shot Slim moved down and a lot of
people said oh so they're not going to
fight each other so papy then moved down
and it was almost like yeah I'm not
saying that there's a narrative there
but it's just an interesting thing you
know when we look at the tactics so far
Salt Salt papy obviously the one coming
forward he's the one putting pressure on
he's the one doing a lot better when it
comes to punches landed so far in the
first round whether it changes here or
not we saw slim sort of looking for that
one punch in a way almost sort of
looking to time him set him up almost
like he knows he's the fighter with the
power and with the ability to stop sort
papy but we've never seen anything in Su
papy's career so far to say that he has
got any vulnerability when it comes to
being
hit I I
mean there's some nice body shots going
in from Sal papy here and it's the twist
that he gets in those hips man
so what it is he he does like say like
the hook left hand and he really takes
his head offline like so he's not there
he doesn't lunge in his and his head's
there to be hit like he He makes himself
oh apart from what we're seeing here
careful now careful don't get greedy
don't get greedy yeah that's what we may
be seeing um I I think that's some good
exchanges from both guys here but Slim's
pinned against the ropes here and uh all
papy if you're a judge you're going to
look at the aggression aren't you and
and think that he's winning the fight so
far but I mean the thing about as he
definitely has power I just I mean I
just don't know he needs to make a
statement on on Sal papy to get his
respect cuz he's just walking him down
so far he just look like he's fighting
with fear you know what I mean when s
PPP is in close he doesn't look
comfortable yeah there's a tentative
sort of aura about him and I think like
that's the issue like obviously as
viewers you can't feel what the what the
fighters can feel but there may have
been a shot say like in the first round
that really lit up slim and is now ever
since then we've seen a more t ative
side yeah he's he's backpedaling a bit I
think my only worry for Sal papy in
terms of the way he's he's controlling
the fight is he faded a lot against a
but he was a different looking guy then
and he's definitely looking fitter and
stronger now and he's putting it on him
but it's some good shots from slim I do
think it's very different against
Anthony Taylor when you look at the
pressure tactics that Anthony Taylor
will put on you the way he'll make you
uncomfortable and we've said before
earlier in the card it's a lot easier to
reserve your energy when you're sort of
the one cutting off the bring and for
the most part that's what you're seeing
a lot of the time here from Sal papy so
I don't think he'll be anywhere nearest
drained Fitness wise in this second
round in this fight as he would against
anony Taylor slim is he's just dipping
the head down he's he he's he's not
engaging in a proper boxing match right
now he's not he's not using his job or
nothing funny because his coach is
actually a really high level World level
coach world champion trainer and he said
we're going to get he said shot there he
said the thing with Sal papy is a jab
will do him well you've not thrown a
[__] jab All Night P so I don't know
what the [__] that was about and I'm
sure he's told SL to do it but he's
abandoned the game plan by the looks of
it yeah it's a lunging jab like like
salt papy takes his head offline where
he takes where when he shoots Slim's
leaving his head right there when he's
jabbing and it's yeah man I think we
need to give some credit to Salt papy's
defense here as well like good M yeah in
terms of being able to like I always got
told when I when I was learning about
defense is like make a Miss but only
just make a Miss because obviously the
less you make a miss the less distance
you've got to then come back and
obviously yeah the closer you are in
range to your opponent the able you the
more ability you've got to counter punch
them and that's what we're seeing from
sh papy so far so I'd put him up two
rounds so far in this fight it's that
South Pole Advantage as well I think
that's the difference uh Slim's really
struggling with that southp pole stance
and that's when you've got your both got
the jab come from the same angle it's
kind of your Clash he's kind of
tentative
you were saying there sorry you were
saying there about not using the jab so
much in the first round he attempted the
jab a lot of times but I think when
you're not landing something as much as
sometimes it's like no no stick with it
it will come as things slow down it's a
bit hard to when you're not Landing it
and you're also getting countered with a
guy who can punch as well you start
hesitating yeah as well Jake Paul and
deji got into some sort of heated
exchange I mean having seen obviously
Jake fight Tommy as well here's what
here's how it play out I feel like this
is why I didn't want to come here
tonight because all these little people
that I already beaten dusted up making
their name off of me this is some stupid
ass clout [__] but whatever he wants
it's about it's not about that we're
here to to promote the fight and I
didn't know he was going to be here
though I don't really here um so yeah uh
apparently Jake uh apparently deji said
recently he thought you could beat Jake
and you know you know how that goes oh
slim making it messy and and actually
connecting a little bit this is the best
I've seen from Slim in this fight so far
far in terms of just actually connecting
with solid shots he's actually letting
his hands go yeah and also is Sal papy
getting a little tired oh it's a good
shot good left salt
papy yeah yes salt papy looks really
good at this weight it's when he lands
as well he really thrives off it doesn't
he yeah he has that like that when he
starts smiling and he's hurting you it's
kind of like floes sometimes you know
like in terms of the
mannerism um before we went live earlier
on and we were looking at some of the
fights and it's like okay they're fun
fights but there's not a real massive
skill level here pretty much every
contest since we've gone live I'm not
saying in professional boxing but for
influencer boxing this is showcasing
exactly why so many people love it and
why this is going to do so many
pay-per-view buyers because the level of
these boys to have took up boxing
whether they took them up three years
ago four years ago five years ago is of
a real real high so puppy is getting a
little tired here you know I've I've
seen Pros early in the career perform
worse than this I think the level's good
and it's 50/50 that's a that that's what
brings you on so much but actually fight
you fight a journeyman that's looking to
cover up okay you might learn a thing or
two if anything you go backwards it's
it's it's can be
deal I've uh I've got people tugging me
in a tweet from Mark goldbridge from a
few years back that was a decent shot
from SL oh Slims oh Slims Landing some
decent shots uh goldbridge put a twe a
few years back saying the Newcastle take
over in the mud true Jordi crying and
loads of people that was like 202 and
now people are taging me the man T
what's it's not looking good is
it I I think Slims had his best round
yet in round three um I if I'm if I'm so
puppy I'd probably take the rest of this
round off a little bit just get the get
to the corner oh he's left hand there
from Salt papy it's the head movement he
keeps slipping them shots and punishing
the only one thing and it could change
over the course of the rounds but I
don't know whether salt papy has the
power to really put a dent in slim um
but he's definitely win on my only worry
is you know this messiness here this is
where slim thrives I've seen him knock
out a guy a first temper he knocked out
first temper in a fight quite similar to
this like for me the cleaner the punches
or the cleaner the boxing that's so papy
and his game the Messier it is like this
the more slim could could upset him just
like that and he's which is weird for
being the bigger man You' think we
better at range he's actually having
more success when it's all closer SM
because he's not his jab isn't that good
for a tall guy he doesn't doesn't you
know use it with authority he's bent arm
shots he's Cuts better then yeah he's if
for a tall guy he doesn't fight like one
no not at all would we say this was 2-1
then on the scorecard so far guys yeah
you've got an argument there that's slim
might took that round you think it's I
think because we're now seeing a bit of
some punches landed I feel as if I want
to give him it but I still don't think
he won the round yeah he probably it
wasn't it wasn't like oh he won that it
it was a 50/50 on that one and the first
two were clear yeah for me if they give
him it I wouldn't argue it but he
probably still didn't win it if I'm so
up his coach I'm going stop [__]
fighting his fight like you're literally
playing the only chance he's got right
now is to to have a fight not a boxing
match just take box him make a Miss
punish him there's also the fatigue in
that as well like you know trying to it
gets to a point where they are just sort
of near each other cuz they're cuz
they're tired and answer the question
with salt puppy I think uh his new body
he can still perform good shot SL pu
he's hurt just oh he shakes his head he
really hurt going he's going and he's
really hurt so puy he needs to clinch he
he needs to clinch be over I literally
spoke he got curse of a commentator yeah
he look this is it man he's he's getting
tired in these and this is what happened
with at he got tired from after the
second round it he wasn't really there
and he's not not really and now Slim has
gotten a a real Second Wind here it's
early in the round as well yeah it's not
what he want let's see how he recovers
slim looks dangerous at this range oh my
God he's there to be hit now wow really
not good this is a bit like the W moment
where you're thinking can you hold on
lad oh every team he's punching on the
brick
yeah and I don't know if trying to fight
fire with fire is the best tactic he's
really out of it Sal puppy is in big
trouble slim is all over him and shakes
his hand salt puy says no I'm not going
down but he looks like he could go at
any second like let's see if salt puy oh
his punches I think he's blown himself
out oh every time slim comes back punch
every it's funny cuz at the start of the
fight the the acceleration in those
hands of Sal papy you're like whoa
there's a real difference but by round
three Sal Slims is exactly the same as
round one it's not and by and that's
when it starts to take effect I feel
like his body type is more that like
ectomorph marathon runner long you know
exactly he's like a n Diaz type you
don't see it at the start but it's right
there in your face to The Bitter End
right you can't he looks tired but he
just keeps
going M whoever [__] wins this has
earned it Jesus yeah
man
wow credit to Sal papy he's still really
trying to put it on him and I'm thinking
you should be getting the [__] away from
him really but and the funny thing is if
he survives this round and then can have
a big round in the last he still
probably Nicks it on the scorecards
anyway yeah after this I'd say it's two
and then yeah it's last round wins
already there's a real power decrease
coming with so papy but but but slim is
now tired because he's
oh down he is down but he's getting back
up he looks really
bad the tip of the jaw that he done you
can't keep shaking your head and get TI
you have to change the [__] F tactics
can't let that go on the oh referee ref
ref ref he's doing 20 seconds 20 seconds
can he hold on hold just grab I think
the ref needs to W what a fight what a
fight from both guys though let's slim
with the hook and he's damage in salt
puy and he SL won huge for slim salt puy
with a hell of a performance I think he
fought Slim's fight he fought Slim's
fight he didn't box him so this is what
I'm saying about the white Los right so
he after two rounds was blowing and he
he was drain BL out he did not seem like
he had that
ferocious in the 0 you know how Conor
McGregor is a sprinter you know your
third round you're like you got [__]
left you bro yeah so papy might be that
guy because he was he was even when he
was carrying more weight against at in
the third round he wasn't the same guy
we seen him go down immediately and uh
that's sometimes something that even
training it might not s it's like it's
like yeah either you have fast twitch
muscles that have that power but they
burn out quick or you're more like this
Slims body type and it tends to be for
boxing especially the longer rounds the
skinnier more ectomorph guys do you know
this is n Diaz Conor McGregor style
fight right but the problem is is for
Sal puy his eego cost him when you start
getting tugged back off mate what the
he's literally like no no there is an
element of him being buzzed though so
maybe he's not able to actually think
like oh let you know it's easy for us to
observe from here when we you know but
he's freaking buzzed many times there
and maybe he's just he's just thinking I
need to get back in this fight I'm
losing this fight so he keeps just
coming Forward credit to both guys but
this is the problem when you lose weight
you generally speaking if you look at
the history of Fighters when they've
lost too much weight especially too
quickly the res even if the fitness is
good the speed's it happened to Derek
shazor when he I can't remember who he
fought was it against Dylan whitean one
fight he lost load load of weight and he
was his engine was great but his punch
resistant wasn't there and it's the same
here puppy look good but his resistance
obviously wasn't as good and he's used
to walking through punches well I mean
that's never a good defense is it well
yeah it's no you can see though his his
ego got the better of him there man you
can't and unfortunately like he learned
a lesson against at that he needed to
bring the conditioning well he's just
learned another lesson that you can't
defend punches with your face man yeah
it's like there's a you need to know
your range sort of thing he like he was
sitting in that perfect range that is
great for slim you know Slim's not got
Slim's an inside fight yeah he didn't
show any good straight punches but those
those bent arm punches look they're
perfect for slim and he just sat in that
range perfectly for him I love slim and
I love Sal papy so you know I'm happy
for both of them that they put on a
great fight I'm happy for slim getting
the win but I feel for Sal papy because
when you have a fight right there and
you're outclassing him and the skill Gap
is there yeah and then you lose it slips
through your fingers you can't you're
never happy how would he come back from
this because he's kind of invinc he was
known for that guy being powerful he
could take a shot is like how do you
come back from that like it's that
that'll be interesting to see how he is
in his next fight I think even though
we've spoke about the weight loss I
think he goes down in weight again I I
don't think he that weight it's a
difficult one because he was he was figh
a 6' one guy and he's what 5 for8 well
you're right I mean there's a reason why
there's weird categories but he was kind
of going against that previously CU he
was he was winning he was winning
convinent so against against a much
lesser level though when you see him
Step Up Against and Anthony Taylor and
against the slim two boys that are
probably more natural at the weight and
can fight a bit that's that's sort of
when we've seen that yes you've got the
skill Co have because he lit slim up for
two rounds in that fight but maybe this
just isn't your natural weight and maybe
he'll find his home maybe one weight
division below that and then we who
there to fight at say like 155 or 150
though like in this Misfits the golden
sort of region is like 165 to 175 that's
where everyone is I don't know what what
werson uh or my mate Nate
fighter they both look like they could
cut down as well um so maybe that's a
fight that might happen but I don't know
to be fair werson Nunes against salt
papy in Brazil would still yeah do you
know what like not to judge his
performance too much but the referee
should have waved that off after that
knockdown that knockdown do you know
what reminded me of do you remember when
usyk knocked out bellu when he hit him
with the first shot and he was out on
his feet and then it was the second shot
and that's what you see there Su papy
was out after that first shot it was the
shot that he was like you can't let it
go on from there he's he's in a bad way
yeah I mean it there's been a couple of
these fights tonight Dean W uh so papy
slim where all right we've had like
we've had clear dominant wins where I
mean it wasn't totally dominant from
slim but they they all come out with
glory in a in a way you know like they
like like saly didn't get run over there
he he if anything I think he let it slip
through his fingers and as much as I say
that there it sort of contradicts what
I'm saying look at the way the at one
point in the fight with wed sharks and
um Dean the great we were saying this
has got to go here the ref needs to jump
in and actually he didn't and welled
sharks came through that so as much as I
can say that as a fan sitting here
watching it's it's it's those guys that
are called to make those decisions
apparently Conor McGregor has tweeted
out about Logan Paul uh what did he say
Josh go on Josh He said Logan me and her
what's up uh oh quite a simple one
really blown uh disrespect I'm I'm I'm
pretty sure Connor at some point will
make an appearance from everything I've
been told I mean you think about that
you got Jake Paul Logan Paul KSI Tyson
Fury Conor mcregor like the egos in that
building oh M it's mental like I wonder
who's got the biggest ego out of all of
them Connor it's got to be Connor I want
to see Conor McGregor and Jake Paul go
at it they're the two they're not even
on the card they're the two that I want
to see in that ring G at it yeah the
issue is is that it that wouldn't be
Misfits and I feel like in order to
afford that Misfits have that power I
believe I don't know would MVP I I think
it would be a cool promotion it would be
an MVP McGregor sports and entertainment
they all jump in together with Doone
yeah and the UFC will be have to be
involved because they've got Connor
under contract and it would just be a
whole load of people sharing a load of
money um he has deleted the Tweet
now classic Conor interesting yeah
that's classic Conor um he he it was
funny because uh this is how like this
is how how he thinks right so he he
tweeted me a voice recorder you look
like a little Burns victim Burns um and
then he deleted that he blocked me and
he also like blocked the kickoff
accounts as well I'm like Wow you went
deep like I'm not going to look like
bother you know what I mean like it's
just so the whole Corner McGregor thing
is very it's steeped in but this is the
thing it's steeped in insecurity and
that's why him and Floyd are like Cut
From the Same Cloth aren't they like
they to to want to achieve that to want
to be that way and so flashy it's insec
it's interesting how like McGregor's
gone from such almost like this
spiritual like artistic fighter that
inspires the world to like since Al
absolute C well since since alcohol and
drugs and you know all of that got
involved almost like the devil devil
stuff oh yeah it's taken him to become
this guy that is act like intolerable
yeah the biggest wanker in fight genuine
it's sad man like he is sad because like
he was so inspirational man that's why
when he gets absolutely smashed in the
UFC I'll just sit there with a whiskey
and go fair enough do you know what the
podcast I can't wait one day right my
fantasy podcast true Jordy Tyson Fury
Conor McGregor I don't think I'd want to
had that happen to be honest but there's
a cage there's a cage that but I think
that'd be brilliant yeah yeah John Fury
is John Fury John Fury Fury scared of
Big John than any do you know when you
meet John as well he's got [__] hands
like bin Lids you's he's got the like
you're just like yeah you you definitely
come from Viking Blood or something like
that you know well obviously Gypsy so
the only the interaction I've had with
John Fury is I was presenting um Jak a
Jake Paul fight on BT Sport and it was
me John Fury David Haye and the
presenter are the weirdest it was so
weird but we were all chatting and like
the thing that he was saying about Tommy
Fury this was when the Jake Paul
negotiation negotiations were going on
he was like so Tommy's major issue is
his mind like so much who sorry Tommy
John John Fury was saying that about
Tommy off camera and he was he was
really going into it and I was like is
what what what what's he displayed thus
far that you think would show that he's
got this frail fragile mindset you think
he hasn't been in boxing long enough
like I I know they talk like he's been
boxing for years but he hasn't actively
being competing like I mean nobody knew
about Tommy Fury until after love Island
I mean I don't know why they talk about
him like he's being this guy who's boxed
in all the junior championships and how
many he's had a he had a handful of
fights I mean in boxing terms that is
absolute novy you know what I mean he's
no different to the YouTube guys that
were watching you know what I mean
realistically he's had a few more than
more I think the thing is is he had a he
had constant tutelage from Big John from
being six years old behind the scenes
but in terms of real competition I agree
with you he has a massive advantage in
that he has been just hanging around the
gyms and Jake Paul didn't know what a
boxing gym was until five years ago or
whatever um and next up it is Logan Paul
versus Dylan danis oh my God Bad Blood
like I I think this might be one of the
most hit filled like bad blood pre-fight
buildups we''ve ever seen in history of
the world no fighter ever goes that deep
consistently I've never ever seen on a
daily basis no he he said he had 600
photographs or videos of of Logan's
fiance saved on his phone and laughed
about it Logan there was a good moment
when Logan you know that was a bit weird
like like at some point you got to say
you're a bit weird aren't you like and
it is weird it is [__] weird do you
know what it shows that Dyan Dennis does
not give a [__] no not one not one he's
just a psychopathic Behavior oh yeah I I
mentioned this earlier and obviously
people have tuned in now we talked about
the LI detector test that he did on
Misfits where he was asked questions of
do you respect Logan Paul have you gone
too far do you think you'll win every
question where you think if there's a a
smidgen of Doubt or Humanity within till
and Dan or any regret or any you know oh
he's actually not that bad no no not one
single [__] given and every single time
they went to the light attack I went
cool he's telling the truth I never I'm
going to beat him I don't care I don't
respect him every single thing where
you're like there's got to be a a crack
here not a single one and that was where
I was kind of like you know on some
level Fair Fox you're a piece of [__]
but you're actually owning it and you
really are that guy like that's like a
true psychopath you know pure denial
like you just that's all you can see
yeah there are some like there are some
people you watch these Netflix
documentaries they get on the stand and
they're like oh I didn't do it and like
Ted Bundy you're like all the evidence
is there and if you put him on the LI
detector it would come back no [__]
given I didn't do a single thing like
you know yeah it's impossible for normal
people to react that way you've got to
have something missing as as simple as
that men you talk about like dark
buildups in boxing fights I was trying
to scratch my head there and I was
thinking have we ever seen anything like
it we've obviously seen the brw breakout
between David Haye and Derek chisora
that's a split split second that's in a
moment okay we see the cage for the
first time ever in the way in between
those two but that is a moment that got
out of hand uh c myga a fighter that I
used to love to watch I remember I
remember him slapping Shane Mosley's
Miss ass in a in a press conference or a
weigh-in or something um and there's so
many more things but all of them are
like isolated incidents whereas this is
a constant daily bar it's like you know
how like my alarm clock will go off and
I'll think to myself right have my
coffee you know brush my teeth uh Dylan
danis is goes off and he thinks right
let's get on the old Twitter straight
onto Logan Paul's case the only person I
can think of is tast Mike Tyson when
he's talk about eating people's children
but like I think that's the closest but
speaking of children Logan kind of came
back with something in uh the the the
press conference where he goes what
about the kid you've abandoned and I was
I heard that me and and you could see
Dylan for a second like he didn't like
it and he was like well aware of what
the [__] and he was like what about
Josephine your daughter that you don't
bother with and I was like mate this is
just [__] mental now what else is
coming out we we have got to appreciate
there though like obviously look I
believe that personally you live by the
sword you die by the sword if you go for
someone on a personal level you have to
accept that things will come back at you
so I completely agree like Logan's with
his rights to say whatever he wants
because Dylan has gone for him on a very
very personal sensitive level but let's
not pretend it's oneway traffic Logan
Paul said stuff about his late father
you know he said stuff about the
abandoned child and things like that
this was after the [__] to be fair to
Logan so Logan was like yeah I heard you
went through a shitty time you s
drinking you got kicked out of your
Jiu-Jitsu school and Dylan kind of goes
oh you did a little research H well well
done he goes yeah I heard your dad died
and he goes he go but he didn't say it
in like a way of he he mentioned it but
it wasn't like oh you dad like you know
what I mean like he he was just prying
to see if he would get a reaction but
he's a very clever man oh and he knows
what he's doing and then he goes oh um
talk about it see what happens like you
know like and I thought oh you getting
there there's something and a lot of
people gave Logan [__] for that and I
was like you know I'm not defending
talking about people's dads in in the in
the event of no [__] talks happen and
you start bringing that up of course not
but if someone's been saying that you
know the things that he's been saying
calling your miss a [__] for [__]
three months oh I would have not held
back I would have said I would have said
everything the rules are out the window
oh yeah I would I would have been way
worse than Logan way I would have
[__] I would have been spitting on
his grave by the end of that sent I
would given a [__] no [__] get me if
you're talking about my misses like that
you could [__] die and I wouldn't
give a [__] let alone who's dead in your
family [__] you so so and I don't give a
[__] what people think of that like I'm
if you've gone there oh we're [__]
there and I want to stab you like so the
fact that Logan's kept it together I'm
like I don't know how youve [__] done
it cuz i' have been like Logan's played
you remember that TV show this is your
life like he's got [__] the Predator
guy coming out he's got like jiujitsu
guys who Dylan had of like he's been
bringing out ala to people but Dylan
handles that quite well to be but you
know like we speak about the thing of
him saying about his dad and the
daughter that's that's on the other
level but like I feel like a lot of the
stuff that Logan's done has been quite
fun like bringing Chris Hansen out was a
[__] Master stroke like if that was
me and I saw Chris Anon Rock I be said
about his taxes I'd be like mate fair
play you know did laugh that was a bit
of a funny moment the cake the bouncer
these sort of things like all right yeah
they're to get on skin oh yeah The
Bouncer and he's in this room right
now that this is where Eddie Hearn must
be watching this going [__] me these
guys are so much better than us yeah
like boers are not thinking but be fair
Logan has the money to play that kind of
game Guess flying people from all around
the globe can we just accept here that
once the once the Benchmark has been set
by Dylan danis whether you agree with it
or not is it not all fair game I think
now you're going to see a lot more of it
I think yeah you mean in general in
general in terms of what Logan has then
said and what D has then said once the
benchmarks drone
anyone I have enough
one you're all right really good oh no
oh Loza you're getting one come on we're
just going to get I'm also we'll get one
for Josh uh two VOD two whiskies we're
getting on it it's the Lan Paul let's go
mate let's go son we got be absolutely
slaughtered by the happen let's [__]
get it the one thing I will say about
the buildup to this fight though is that
I feel like Dylan's stuff seems more off
the cuff and witty and like you know
even though it is quite low and you know
all of that it does seem more natural
whereas the premeditated stuff that
Logan seems to have maybe I almost feel
like he's sat there and gone right how
can I get back him it's too let me let
me make a cake and it just sort of see
and then I almost feel like when it
delivers it it doesn't always hit as
much as when Dylan comes out with this
thing about bringing the Brazilian
jiu-jitsu guy out um to protect him from
Dylan and I was like oh that that's not
right yeah they've thought about it and
they haven't you know but it it needs to
be quick and witty it's not about spend
the weekend doing a bit of yeah yeah
yeah it's not as funny then do you know
what the funny thing is like there was
complations made and a lot of a lot of
just sort of narrative around that face
face off thing between Dylan danis and
Logan Paul and everyone was saying ah
Dylan's a rubbish talker he doesn't know
what he's doing sort of thing when it
comes to the verbals and I've actually
looked at the build buildup and I
thought you know what I think Dylan
danis has held his on really well oh
we're seeing training now with Dylan you
you said and and a lot of them closeup
clinching very Anthony Taylor type these
are spoiling
he is trying everything to uh to get a
grip on him two vodka for the other you
said it earlier he kind of stole the sh
really has he massively and and to do
that like Dylan danis is a name but
let's be honest the people that don't
follow MMA to that extent what is he
he's Conor McGregor sparring partner you
you know that that is what it is so to
come in here now and at the end of the
thing everyone began looking forward to
Dylan danis against Logan Paul you know
that Dylan danis has come in and in a
roundabout way way I'm sure Logan Paul
would change it if he could he's
actually done wonders for the sales of
this show I almost feel like a lot of
these guys who've been another Sport and
they coming to this is like it's an
opportunity to reinvent the themselves
it's like it starts all over again they
can now like you like we discussed
earlier you they weren't exactly high
level in whatever sport they come out of
but when they come to this they can
almost ruler Roost kind of be the top
guy so it's funny I'm getting a memory
of um the khabib versus Conor McGregor
fight where the one person who pissed
kib off as much as Conor McGregor was
Dylan danis he's got good form and and
it's funny because at the time people
like Dylan who the who the [__] is this
Dylan guy and uh khabib beats the [__]
out of Connor McGregor strangles him
Connor Taps out like a little [__] no
sorry
um I can't help it I've got to kick him
no and and kabib then thinks that hasn't
satisfied me I still I still want to
kick moreos jumps the [__] cage and
and then jumps straight [__] flying
knee into [__] Dylan danis and is
punching Dylan danis outside the cage
there was no title lift khabib's mates
then jump in the cage they're [__]
firing off on the Conor McGregor it was
absolute chaos and people kind of
rounded admitted Dyan Dan has caused
that like so as much as we're kind of
getting a taste of this when Dylan's the
the main attraction he's always been
good at needling and like khabib was a
stoic hard-nosed bastard he was very
good at keeping his emotions like like
you know like a Russian would be but you
know like uh when it's going against you
and when he's the one aiming his verbals
at you you absolutely hate it but I went
to school and I bet everyone round his
table did with a lot of people like
Dylan danis you know I mean there was
always a kid in every year that was like
Dylan danis and when it wasn't you that
he was giving the stick to it was
hilarious you know what I mean he used
to think he's winding him up a tree you
know what I mean and I think that's why
a lot of people are warming to him in
this buildup does that say something
about culture Society maybe so but at
the end of the day he's a guilty
pleasure isn't he really I'm really
interested to know how that clinch uh
style will work against Logan because
when I look at them I'm like well
Logan's stronger than you as well so
you're going to try and clinch up with
him I fancy Logan to just bully you yeah
but only for an amount of time because I
do feel like Logan will Tire man I feel
like he will yeah he did eight rounds
with Floyd yeah and the issue clinching
but the issue with it was yeah Floyd
wasn't clinching but also uh and the
clinching will drain the muscles and
that's probably what he's going to think
of I'll drain you and then it becomes a
Level Playing Field because the fast
switch fibers are going to be struggling
but credit to Logan in the Floyd fight
people forget about this you got a
second wind yeah sixth round Floyd
really looked at him and went I'm not
finishing you here and then Logan
started kind of come back into it a bit
and so he's I don't think he's cardio is
as problematic as people think but I
think that's Dylan's best bet for sure I
I've honestly I wouldn't be surprised if
Dylan started
sorry if Logan starers Dyan within two
rounds here do you know what I worry
about in this fight like there's more
than one way to skin a cat isn't there
and when I look at this fight I think
has Dylan won anyway do you know like
even if he loses the fight on a points
decision has he won like in Dylan's head
we got this can't got a decision the Lan
Paul and I'm I I say this as someone who
really likes this guy you can't let this
guy walk out of that ring with the
ability to go haha this was your this
was your game this was boxing now come
to my game MMA like you can't let him be
talking he has to be out on the floor
like no way but not only that when you
look at the way the buildup is gone
Dylan danis could go yeah all right you
beat me on a points decision but I
absolutely embarrassed you and gave you
a lot of problems in your personal life
not that it's right but I gave you a lot
of problems in your person life exposed
you to the world in the buildup and then
you only beat me on points and we all
know if you come over to May I'm going
to absolutely tear you apart and that's
we're getting the mind we're getting
oursel in the mind of what some people
have labeled as a psychopath here do you
know I mean like so it it could be a
case of like if Dylan doesn't get
stopped he could see this as a bit of a
moral win here I think this reminds me a
little bit of when Floyd fought Connor
and there was a moment where he thought
Floyd knew like I have to get this guy
out of here I can't let him walk out
this is my domain you know what I mean I
think there's way worse pressure on
Logan tonight even though Logan has had
three boxing matches he is not a
professional boxer like he the pressure
on Tommy Fury should be worse in reality
than what it is on Logan Logan isn't
someone who's had Lords of experience
but it's the buildup that's put that
pressure on Logan if anything I think
like that male pride [__] it's really
bad for you that in some ways though I
do almost feel like there's more
pressure on Logan right because I think
Tommy if he really Nails the perspective
as of I'm going against novice here and
doesn't buy into the whole KSI bollocks
and that aura he's just like I'm going
against GE that's been boxing a couple
years I can do my thing I think he can
simplify and actually calm his nerves
where whereas Logan I feel like no
matter how he thinks the facts are this
Giza has already caused him ridiculous
amounts of stress and there's no two
ways about that right and going into
this fight he his mind's going to be
like don't get too emotional don't get
too emot he has to you know the more he
the think that he's he's trying to
escape fact I the most emotional guy and
I think I think that's one thing that
could play into his hands but even the
even the most cool customer you got to
be rattled a little bit here like and to
a point where in a uh podcast with uh
Jake recently he was like yeah we're
going to we're going to drain him with
the the lawsuit and then if we've got to
take money off of his pay packet cuz he
can't afford to pay the lawsuit we'll
just take money every month from him and
that was when I was like oh this is d is
you only do that stuff if if yourself
you have been hurt if you're wanting to
get back at him that much oh you want to
leave then yeah you hate him that hatred
so that's why I'm saying going into this
like we say about is Logan emotional I
don't know like going into that second
KSI fight look how much he didn't want
to be there yeah you know what I mean
you look even in that face off before
the head-to-head before they fight he's
there looking the Floyd fight gave me a
lot more confidence I he evolved from
that experience fight you know what it's
like the person you were when you fought
KSI
and I think this this is years later the
Floyd fight would have helped him like
in his mind what he needs to think is I
thought Floyd Mayweather who the [__] is
this I I I don't even think the pressure
comes from I don't even think the
pressure comes from what's happened in
the buildup because I think it's more
the fact of what is what everyone
expects him how he should react because
I think he he knows how the game works
he's he's played these sort of dirty
games he's his full career this is how
he's become who he is I think it's more
the fact that every male in the country
is going mate you need to do the right
thing and absolutely bury this guy I
think that the pressure comes from what
is expected of him versus how he
actually feels emotionally about it I
think like one of the one of the points
that a lot of people make is Logan Paul
has got to Channel all this negativity
and the hatred into the performance but
saying you touched on there and I'd
massively agree with it he's like you
got to completely separate yourself from
it anything I know for a fact right I've
sparred people that I actively dislike
and I've never done well in them spars I
might have done all right but I've never
performed it might have just been a tear
up even like just in life in general the
girl that you fancy the most probably
won't be the one that you're going to
have any luck with you know what I mean
like the things that you want the most
sometimes you've got to
emotionally detach yourself from these
things and I think that in a roundabout
weird sort of way maybe that's the best
thing Logan Paul can do in this fight
yeah shout out to everyone watching by
the way we got plenty of you watching
hit that like button subscribe thanks to
all of you we we we're literally waiting
for the entrance
and it'll any second now Logan Paul
Dylan danis Bad Blood we've done a poll
Brian oh really and uh the people think
that Logan Paul is going to win he's got
62% 62% that's not that high though it's
still a close to a 50/50 like but before
you ask us for our predictions on the
fight can I ask you a question right is
there any part of you that thinks that
we're going to see a genuinely really
entertaining fight here because for me
the fight has got a bit of a spoil up
close Affair written all over it but I
could be completely wrong here
um it depends on Logan um implementing
his game plan and keeping a clear head
when I look at him I go the force you
can generate with the job you should
have you should JB the when when when
Dylan's trying to clinch you should be
[__] jabbing that head all the way to
the [__] ceiling and making him
unable to close the distance because
Dylan isn't an athlete Logan is an
athlete Dylan is a is a good Grappler if
you remember people like Ben asrin
Logan's coming out now dressed in Old
Pink uh attire uh he looks very calm um
he is um walking out with Jake Paul um
behind him with his arm in the air looks
smiling um he doesn't look worried he
doesn't look nervous he looks very calm
in the
moment do we know who that other person
was Brian the Jiu-Jitsu guy jju you know
the is that who he is yeah the jiujitsu
guy that he brought to the weigh in or
whatever I'm not sure that's him
actually I thought it wasn't I know uh
as boxing fans we the one at the back
yeah that's that's the old school I know
as boxing fans we really shouldn't care
about stuff like this but Logan Paul
ring walking first yeah I saw that yeah
I'm surprised by that supposed to be the
as apparently yeah he's definitely the
as side mean he's done the [__]
pay-per-view percentage but Dylan um I
don't know Dylan Dylan apparently had
some sort of entertaining ring
that he had apparently Dishonored said
that that ain't going to happen um
apparently uh by the way Anan Gibb has
tweeted out a picture of uh Sal papy
saying Manny Pacquiao didn't die for
this uh so so Gibb playing the promo
game getting his tweets out there um
we're going to do quick predictions um
and and there was Mega Security in the
ring for this so that nothing happens
beforehand uh I'm going to go first with
Josh what do you think mate I think
Logan Paul cleans out in two rounds I
think it's that simple scrappy fight
Logan pull on points big Los I'm going
Logan stoppage
um third round Jo uh Joe how many rounds
is this fight six uh six rounds six
rounds I believe it goes the distance
Logan Paul wins oh that I can't have
that I can't I just think it does I no
I'm not disagree like I'll get you you
got I just think with with Dylan knowing
how to an extent to
smother grab wrestle C probably defend
himself to an extent I just I just think
he'll evade Here Comes Dylan now I'm
going to predict Logan Paul inside two
rounds and Dylan danis is smiling he's
getting his big moment and just to be
clear I know Dylan has performed in high
pressure moments World Championships of
Jiu-Jitsu where he's had to uh you know
Spa um sorry he's had to roll with four
guys in one night um but this is his
first Main Event 20,000 in the arena and
he is loving every minute of it by the
looks of it uh about you said about the
capacity of the arena there and Joe you
said this earlier about look at what
influencer boxing is now doing selling
out the me Arena yeah they could have
sold out the Spurs arena for this I
honestly believe that's sounds like a
bold statement I think they could have
sold out the Spurs arena for this
100% God I'm feeling the [__] like I'm
just thinking Logan you cannot let this
guy walk out of here you need to put a
nail in him fit in the Vodka
um uh Dylan is trying to go Logan right
now um you know over the security guards
and the crowd are absolutely hyped and
uh Logan is
smiling and he looks yeah they both look
very confident like right now we're
seeing no sign of any uh insecurity here
they're both very confident um despite
the going out last night
uh and uh I'm feeling this like I'm
[__] this is I know it is a co-main
but it feels like a main event it if any
like the fact that they've doubled up
like this oh my God shout out to Misfits
man like th this is like Eddie Hearn
must be sat in that front row thinking I
could never do this I could never ACC
yeah yeah but when he gets interviewed
after he'll still go yeah well I'll put
Logan Paul car ey on the second time
around and it's like no mate Brian did
that keep your
mouth it was me who said is there anyone
you want to call out so I still haven't
got 5% of
PR oh we're not doing the anthems we're
doing going to cut to the underarm
commercial we doing the national anthems
I'd rather honestly I I I really I'm not
a fan of national anthems before boxing
match man um but yeah it was a real good
insight to say Dylan backstage there
like um hitting the one two grabbing so
at least we we totally know the game
plan we know that
I would highly doubt that Dylan knew
that that was getting streamed on he
wouldn't have known that the C you know
what's interesting Logan's done no media
like no extra media all week and there
was no no cameras in his dressing room
nothing I wonder why what are you hiding
I'm not sure but if if there's one thing
I am sure about is he looks like Ivan
Drago right now Ivan Drago he's sculpted
from Stone there remember like in the
Rocky movies remember how Ivan Drago was
sculpted though what I mean he looks
chiseled compared to Dylan Dylan looks
smooth you know like cuz Dylan fought it
at 170 well to weight I think yeah and
even then he physically looks a lot
smaller doesn't he it's it's a little
bit like the Tommy KSI difference little
bit yeah apparently they're booing the
American national I'm not surprised what
the [__] are you thinking we're in
Manchester what the [__] who thought
this was a good ide and this poor
singers having to sing she'll never
forget
it got the stars and stripes in the ring
as well oh coach the the WWE commentator
giving that God bless got to be kidding
my he he's flying the flag here look at
this oh god oh no oh no wow Logan's
flying the American Flag how to make the
audience turn on you to be fair that
that that point that you made a while
back about the uh the W experience and
now like Logan is totally comfortable in
front of crowds he is weak in week out
performing on the mic like he will be
more at home than than even anyone else
he at tonight there is cuz he is selling
out Arenas all the time 100% And yeah
like I said about you know it's he's
used to be in front of a crowd and it's
a it's a very negative reception it's
that booing anytime he gets on the mic
anything he says you know so he may even
be trying to make the crowd boo yeah
[__] you know that may I know Jake Paul
does that he loves that sort of you know
that rolls him up do you know one slight
difference and maybe Logan would sort of
understand this or not but it's like you
know in WWE when they're booing you they
are booing Logan but they booing the
character like a l i don't think it was
with him because he got booed from the
minute go it wasn't like he went in and
went I'm going to do something to make
them boo they were like [__] this
YouTuber trying to get in on our sport
you a't here for for us you're here for
your own brand your own [__] they
hat another thing that I was making the
point earlier on about WWE and misfits
and whatever and emphasizing how massive
influence of boxing and misfits in in
general has become like you look at WWE
back in the day yeah Kurt Angle he wins
Olympic gold and then goes to WWE other
Brock Lesnar couldn't go on fight on the
UFC until he had left the WWE now you
got lights of Logan Paul Moonlighting
and a bit of WWE and then going on to
Misfits and it's like okay you can come
back over after you're done with that
like they they very much understand as
well like this is where this this is
going to bring this is going to bring we
viewers as well right like um and oh my
God I I just keep thinking like I think
Logan's going to spash but look at this
he's doing the thing that he did before
KSI where he's very just sort of it's
good to see he's got Lis Ortiz in his
Corner as well I
mean wait whereas you see that Dylan
he's very much just sort of like seems
to be bouncing and in the flow whereas
Logan does very still and it just seems
a little bit like you don't do this to
me no mate M I know what I know I need a
knockout 100% man I know what you're
saying I don't think he's a massively
confident guy every time the cut he
realizes the cameras there he gives them
a chicky look but deep down I don't
think he's got that to him in the run up
to this they said what do you do to
Dylan Dynasty said whatever I want if I
want to knock them out early I'll knock
them out early if I want to take him
four rounds play him around then knock
them out I'll do that like that's how he
was talking so and I believe that the
skill Gap should be that it should be
that and the athletic Gap like I think
in Grapplers you some like grappling and
and striking athleticism is so different
completely different like it it's that
um oh they're ready they're ready we're
going to get them in the middle here oh
my gosh can we all just take a moment to
uh believe that Dylan danis is in this
ring cuz I I never thought he'd actually
be there sh watching hit that like
button come on let's go on Warriors come
ont find would have added up if he
wasn't did did we all think he'd
actually turn up cuz I honestly didn't
is I did yeah mate the amount of people
in this ring it is wild and do you know
what you said earlier you said earlier
you said when you were about to fight
someone and someone kept rubbing their
shoulders you knew they needed their
handheld well we're seeing it now cuz
Dylan dnis is getting a borderlan thae
massage in this [__] what the [__] sign
me up yeah get a happy ending
on we're getting the rules read out by
the referee and I think he's
particularly aware that Dylan danis if
he's getting a Pon would have no problem
in uh and there was no touch with the
gloves would have no problem just saying
[__] it I'm going for the guillotine
choke yeah [__] this Logan Paul is a
massive massive star but there been a
lot question when you actually talk
about his boxing credentials this is the
fight that he can actually we're going
to get answers boys come on guys this is
massive Jesus I'm glad I'm sharing this
experience black ey keeps looking worse
and worse every time I see it it's it's
getting worse the's going to come off
very quick got wait he's got a love bite
I don't know if that's that um Logan
just blew a kiss into the crowd I'm
assuming it's to the m he's not got a
love bite she's not that sort of girl oh
Body Shop oh and there was a little bit
of a um so Dylan danis has come out
southp Clash of feet um and there was a
clash of feet there body punches from
from Logan on the
Belt he's doing the thing where he's
going to try and make him gas out by
punching loads you got to go for a hook
there supposed to move your head when
you come in he's got a throw a punch as
well no I think he's this what almost
Floyd oh no Dylan's no yeah but yeah but
Floyd's good enough to do that Dylan's
going in straight any head movement he's
not dipping the knees at all yeah
Dylan's Dylan's not um he's yeah he I
think Logan should just piece him up and
and tactically dismantle him if you're
going to try and wear him down like that
i' I'd sort of try and get a more into
the talking talk like Dylan hasn't got a
clue what he's doing here has he you can
see that but Logan's kind of unsure that
he's like what the [__] are you doing
yeah like this ain't boxing bro but
Logan actually just missed with a a
combination there hook in a straight
this is what he's like against Floyd
he's wild when he lets the hands go yeah
he needs
to Dylan isn't really throwing here in
the exchanges Dylan looks scared to
throw Dylan's scared to actually leave
himself open because he knows when he
does start throwing it's actually when
he's going to be at his most vulnerable
I said that in my preview see he's not
throwing a single no no I think he's
doing this to try and make Logan punch
himself out that is what I'm seeing here
I feel like this is a tactic I I mean
maybe he's kind of going uh Floyd
Mayweather did this to Conor McGregor
and I don't know if he's trying to just
but he's getting jab now he's getting
go on Logan
son's laughing
off the main thing that he should be
looking at here is Logan is leaving
plenty of spaces to be counted Dylan
finally letting a few go yeah he's doing
nothing though Dylan I I I guess he's
looking at those big arms and thinking
like he said in the uh the face off
you're going to gas nice right hand by
Dylan dnis and a good one two by Logan
and he clinches afterwards if Dylan's
going to have that tight guard like he's
adopting here he needs to make sure that
when Logan does come with a one on a two
he then at least throws a counter hook
in there because the punches are coming
from low and the hands are going back
low so Logan does have plenty of uh
spaces for Dylan to punch into but at
the minute we're literally just seeing
the pressure and it's looking like he's
wi lovely right hand from Logan Paul
rocks the head back and Dylan is doing
[__] all you flyed all the way to
Manchester and you're not even throwing
punches like what was this elbow thing
like
literally n i I really don't know I
think Logan's just getting a look at
Dylan here like what the [__] am I
dealing with you like who fights like
this I I I I think Dylan's even scared
to even throw punches cuz that's when he
knows you beard is most vulnerable he's
literally not doing nothing
yet this is a bit weird this is weird
this is Dylan is doing nothing Dylan
literally threw a grand total of [__]
all there I mean like to an extent I was
you know yeah tactic maybe get him to
punch out but you got you got at some
point do something and I think like he
can't like okay do that for a round he
can't now do that the second round cuz
he's just going to slowly lose this
fight and at least well maybe he wants
to lose on points as long as he doesn't
get knocked out I think he wants to take
the the the the the sting of the punches
on the gloves yeah and and get the worst
out of the way and then try and
Implement his thing but I don't know if
that that's going to work let's see how
Lan Paul comes out see if he looks like
he's uh drained anything from the tank
or not I think Logan showed good
restraint there he didn't overthrow he
he definitely rocked the head back
plenty of times despite the tight God I
mean it was an easy [__] round but
but again you have to knock them out you
have to make them you can't let him walk
out of there talking [__] if I'm Logan
and I'm thinking I want a stoppage in
this fight I'm looking at that and I'm
thinking I tell you what before my arms
do start to drain a little bit while
I've still got my power let me twist my
hips into these and let me get him out
of here in this round because punches
aren't they and that's what Weir has
criticized Lo for a lot is is just
constant arm punches yeah um not getting
the torque um from the
hips but I think he does that to keep
yourself at a safe distance rather than
overly
committing yeah a lot of that that style
that Milton applies with the hands down
law is is like
that is Dylan going to throw a punch in
this fight [__] to him the whole
time what is
this this is going to sound I wouldn't
be surprised if Dylan tries to bite his
ear at some point make and St could he
go for a taked down cuz I could see that
happening as well to be honest doing
rear naked choke this is
bizarre what is Dylan doing [__]
hell oh my God I I I can't believe it
like I think Dylan knows how vulnerable
he is and he's just like [__] throwing
punches I just want to make it to the
end here I think that's genuinely his
whole game plan
like you know how he keeps dropping them
hands Logan needs to time that do you
think you could imagine Dylan at the end
of this fight if it goes to points G we
just fought in your form of combat now
come and fight me in MMA and taking that
moral Victory like we said from from
surviving I think yeah like if he just
does the whole fight like this and Logan
doesn't get near him doesn't actually
doesn't Mark him up in any way mate
that's a win for Dylan it is but for the
fans but he doesn't give a [__] no he
doesn't give a [__] but for the millions
of people or or million over a million
we reckon that are going to be buying
pay-per-views here you would be
disappointed to to see Dyan not come out
and at least try and put heavy with 100%
But ultimately as he says Dylan is the
bad guy and he does not care what anyone
work that [__] body son work that
body the body's right there look Dylan
finally threw a punch we're at one H
we're at 2 minutes into the round um I
actually think Logan needs Dylan to
throw punches yeah he does that's what I
said in my preview he dyan's possibly
might just go up and just try and
survive in there and that's all he's
doing right now it's very hard to land
when someone's being this pathetic as a
as a man you talk all that [__] you
haven't even thrown a punch that is some
[__] [__] that like you can't do that
he at some point like he needs to
actually
engage this is where as Logan it might
be worth playing playing a game where
you bait him oh go on Logan go on Logan
son Come On Son oh no yes Dylan danis is
in trouble and Logan is wailing on that
body yeah doesn't want to blow your out
yes get that [__] out there come
on Logan son Lan did well there to not
let Dylan danis hold him actually he
took a step back saying I haven't seen
him before oh where's the laughing now
he's got to get him out of this ring
though soon he's going to be
gassed yeah and that's exactly he wanted
to weather that storm Logan's now going
to be very Gass just needs to let let
him off now he did was it not about was
it the second or third round we done the
same thing with Mayweather where he kind
of but that one was the button bashing
do you remember everyone said it's live
on the PlayStation when you hit all the
button he was hurt Dylan was hurt there
but I mean in terms of letting his hands
go kind
of Jake in the corner with Milton really
trying to uh and and this is what we
want to see not to take the Shine off
Logan but imagine what Jake would do
Dyan Hest I know to be honest with
you what it's because I I I don't know
if it would be that much different to
this uh it would be it would be better
it would be worse J is a huge level
above Logan yeah like this is a lot of
just I don't that Nate fight wasn't
great mate it was actually not a great I
don't think he's a huge level I think
it's just I feel as if Jake's a little
bit Karma and he's he's and obviously
Jake's being a lot more the Box more
composed and he's actually developed his
technique whereas I feel as if Logan's
got great feet but he's never really
improved on the way he delivers his
punches that's his downfall I think
defensively there's not much difference
in it it's just the way he delivers
these punches that obviously got the
same genes I feel as if he's got the
potential to have the same level of
power he just hasn't improved his
technique I also think that the fact
that Logan look as a sort of armchair
YouTube fan as the fact that Logan was a
bigger star maybe going into it meant
that Logan hasn't got as much time to
put into boxing as Jake did and Jake has
obviously had a lot more time to invest
in boxing and learn his craft so maybe
that's is literally got no intent to
actually win this fight man you're a
grown man you call yourself a fighter
you're not even throwing punches like
what the fck oh my God this guy is Logan
needs to clown this guy and invite the
pressure on and then counter him because
this guy he doesn't know how to throw a
[__] punch and he doesn't want to be
exposed for that not only does he not
know how to throw a punch I'm a massive
fan of Roy Jones Jr but that is the
worst attempt at a shoulder roll I've
ever seen in my life it's like oh my God
oh my God like literally we're talking
literally we're watching the 69er
fighting right now like it's all gstar
and
is he just until theth to actually throw
some punches you not think he's like is
that not the game plan like just stay in
the fight until it's to get it's to not
get knocked out mate all all Dylan wants
to do is to not get knocked but at the
same time I hope Logan doesn't switch
off and get like get too comfortable and
play Dylan's Hands by getting into his
head oh there's the elbows trying to
come in there just wearing pink
tonight wait look how he's marked up
Dylan is oh he's getting caught them
right cuz you know when you got your
hands high you end up cuffing yourself
you're still taking the shots you know
what I mean oh back fist yeah that back
fist what is that what is he doing oh
Dylan really is an embarrassing man and
he look at him he saying let's do
jiujitsu yeah he's just lying down
saying let's roll or whatever but like
you literally you're throwing three
punches in three rounds you [__]
idiot like if you want people to look at
you as a fighter this ain't the way to
go about it like you don't look like a
fighter you've got to shorten the
[__] gloves on but me you
look a bit of intent he literally looks
like a [__] a person who's had one
boxing lesson yeah what the [__] H
he's in a southp stance with his right
foot as the Lead Foot and when you look
at when Logan pushes him back the left
foot should go back first the right
foot's going back first so his foot
works all wrong and then body shots are
going to start H take tall yeah as the
fight goes on yeah try keeping your
[__] hands up when that body's
getting
hurt what Logan needs to do was bait him
in and make him think that there's an
opportunity to hit and then slip it and
counter but it's easy to say that when
you know I'm not in the [__] Heat of
the Moment but I think that that's the
hardest bit for just Logan turning his
back
there God he's absolutely [__] isn't he
Dylan he's not giv him anything to do
like Logan needs something to come back
to create a counter yeah and that's why
he's just deliberately thinking I just
need to see the end of this round and
then I can say [__] you come to MMA and
unfortunately
he's he's kind of getting away with it
right now even though he's getting
beaten up it's it's it's not enough
Logan's not fighting like a man who's
had his partner abused for for weeks you
know what I
mean it came it came out in the first
couple of rounds though and he was very
aggressive was he is he any do you think
that's more aggressive than he normally
is I don't I'm not seeing you're as
aggressive as you're allowed to be like
and and and again it sounds like I'm
being really negative towards Logan I
really don't mean to be but like you
know when Logan puts on the aggression
and when Logan goes for it you sort of
feel like it's very forced and comparing
it to Jake we were saying they got the
same genes when he does it it's very
natural like it comes to there's a spite
there in Jake that I just don't think
Logan has like Jake there's moments
where Jake enjoys hurting people yeah
right and it's not the be wiend in life
there's plenty of things that Logan will
excel Jake up but in this specific skill
set in this format I just think that
Logan could do with adopting a bit of
that aggression that natural Killer
Instinct that's in his brother it's
almost like when he does try to be
aggressive he just tenses up and it's
it's just all arm punches there's no
Exchange in the hips or the shoulders
and let's have it right from from
someone that that's boxed to a high
level like yourself if someone stands
there in front of you that guard like
that you should be having a field just
threw a right hand very a very hard
right hand did land did it land didn't
didn't quite land but it was well a for
effort thr a punch ladies and gentlemen
he's throwing a punch Dylan danis is
throwing an actual punch a good idea is
a good idea forever when you don't throw
punches that's the reaction you get wow
I mean we might actually start to see a
fight take place now um aside from Logan
using Dylan as a cross test dummy what
what is a better moral Victory is it a
better better moral Victory if Dylan
goes out on his shield trying to win or
if he makes it to points because I think
all of us around this table purely for
the fact we want to be entertain would
say Dylan he's got on his shield you not
think that Dylan's role is the king of
the trolls and for the trolls [__]
housing your way to a decision is almost
like a win like they will love him for
that like you stunk the joint out you
didn't get ironed out you didn't throw
anything and you made a mockery of the
whole thing it's like an anti-hero yeah
it's like the class clown which is what
Dylan is it's you're not there to take
part you're there to disrupt and that's
what he's doing now he's just stinking
The Joint Now by not throwing punches I
mean if you're Misfits you don't want
this as a as a show of the sport no I
also think this is actually all he can
do like there's been a couple moments
where he's tried to maybe get on the
inside and and unleash and he I just
don't actually think he can I don't so
this is almost like the second best like
let me do this you know what I mean yeah
this is this is yeah it's tough Man
Logan looks like he is tiring slight
tiring yeah yeah yes cuz he's thrown a
lot of punches but he's just hitting a a
shield you know what I mean yeah you
know when you said that Dylan was a bit
of a punch bag from McGregor and Spar
him yeah you can see why right like if
anything no no no I was going to say I
think you were being very light by
calling him a punch bag yeah I think no
but you can see why like cuz Dylan
obviously like I kept thinking this in
the preview in the prediction I did is
like he's got to be tough you training
all these MMA gyms you've been with
Conor McGregor that long like McGregor
if you're not tough wouldn't have you in
your his team like that's why he had
autum lowo he needed a [__] crash
test dummy like that so I knew Dylan was
going to be tough and and you know to a
degree he is but he's not tough in a I
want to go and win this fight I'm going
to throw a punch is tough he just
durable and can take getting beaten up
but make no mistake this is pathetic
from him tough and proud at different
things saying he's not proud he when we
knew Dylan was the underdog but he
hasn't even tried to win the whole thing
KSI tonight is the underdog we ain't
seeing this from him we're seeing him go
out there and give it everything and if
he doesn't win he'll go out on his
shield he's like a journeyman and you
getting pro boxing they're there to just
to survive they're not really there to
do anything yeah but a Kevin Johnson
will still show sh us like you know
little bits in your armor there you know
what I mean that's like a high level
Journey oh see when he when he lets his
hands go he goes square he gets wild
doesn't he
Logan interesting thing there to go away
from the fight a little bit look who
Eddie Hearn sat next to we were talking
about a rumored fight earlier on between
Conor Ben and Chris Eubank seen that
earlier Eddie Hearn sat to chis pretty
much confirmed that's happen in the next
6 months
apparently um where it'll happen as
anyone's guess we're in round five live
uh shout out to everyone watching please
hit that like button subscribe if you
haven't already we appreciate it and um
right now it's been four rounds to Logan
Paul Dy disis has probably for five
punches this is meant to be like the
main event the ones we've watched
previously have been far more
entertaining it's like yeah Dylan is he
had to just survive and by survive you
know get to the final Bell and and get
his ass kicked you need a good dancing
partner don't you it's just embarrassing
this man like as a as a grown man to get
in a boxing ring and to perform like
that like most people would perform I I
remember like getting in the ring and
doing my first spa and be willing to
like give more than this and this is
behind closed doors there's not 20,000
people watching yeah there's an element
of like as [__] man yeah I don't want
to go you look like a [__] fighting
like this absolute [__] man come on
throw some [__] punches you [__]
embarrassing man you can't call yourself
a fighter and fight like that no [__]
way you're a [__] Jiu-Jitsu guy who
has no place in if you fight like this
and you want to win a UFC
[__] you can't even fight Logan Paul
like supposed to be he thinks he's going
to be UFC champion and you can't even
throw punches [__] off you Joker
absolute [__]
Joker why is he going into the corner I
suppose he's getting me annoyed and
that's his goal right he's winning by by
me watching him thinking I want you to
actually have a fight he's winning to
some degree by even doing
that and by even pretending like he's
not hurt and laughing that's the whole
game game that he's playing yeah look at
both his eyes he's marked up oh he's
black eyes the whole lot Logan hasn't
taken you know the Logan this is the
thing that we remember the one time
Dylan danis hit Logan was with a [__]
microphone you ain't done [__] it's mad
problem is the whole way through the
buildup the signs were always there when
you when when you look at it and you go
did Dylan danis really give a [__] what
anyone F when he was saying all these
things and everything he was
doing this is what Lan has to do he
needs to he needs to uh troll Dylan yeah
he just gave it this when when Dylan
missed with one punch that he's thrown
this
round come on come on Dylan throw a
punch it's literally imagine the [__]
compy box stats from this man you're
going to have like 300 punches to to
three you know when I said before the
fight that there's the chance here that
we still don't learn anything about l
so maybe from a character point of view
the way he's you know not um sort of
crumbled under the pressure and whatnot
yeah okay but in terms of technically
where he's at in this YouTube boxing
scene if the fight stays like this which
it looks like it's going to we don't
learn anything about Logan PA do we and
that's that's technically you do but
that's that's about it there's nothing
coming back can it's not his fault at
all but this is a glorified Spar against
a guy who hasn't got a clue how to punch
um but knows how to cover up
um he's no worse he's just no better but
he's been out the game for a while so I
didn't expect him to be better to be
honest oh Dylan threw another one missed
again but yeah um Dylan is getting more
aggressive in terms of his he's trying
to walk uh Logan down but now we're in
once we get into the sixth round and
Dylan sees the end of this fight within
touching distance I mean we can and
Logan doesn't even seem like he wants to
knock Dylan out right now in terms of
his movement um he's content to outbox
him and embarrass him so maybe that's
you know that's the way he wants to play
it but I I thought we'd get a bit
more I thought we'd get a bit more
aggression from Dylan
here I think this is the best chance
Logan has to try to play him at his own
game otherwise he's just going to have a
guy with a high like high we've got one
round left so I think we're we know
where this is going it's a Logan pole
decision ah it's been a bit pole on
points you nailed it you nailed it brav
I'll be happy if you're wrong and Logan
lands that big shot but um I think given
how tired he is from it's it's almost
like an excise machine that he's on like
you're just punching relentlessly into
the guard um there's nothing coming back
pretty
much it's quite deflating isn't it like
this this this this this is not the main
event this this is where it is we got a
proper main event where two people are
going to take each other's head off and
we got real proper fighters in the head
vill and dnis you can't ever call
yourself a fighter after this this is
embarrassing you are an Internet troll
yeah you are literally 69 so
congratulations you played yourself you
know what I mean like go back to
Jiu-Jitsu bro you you're in you're not a
like a proper Striker and you got a
simplifies with Logan Paul because Logan
Paul did not know that Dylan danis was
going to come out here and stink the
place out and he and and what you can
say is Dylan danis probably knew what he
was going to do Logan Paul was there
ready for a fight so you got give him
credit for that and he's still taking it
to him in this last round couple of good
shots still hitting him hard I feel like
when they're when you're not looking to
throwback it's a lot easier to cover
yourself up so Dylan danis is probably
going to see out this round yeah I mean
the one credit you can give Dylan is has
he got a decent chin yeah it's all right
he's not I don't think Logan's been able
to hit him clean no he hasn't been he's
just had a this tight Shield it's it's
hard to kind of land cleanly when a
guy's doing
that wonder how much Dylan is getting
paid oh that was a good body shot from
Logan Paul uh Dylan definitely felt that
but uh he circles out doesn't want to
know immediately his hands go further
down so that definitely did something
but Logan isn't capitalizing on it right
now he's giving him that time there's
two minutes left Dylan goes in Dylan man
oh oh you know I was beginning to think
you know maybe there's some Star Quality
about this guy on the run up even after
all the [__] he's done but you don't
you're not even being a man here [__] me
you're absolute [__] this is what
happens when you just B partner you know
what I mean for Conor McGregor that's
his mentality just a cumrag like he's
literally just W it off in the rug oh
Noy goes for the takeown no he's going
no way no way going to do that Dylan's
an absolute [__] does that mean disqual
is that a point deduction some uh a lot
of the book makers were giving odds on
the DQ for for that thing I mean I I
wouldn't be surprised so what's happen
he's getting a point taken off of him
Lan's making
it he's a [__] you know what you have to
think right you have to think like I
understand that Dylan danis has a name
now and that there's a chance of him
bringing attention to an organization he
should go for it again but but why would
anyone ever hire Dylan danis for a fight
ever again Jesus Christ we've got a
minute left does Dylan danis go for that
again you know a question for you guys
do you think when Dylan danis is old and
gray and his [__] you know old man
you look back at this and think I fought
like a man or I fought like an absolute
little [__] wow I think you'll go who I
fought like a man in ju-jitsu I'm a
champion this is this is just a joke for
me this is me just down the park with my
mates like I think that's how he sees it
this is embarrass him any fighting man
would not be proud of this you can't you
and you know now I'm quoting the furies
here but you can't call yourself a
fighter you C like
wow would he be earning more more for
this than any of his MMA fights Dylan
danis earned more tonight than he's ever
earned in his entire life for anything
so when he's an old man would he maybe
go I did what I thought was the noble
art and then I went in and messed about
for a few rounds and earned the bag uh I
think he may think I had the chance of a
lifetime I pussied out didn't fight like
a man and then after that oh my god oh
look he's going for it oh he's going to
get a point deducted Sur no wait no wait
go on go
on in for the coaches oh my God's it's
all kicking off right now after after
six rounds of not wanting to throw
punches Dyan dinus is throwing punches
what a look at this [__] Bro there's
about 80 people in the ring right now
lad can I say one thing did you see when
Logan swung for Dylan when he went to
the four oh yeah fair play cl themir
play C them as he should as he should
but honestly oh my God secur security
are fighting each other as well oh my
god get these [__] juice heads out
the [__]
what are these [__] idiots doing in
there honestly for the attention there's
one security God I swear to God right
the other day I'm going to do this on
the he was like this he was like and
then you seen him
go like they're desperate to be on
camera these [__] it's not about you
man you're a bunch of [__] nobodies
yeah they were gagging for that [__] out
the ring man [__] hell well then
Logan Paul wins on points uh I I mean I
don't know if they'll they'll they'll do
but the round wasn't actually out but
Dylan just the the [__] Houser is not
even it's not good you know what I mean
you've literally come here to do nothing
no but the thing is you went for the
takedown twice and you didn't
land he go for the choke as well mate
you missed that as well yeah I mean look
Logan dominated in in the most easy
fight of his entire life so he can claim
that um and laughing about it but for
Dylan like what you go in say you abused
you and you just done absolutely nothing
probably I mean he's leaving with two
black eyes like but yeah he's still
going off by the way going still going
off there Dylan's nowhere near this
Dylan's on the other side of the Ring
right D's probably out on the road home
he's laughing thinking look what I've
created you what I mean listen look at J
Paul's going absolutely mad shouting at
him you know why cuz Jake Paul's
actually [__] a lunatic man uh and I
kind of agree with you and what you said
earlier I think I think it would have
been worse for him if Jake had have been
there in terms of just Jake understands
leverage and use of the power uh that
he's got whereas Logan he's still I
don't think Logan has evolved as a
fighter and um and I think if if Logan
ever wants to do this properly I think
um a proper camp like Jake has done
would be like I know he's very close
with his coach and stuff like that but
those arm punches were the reason why he
wasn't able to generate the power to
actually get him out of there um to give
to give Logan a little bit of credit
when I was saying about maybe that bit
of inner spite that I didn't see there
and people are look at this and think
why know if you giv him credit for this
when Dylan danis tried to take him down
there and tried to give him the choke
and he went to the ground I was actually
quite happy to see Logan Logan Paul
throw that punch in when he was on floor
because not just cuz he deserved it but
just to show me all right yeah that's a
bit of character there but Jake Paul
probably knee drops his skull there you
know what I mean Jake Paul stabs him
pulls a knife out just kills him right
there but for me as a as a Combat Sports
Fan if I'm the UFC any of them I
wouldn't touch this more with a barge P
he literally went in there and did
nothing look he's an idiot this is it
isn't it is it that's that's the first
one but you know what what he showed
there he kind of defended that taked
down pretty well didn't he show wrest
back wrestler tried to take him down he
went up the
legs I love the fact that Dylan actually
threw punches at the security at the
security guard Big Time finally you
actually act like a [__] man you
little [__] I just don't get why there
700 SEC guards they just all want the
spot look they're all fighting each
other they're embarrassing these
40-year-old men do stop trying to get
their moment it's like get out the
[__] ring mate that's like bouncers
outside [__]
prison crazy never let me in
bastard but still I can't lie surely
Logan doesn't feel like he's Avenged his
fiance well I mean he's won in Easy
fashion but for sure he would have
wanted The Knockout I think he tried his
best you know what I mean try he did try
he let his hands go he just had nothing
to work with man the guy wasn't throwing
punches back like I when I when I said
oh he needs to knock him out I was like
yeah assuming Dylan danis would actually
fight like a man yeah but you'd still
think like surely he'd be able to set up
a knockout even if you there's still an
element of like it's so difficult when a
fight is that negative you've got to
have something to work with um but I
believe Jake Paul would have been able
to work something out there it still
would have been hard it still would have
been a night you would have been able to
work something out there that's the
difference of Jake Paul I actually feel
he dedicated his life to boxing and he's
given a good go to really improve where
Logan's been in the wrestling he's he's
he's done a lot even from the beginning
I never I've never felt that he's really
dedicated the time the way Jake that's
what I'm saying as when him doing all
the WWE there's no way he could have
like he needed sence being given right
now over the direction um so yeah I
don't think this is as well I almost
feel like Logan can't fully go for it uh
because he does actually get tired like
you did see him breathing and I feel
like with that muscle and I think WWE
will be Pro promoting yeah put on more
muscle I mean you know what I mean like
to be fair if you're throwing that many
punches and never having to defend
yourself like it is a tiring six round
punching punching punching it's it's the
tension he carries he never looks
relaxed he's so stiff when he cuz it's
all arms you're like it's just your arm
muscles rather than let your corn even a
winner every uh now and again I used to
spar with like MMA guys right very very
hard to spar against them because the
faint you throw they don't react to in a
way that a boxer should and there was
certain things in there like Logan
actually invested in the body quite well
with the straight one twos and stuff
like that any normal boxer when you do
that lowers their guard to protect their
body Dyan danis keeps his guard up so so
you're not getting the uh the benefit of
doing that because nor you're going to
go bomb bomb and then come over the top
with a hook or something like that but
you're never getting that with Dylan
danis so it's it's hard to look good
against someone who doesn't box or act
like a traditional boxer it's it's
you're right my toughest spars been
against guys who are so unorthodox you
know people like we got we got a we got
a bit of Logan Paul sorry tus he just
said Logan Paul is a coward Logan Paul
is a
Coward sorry sorry Logan said Dylan
danis is a coward in that he was
supposed to be this at the other and
he's just come in there and done nothing
sort of thing um I'm getting secondhand
instructions yeah sorry guys
um uh we got pictures of KSI getting his
uh gloves wrapped with Tyson Fury double
checking it yeah so obviously no you
know normally a person of the other team
does come and watch that but Tyson for
isn't it interesting they've sent T very
clever you're kind of like oh [__] this
guy is related to him it's okay Logan's
just said he can't wait to start a
family with Nina oh well then that's
lovely and Nina was in the ring there
she's now gone out of the ring she was
with him yeah [__] me I mean it's not
really it's such a [__] uh cluster
[__] uh here I where is Dylan at this
moment where is he
prison no are we going to see him again
is he going to be involved in another
fight again after that performance do we
do we think that nobody wants to I don't
want to see Dylan in anything like what
what is the point the thing is though is
like it's the buildup he sold
pay-per-views and it's actually that
that matters yeah but the here is the
anomaly Logan Paul is a special guy to
share the ring with and you can work
with so many different things about him
he's leaving the ring with two busted up
eyes now Dylan with a sing without a
single punch throwing he can't feel like
a winner he cannot he knows he's an
absolute little [__] right I bet he
scared like it's embar it's embarrassing
but but with with with the dance partner
that Logan is Dylan had so much to work
with you put Dylan in with average MMA
guys who a will hurt him because he'll
have to strike with them if he can't get
them down I mean he's just just another
guy in the MMA world he is literally
that he's but he's that's why I think he
he'll look at this Misfits if an offer
comes like for him to fight I mean who
else could he fight I'll be surprised if
Misfits take him on board so let let's
think about this let's think about this
track record right you didn't show up
with 10 days notice for KSI because you
pussied out of that fight you then
finally get a fight you then act like an
absolute [__] in the fight it's not a
good track record for me I'd be like I'm
I'm good we're good you you go and do
your thing and let your 500 Grand do
wonders for you in the Law Courts where
Logan Paul drains you of every last
penny that that's a problem like he cuz
he's played all of this with like um
kamakazi consequences so when you're not
thinking of the long term you got to
think I want people to want to employ me
I want to be in the ring again I want to
have a sustained career I don't know how
he does that after this like he's got
loads of attention so that's one good
thing everything else is terrible his in
ring performance was horrendous you then
pulled out with the fight before that
there's nothing about you that says
you're a fighter you're a Jiu-Jitsu guy
and you're a good Grappler but you ain't
a fighter there's a difference right
yeah jiu-ju guys have Lords respect for
the martial arts but you are not
Fighters and when he goes oh it's easy
it's a half a fight man you can use the
Conor McGregor line's all you want you
look like do you think Conor McGregor
would have done that no no way come on
we haven't seen Conor McGregor on screen
so not yet I thought he would have been
there yeah I thought he would have been
I was 99% sure he was going to be there
from everything I've been told but is he
not there then I bloody I don't know
they haven't shown him and you know what
Miss he might be there for the main
event I don't know
um but I mean it was an easy fight you
know what I mean that's easy fight it
was the easiest fight we'll ever watch
really yeah without a doubt um I wonder
if there if it will now continue in any
way I.E the social media abuse is it
like okay yeah you had your KN and now
I'm going to just if I'm Logan I'll just
block him and move on with my life like
what is there left to do you literally
didn't throw a punch mate what we
talking about yeah if you you had your
chance and you didn't want to know it
will continue cuz the lawsuit sorry yeah
no no yeah and and that's the point
though where Logan like we're talking
about a guy who's going to be a
billionaire one day or at least in the
hundreds and hundreds of millions I mean
he can just be like this and be like you
know what I wasn't quite satisfied with
that fight let's just ruin his [__]
life and that might happen that might
actually he has the money to ruin this
man's life even I mean I'm going to be
real if he wants to get him killed he
[__] bro he's [__] but yeah can you
know what the ironic thing is there
though if Logan knocks him spark out I'm
not saying I don't know Logan but maybe
there's a chance there that you go fight
the lawsuit oh Dylan might have actually
won by letting him do that if he
actually fought and got knock out Logan
might have went that's quenched The
Thirst but right now it ain't enough I
got I got more business plans for you
bro um so where do you think Logan Paul
goes from here who do you think he
fights next I don't think does you think
that's it not not never again but like
you know how we're looking at it now and
we're going who does Tommy fight if he
wins who does KSI fight if he wins who's
Jake Paul fighting next I just never
because of the way like and this is a
credit to Logan Paul because he's an
unreal businessman and he's got so many
fingers in so many PES different
business ventures I just don't put him
in the mix like I think he's someone
that will come every now and again when
there's a narrative and a story line for
him to dip into but I don't put him in
the mix of like active influence put him
in there with you know how we were
speculating who could be next a lot of
people around the table said maybe Tommy
no that performance definitely not yeah
he's just he has not evolved from a long
time of of of since we haven't seen him
to me yeah that was the that was the guy
that faced KSI to in in Los Angeles it's
pretty much the same as that guy yeah
yeah and um I don't know it's I'm really
interested to see how the internet
reacts to Dylan because for a normal
fight fan you're looking at a coward
you're look a man who didn't want to
throw a punch but I don't know if the
internet on some level will still like
him for that it's weird I feel as if
people will not be bothered CU I think
what he done under the leadup like I
don't did did anyone have any big
expectations of him really I don't think
they did you know what I mean and you
know the people that I expect them to
throw more than two
punches the people that were loving him
in the buildup were they going he's a
brilliant fighter or were they going he
[__] good at taking a piss out these
lot do you know what I mean so so now I
think that even those same people might
go yeah he was [__] but he's still going
to absolutely wrench you on Twitter it's
not good but maybe they'll still give
him the sort of props that they already
giving him because they weren't bothered
about his fighting record yeah that's
what I was thinking the thing is though
is I still think Dylan will have like a
a group of people that will follow him
throughout everything cuz he's just got
like a group of fans that just love him
right yeah so so that will Propel him
into some level of fandom and awareness
oh here we go he will he'll still have
an audience it's like a guilty pleasure
just who's he going to troll next what's
he going to do next but not not not for
his fighting just for what he does
outside of the boxing basically all
right we have got KSI versus Tommy Fury
up next guaranteed to be a [__] way
better
fight thr no punches bloody hell um this
is going to be the opposite this is
going to be all out Warfare I think KSI
is kill or be killed type of fighter and
people love those guys because you know
your guaranteed
fireworks and it's going to tell us a
lot about where he is because what's
been coming back at him in the previous
Mis fight the the guys haven't been
great punch as Lads they and we're the
defense is there to be questionable but
he's he's been able to get away with
that because the punches haven't been
great everything's going to have to be
on point perfect storm tonight what you
reing I just can't beating Toby fury
like I I he's he's never ever shown me
anything yet so I can't like like said
we can't really rate them at this point
in time um what's your thoughts I think
like you know the thing you said there
about the guys haven't been great
punchers yeah I completely agree with
that but you not the main thing is and
we sort of touched on this earlier no
one he's fought so far has had a decent
jab and like when you look at Tommy
Fury's jab it's quite good from range
it's quite good up close when he's just
chopping with it it also comes off the
back of a faint and a twitch a lot of
the time and these are little things
that until you until you sort of get in
a ring at any level to be fair you don't
realized like how big it is how big
you've watched Edris Vergo y he is one
of the main sparring partners of KSI
where do you run Idris Vergo by
comparison to Tommy Fury he beat Aon
Chas last time for those who may have
remembered well if I take a business hat
off that's the sensible next fight
should Tommy Fury come in this if you're
going to stay with the influence of
boxing stuff with the business hat on
you go Logan paol and and pretty much
probably that's it to be honest in terms
of the big big household YouTube names
or whatever but in terms of actually
matchmaking and I'm saying like Okay two
blos on a sort of bit more of a Level
Playing Field bit more level experience
Idris Vergo is the next fight the
problem is this and and and obviously me
and you have spoke off camera about KSI
sping with idrus fergo and that's one of
the main things that you've sort of not
convinced me because you're not trying
to do that but you've made me think okay
yeah know ksi's got a decent chaning
this is the fact that kosai has
apparently done pretty well inpiring
against rides fergo but I will believe
it when I see it we haven't seen it I
get you you have to yeah you have to see
it and I could see it in a minute and
then I could go do you know what no
those rumors are true they're completely
right but until I see it I just can't
believe it and the eye test to me is
that I believe that Tommy Fury is a
level above K side but I will cap it off
by saying this we just seen a fight
right where obviously the level's a lot
lower than the level of this fight we're
about to see but Dylan danis is a
massive Underdog in comparison to what
Logan Paul is going into that fight I
personally believe that KSI is an
underdog in comparison to where Tommy
Fury is going into this fight Dylan
danis showed no ambition to win in this
fight KSI will not lose this fight on
points probably like if he loses he's
probably going to go out on his shield
because KSI even if he thinks exp's way
better than me all right I'll throw the
kitchen sink at him and that's what you
got to give him respect for Fearless in
that in that aspect so I think um the
the Jake Paul game plan against Tommy
was to uh outbox him and I think that's
that's what lost him that fight almost
from the get go like you weren't going
to do that and I I don't think that that
he was hoping to land that big shot but
he did land some left good left Hooks
and I've looked at that um but I think
KSI whatever his level is and I think
it's very hard to tell because of the
competition I do think he his game plan
will be I'm going to go in there and
really put it on him and make it a fight
not it's not going to be a boxing match
and um we're going to learn a lot about
um Fury and uh KSI Tommy Fury currently
looking like Kenny from South Park with
this shout out to the furies Big John's
coming out look he's got his trousers up
um which was we' seen his ass the other
day bit interesting now this I believe
is going to be a very different
atmosphere to what Tommy faced in Saudi
Arabia yeah right this is going to be
loyal siden KSI fans and if he was
rattled At All by yesterday and is a bit
confused as to why ksi's got so much
confidence this could potentially get
inside his head when he steps out there
and feels the booze everyone in his
hometown hating him like it's going to
be will be what it look like I reckon so
mate it's Tommy Fury doesn't have loyal
fans no one gives a [__] in the real
boxing Community whereas this house is
packed out by KSI KSI fans bro you know
what I mean and you know what's mad when
you for KSI MH well
well SW this is
but you were the hero and by a mile
everyone was cheering you and booing him
that's the power you have that is like
that was when it hit me I was like fuck,
people chees out I can't lie bro when I
meet my audience on the street wherever
like the the connection I have with my
audience is [__] unreal and I believe
it's because like I've just been so open
you know what I mean with UPS Downs all
of it you know what I mean like my my my
supporters are real do you think you'll
ever come back 100% yeah 100% love it
100% you know what that's the the thing
I'm waiting for like uh there's a
there's a moment in Misfit in the future
I hope where we get the return of Jo and
I mean you'll pack out with [__]
without a doubt Man without a doubt
whether it's Wembley Arena I'd love to
do it in bloody eastborn unfortunately
we don't have the the the the stadiums
do you know what I mean but yeah man
100% any nam in the any names bro I'd go
from any of them I'm going to be at 165
so that's like the hot division but I
think some that can talk on the mic I
want someone that's going to like you
know I want to create some excitement
yeah Bazinga ooh interesting one I think
in shape these days
yeah huh can he fight we don't I mean I
I don't I haven't seen him fight but I'm
pretty sure that he'd be trim and ready
to go he's been talking about like
wanting to make his boxing debut um I
think that can make total sense I think
well I was going to say swarms before
this event but do you know Ed Matthews I
think Ed Matthews why not deji what
about uh Jay swingler Jay swingler the
thing is I get on with Jay swingler I
know you are so similar to him I text
him like I mean like we're mates and
it's sort of like you know you I I'm not
really about like faking anything in
terms of like oh let's let's have this
beef or anything like that like I'd want
someone that I can go right yeah let's
[__] go I don't give a [__] about
hurting you you know what I mean Dei one
makes a lot of sense yeah deji makes a
lot of sense um he's traed a lot of [__]
needs to pay for it um yeah man like any
of them I'll take them all I think it
would be great for us to see you back
there because again the man you were you
weren't even a man you were a boy when
you for KSI you've had so much uh life
experience since then and I think
everyone would love to see you get back
in there and show the real you because
you were fighting without any good
coaching any experience and KSI had
Vidal Riley mate in it mate I remember
saying to someone if J had Vidal Riley
that could have been a completely
different fight right you know BR for I
I never learned to jab I was never it
was actually mental it actually blows my
mind you had a big te basically who like
just a boxer sized guy right it wasn't
uh but look this is what um growth is
all about I'm looking forward to seeing
it man it's going to be doubt but
tonight it's not about me we've got
Tommy Fury and KSI Tommy Fury are
fighting man the fury are the best fires
in the world yes we're going to find out
he's a machine oh wow uh Tommy Fury's
got backup dancers here um didn't expect
that they Halloween themed Brian Brian
the thing I love the most about that
clip of John Fury shouting that in the
press conference we were talking about
this before is it what he say in the
press conference when John Fury uh when
John Fury was shouting the fury are the
best fighters in the world I was
watching the press conference and I
thought oh no one said anything about
Tommy Fury in about two three minutes
and John Fury is sort of sitting there
right on
Q no one's mentioned me in a while the
furies are the best fires in the world
yeah Legend yeah I look John's wild but
he does he does bring entertainment
don't he [__] me he's a bit like me old
man who's actually watching shout out
dad appreciate you
um he just messaged us saying I take
you're not a fan of Dylan danis
um uh but no this is it uh Fury looks
stonefed right now um he doesn't look
nervous to be fair to him looks like
he's in there to do a job um and our
favorite security guard is making sure
he's got his sleeves rolled right up and
is in in shot that's the thing mate when
I saw this bloke at the public workout I
like he looked [__] sharp and I was
literally like about and then KSI comes
out and just does like 25 minutes of
ladders bloody Hopscotch I was just sort
of
like like your brain does just think
like this could actually be a a job the
thing is this is why we're relying on
ksi's coaches only they have see in the
SC only they can sign off on this I can
make all the breakdowns I and go well if
this happens and this happen it doesn't
matter they are paid and no and if
you're KSI and you've got all the money
in the world and you don't need to take
a fight like this you've got to look at
them and go I can have three or four
more fights should I do it yes or no and
they've said you're ready now so on
tonight they better know what they
[__] signed up for and I assume that
they do but when I watched uh Fury
hitting the the heavy buag in the uh the
Run oh my God is Ki a Lamborghini he's
coming out the Lamborghini Lamborghini I
bet it'll be a remix it be a remix of
lambor what a legend oh this is epic
he's got a 40,000 gum shield in with
diamonds in that b wait look at has no
one [__] with this AJ sit down your
fireworks mean nothing no bro no way
this man is in a Lamborghini I wouldn't
be surprised if it [__]
flies Prince Nasim this is crazy no way
that Lamborghini looks tough man oh oh
he's getting out of it is he getting out
of it the lambo doors are
up yeah oh I want to hear what song it
is like if is lamb is it can someone can
someone confirm um we're um yeah we're
uh we've got KSI looking around looks
cool calm doesn't look like he's about
to fight one of the fury clan um I I he
knows something I don't know what he
knows but I I believe in it I put money
on him uh to win uh genu how much money
like 50 quit okay okay but I still
thought you know what [__] hell he's
he's a mate and I wouldn't have the
platform I do without his help that gigs
[__] G he's got G
sing Oh what to hear it I wish we could
hear
yeah um he's in that um like a lime
green uh jacket there uh I like those
colors the green and black it's cool
that's for the glow Berry Prime do you
know what's weird they send primes send
me whenever they launch new stuff they
send me a batch yeah yeah Co like that
I'm just like I just don't get it cuz I
thought they like there was beef so I'm
just like I don't I don't it must be
that bad you're still getting the goods
it's fine I'll take yeah we get some as
well actually PR uh it's all right like
I I like priv cuz yeah I mean I am like
I'm calm like if JJ was here I'll be
absolutely [__] can't but the thing
with you and him though is it's just
this like it's kind of like brothers
right it's like it's sibling rivalry
type stuff like it could always kick off
if you know what it is there is an
element of like where it's like in his
in his group he's like number one he's
like top top dog and where in my I'm Top
Dog it's like we come if we're near each
other it's like well it's two top dogs
like and it's always that whereas I
think in reality if we sat down and was
like sorry mate like are you good how's
it going you think there there's an
element of you right where you have a
problem with people who think that
they're a certain level and you love
bringing them down to Peg or 2 what I
think that well there is obviously an
element of like arrogance that he
displays he probably thinks I display an
arrogance in in a clash in it there's a
clash 100 it is a do you know what I
mean it's the only true rivalry that's
ever actually I feel being on this
platform obviously you got Jake Paul and
KSI but that rivalry that we've had like
mate it's it's [__] it made it like
if it wasn't for what you and I remember
before the fight I was on camera and I
was like this is going to do 20 million
views and and loads of people afterwards
it did the 20 million views on YouTube
people coming going how did you know and
I went cuz I [__] know these two man
[__] Mega stars but yeah I think the
Jake has to be next no matter what
happens when lose a draw the fans are
quenching uh for that and uh they need
to be given it um JJ is about to um and
at the ring Tommy is uh getting um the
rub from uh Big
John we were right about that rubbing
thing someone's getting a rub and
they're worried he washed his hands off
slapping his
ass [__]
me yeah this is they got the prime
bottle on the [__] Lamborghini I
didn't say that before
Jesus um and the legacy tattoo across
the back of KSI who says this is all
about Legacy that's what he does
everything for
and um and fury is kind of doing it for
Legacy Family Legacy following in the
footsteps um and it's going to be
interesting because Loza pointed out a
great Point earlier about the amateur
like the the minor amateur background
feur he had and the fact that yeah he'd
been around boxing the whole time but
he'd never really been dedicated we
might see Fury go up a few levels
between fights here we you know because
now he's actually applying himself I
hope so you you would expect so because
the pressure from the previous fight
every is looking for improvement so
surely oh God we got the [__]
national anthem again you know what the
funny thing is though like we look at
the amateur career and the amateur
pedigree of Tommy Fury which there's not
there's not that much there but when he
was first fighting Daniel b binski or
whatever his name is and and and and
obviously Journeymen that weren't
throwing nothing back I was thinking
okay well we're we're seeing Tommy Fury
we're seeing him under the lights he's
dealing with the occasion we're not
learning nothing from the fights he
fought a guy called Jordan Grant right
two and0 yeah two and0 at the time has
now been in there with like Ben Whitaker
and a few other Fighters and whatnot got
stopped orbe it but I look at that and
that was a bit of a back and forth fight
where he had to show a bit of heart and
I thought you should match him up with
opponents like that that he's still a
favorite against but are going to come
with a bit more ambition because Jordan
Grant when he fought him was two and 0
at the time he's now six and four or
something right two and0 at the time I
thought you should match him up against
people like that because that's actually
going to develop him quicker and then
when you look at it and you look at
Jordan Grant you go
you're not a million miles off a Misfits
fighter and actually now I'm looking at
it and I'm going Jake Paul KSI Jordan
Grant the fight before that maybe if if
you count that one they are fights that
I do think are going to continue to
develop Tommy Fury I don't think they're
fights that it's like Tommy Fury was
doing his Pro thing and he stopped
learning and stopped developing because
he's now gone Misfits like I actually
think that the liks of Jordan Grant and
then going overs Jake PA and things like
that they're they're level up a little
bit and he's continuing to develop so I
don't think it's thing of like the
amateur experiences out the window and
now there's nothing there for Tommy Fury
and he's just only doing this cuz I
think he's still growing as a fighter
and learning a bit and when we said
about seeing on the pads one other thing
is for a very musclebound fighter when
we saw him on the pads we were saying he
looked explosive he looked sharp one
thing to me is he looked very loose he
was throwing that left it to the body
left it to the head followed by an elbow
or beit but you know like I actually
thought he looked loose on the pads and
L looked quite sharp so one thing I
would say is you're you're fighting guys
who are getting premium level coaching
they're paying for the the best coaching
right so they're they're not just like a
lot of the lads who Who Tommy would have
been fighting before might have had
parttime jobs Str like it is hard being
a boxer Laz has told me all about it
time and time again like to to spin all
the plates in life and then get good
coaching it's really hard so actually
you'll probably not fight people who
have got more time and energy and
dedication who've got their whole lives
perfectly set up for boxing they're a
KSI or a Jake Paul everything's the best
they're nutrition the training the
coaching everything so um I think there
is a level where it it is a test for
Tommy and that this won't be useless to
him if he wants to be a professional
will champ one day if that's the call
but it's the question of do you really
want that or you're just content to keep
fighting celebrities I I think we'd all
probably sit around this table as much
as I really like Tommy Fury I think he's
a really nice blo from what you see of
him we'd all probably admit that he's
not going to be World level unless
something drastically changes and when
we look at the past history of Fighters
things have happened and that has
happened but what is the sort of level
of him as a pro is it southern area or
do you think he could go a little bit
further than that well he is still only
very early in his career to like if you
look at like Callum Smith or somebody or
rocky Fielding or people like that
within the Callum Johnson Callum Johnson
within the first two three even four
years Callum Johnson I think for a good
four years done absolutely nothing and
he didn't always look that great and
then look who he fought he fought B and
put him down I know he got he got beat
but that's world that's the cream of the
crop Ro buing to be fair is a really
good example there exactly so you can't
really judge Tommy Fury at this stage
because because of his lack of amateur
experience um but like you just said
earlier on the guys that he's fighting
is probably in that parallel to what he
would be fighting even even if he was
just fighting journeyman in the Pro game
he's a little bit better I think he's a
little bit better ambition I think
you're right here I got a question
actually I've got a question for you
first Joe
yeah KSI is getting his name announced
mhm you've been in there with him you're
the guy personally very well what how
how is he when I was across the ring
from him no [__] joke I was I was
going you're nervous you're so he looked
[__] he was [__] himself and he
was like he he genuinely was and he and
now I think he's got to a point where he
goes if I just 100% believe and go
Legacy in his head he's going Legacy
Legacy Legacy in his head and believe
and believe then he's exuding it but at
that point mate I he wasn't confident
when I've spoken to the likes of well
I've heard I don't know if it's was Cal
frezy or someone but they were like the
morning of that fight he didn't eat
break he couldn't eat he was so like
sheepish he was so nervous but I think
now he's got to this point he's figured
it out if I go a wholeheartedly belief
and even we we see it sometimes as
delusion but if he goes without a doubt
no question I've got this I've got this
then it works and it has paid offive
it's if it's when it doesn't work that
it's going to be like okay where does he
go from there here we are they're uh if
it ever does they're about to touch
gloves or they may not touch gloves KSI
is dipped his head he's sort of bending
over at the waist there looking up at
Tommy Fury Tommy is looking down neither
man looks in any way in doubt of a
victory here um so there is delusion in
one of them we're going to find out who
it is KSI Tommy Fury true Jordy YouTube
channel don't forget to like And
subscribe appreciate everyone watching
here we go round one I got a feeling
he's going to run at him like Anthony
Taylor did I wouldn't be
surprised he says he's got a game plan
and he doesn't need heart because the
game plan will work and he's doing the
bouncing on his uh toes sort of thing
and he throws a big overhand right
hand oh a little slip there and Tommy
and KSI ties up with Tommy we're going
to see if there's a big strength
difference here there's a lot of added
um size on Tommy by this point of the
rehydration he's probably over 200 now
after weighing at
183 and uh KSI is looking really
loose um he does look loose doesn't he
lad yeah that's the thing like this this
this strange sort of like bouncing thing
that he does it's very oddd it is so
unconventional and like that these early
rounds that that could throw Tommy off
it's when he adjusts he's a lot like the
guy MVP who also trains at shoot
Fighters um who's a um like kickboxing
expert uh MMA fighter B knuckle as well
oh big right hand from JJ see that's
what I'm saying 100% that is it it's
that he's throwing off he covers
distance quickly with he launch launches
himself on so quickly it's very
impressive My worry is is he's not
throwing wrong anything else it's it's
it's sort of the same shot over and you
just don't want to become predictable
but yeah it it it did land there yeah
that is the shot man that is it that is
the one he's very deceiving the way he
covers that ground that that was a
massive amount of uh space covered in
one
goal it's uh it's a pound shop Fury
verse Wilder it it kind of is yeah um
and he's not biting on the fence of uh
Tommy here really uh Tommy's trying to
sort of uh do the uh you know the Tyson
Fury style but
KSI is is looking okay in there he's
looking composed he's covering distance
well and he's not overed by this it's
it's you know the fight isn't really
started properly yet oh there's a good
there's a good left H landed by Tommy
fury it's that overhand I we said about
we said about an influence of boxing you
go where the money's at one thing I'm
looking at straight away Tommy looks
massive compared to KSI oh back of the
head shot from Tommy Fury and KSI is um
complaining about it I don't know if we
might say a point deducted here but he's
complaining to the referee saying what
the [__] was that he's milking it I
don't know yeah I don't think that was
anything bad you never know what them
head shots like but I mean not that it's
the back of the head and that's
obviously a different story but KSI did
throw an upper cut earlier on in the in
in the clinch when they were holding so
we'll have a look at it here oh that was
a it was two that's a point deduction
usually isn't it yeah well you get a
warn sometimes early on do you know what
it's it's like putting a two not a two
footy bit it's like putting a big
challenge in first second one genuinely
just seen a go and nipples cover by the
really can we rewind or we um KSI still
employing that um that long range game
but T Tommy's covering distance and he's
locking up with him a lot you know Tommy
said that he's going to he's going to
step on the pace he's going to get him
out of here earlier I think that Tommy
could do of getting his jab going here a
little bit he's not he's not got the jab
going you know what it is it's cuz KSI
is out of
distance
or no midrange figh yeah yeah yeah that
is what KSI does very well yeah it's
actually you know it's problematic for
Tommy he's Tommy doesn't look like he
did against Jake Paul he looks like he's
struggling to figure him out a little
bit Yeah Jake Paul is nowhere near as
erratic and I mean that in a good way as
KSI yeah and I I said Jake Paul was more
predictable than KSI and that alone
gives KSI in Advantage it doesn't mean
it changes the outcome but it's it's a
tougher style to figure out it's not
like this is a boxer I've seen what
boxers do before it's it's more like MVP
right um and when when J uh JJ lands and
there's another back of the head shot
and the referee is that referee is a bit
old to be in there with these what's
going oh end of the he's only thrown
that back hand all he needs to be doing
is moving off to his right uh to move
away from that KSI big back hand that's
all he needs to be doing and if you can
get that jab on the way that's all he
needs that up jaob that he throws I
think if a KSI team must be happy with
that I mean he didn't look completely
overr got around in probably landed a
decent shot no one really won the round
you can argue that KSI got that the
first ra hand earli in the round was
that was the best punchi got the best
punch there was two meaningful shots in
the whole fight K in the whole round
sorry KSI has probably been the better
one with that overhand right and then
there was the
left yeah yeah uh good first round uh
you know if you're worrying about the
level that Tommy should be at
um I
what I would ask myself there is who's
exerted more energy there and I would
definitely say you know the problem when
you're throwing from that far out is
landing on a Target as you're traveling
that much distance like you it's not the
same as it when you're fighting in your
comfort zone and if Tommy starts to time
it he might get caught coming in he's
looking for that up theut I would assume
now right got a feeling Cent from Tommy
in there that t of that yeah that's what
he's he's waiting for kosi to Lunge in
and that's what I'm saying like it's
early that KSI needs to catch in because
I feel like Tommy will figure it out if
not that'll be John in in the corner
going this that this like who's also
seeing what's going on I know I've said
it but to people watching influencer
boxing and if that's all they've seen
they won't realize as much but to people
that watch Boxing week in week out this
size difference is massive yeah it's
it's borderlan
it's it's a weird division or two nearly
it's a super midle he's piing a point
it's one point deducted from Tommy Fury
and round two so potentially we might
have round one to KSI and another round
to KSI that is huge at this point wow
wow what was he thinking doing that
there this is like the music thing do
you know when you're the big name you
can use the influence by complaining
normally the ref would say just be quiet
that's my job but he's got that much
influence mhm ooh oh it's a big right
hand from KSI oh and Tommy stunned and
KSI is whing on him and this is this is
the game plan whoa yeah that was a
decent little right I think I got over
excited but [__] it I don't care that
was decent I mean [__] hell mate KSI
is doing better man I Tommy's struggling
to figure out like he can't close the
distance look KSI is maintaining that
distance so well yes he really is and
what the the worry is is you don't want
to get trapped in the corners but when
Tommy does close the distance KSI
clinches up works his way out and then
gets like this the way where he puts his
head is very intelligent from KSI puts
it round the shoulder that means that if
you know he's protecting himself and if
Tommy does throw it it's going to be
back of the head the the worry is is if
KSI gets a little bit tired I don't
that's a lot of eny Clos he is carrying
that extra weight as well but I believe
look look he walks around normally
heavier than this and I think KSI he's
got them jeans we've seen it before he
he you know he's got the ability to to
last and to dig deep the problem is
Tommy's allowing that room the L and he
should be getting much closer on the
edge of ring and using his jaob he's
just giving him all that distance to
such a good job and you're not even
using it that see straight JB to the
body as well rather than just go to the
head every time where he can come
underneath and then hold you yeah just
do know why he's not putting the
pressure like front foot pressure credit
to KSI he's he's doing good yeah yeah
without a doubt I tell you what My worry
is from a from a sort of audience aspect
here is since Tommy had that point
deducted I've seen him go to the back of
the head again I think I think we could
see another Point deducted if keeps that
up yeah and it's hard for him because
I've I've been in that situation where
it's like oh he's landed again there you
know doing the right thing Tommy's
trying to move to his right to move away
from it but he's still not quite get
there another back of the head shot from
Tommy Fury I don't know how he keeps
doing this is he going to get another
Point
deducted um and and and we're at the end
of the second round and one thing we do
know now one thing we found out already
is KSI versus Jake Paul is competitive
we already know that now like we
couldn't really tell from the Joe Foria
how good are these guys we now know
you've been in there and whatever
happens we know that's a good fight you
know what's crazy as well is I feel like
KSI has unlocked a new boxing style that
I think you could see implemented by
professionals this thing BR is crazy
you've never seen this this Skippy thing
that he does way out of range and then
launch himself in where like too quick
for you to be like mate it's it works
and it's working but there there are
ways around it but Tommy furri is is not
aware of it he's not experienced enough
to do it at this point in time but would
would you argue that KSI is winning the
first two rounds I think with the pine
deduction you would I
think this was a dis oh that was a clean
right can I say something that you might
think it's a little bit controversial
here on the first two rounds but I
actually think the tactics that Tommy's
implementing aren't that bad I actually
think that over the course of what is
this eight rounds six is it only six
yeah credit to the Audience by the way
shout out to you guys you're voting and
you've said that KSI is winning the
first two rounds so You' spoken hit that
like button we're in for the third round
now and Tommy is um looking a little bit
more a little bit more frantic a little
bit more purposeful he's trying to match
him he's trying to match what he's doing
again back of the head Tommy Tommy needs
to jab to the body cuz that will open
things up a lot he needs to stick to his
own tactics in try to instead of trying
to do what ji is doing you know what
playing Another Man's game is never a
good idea well that that's that's a sign
that KSI when he's drawn him drawn him
into his type of fight Jesus this is
great yeah this is mental come on
son I just I just worry when he is
jumping in if you know that's a lot of
energy um and a a lot of force to be
moving with and if you get met with a
shot it then increases the power of that
right so you just got to hope that uh
Tommy can't uh time him but right now
this isn't beautiful boxing and I said
you're not going to box him you're going
to fight him in my prediction video and
that and that's exactly what we're doing
we're seeing a very abnormal fight even
and we're all talked about uh Tommy's
job where's it been non-existent cuz
he's out of range yeah he's either well
out of range or he's completely inside
and and they've taken they've nullified
the job credit to his team like for
doing that yeah and then when he gets in
range tie up that's what it is it's be
well out of range and then tie up and he
clinches again something you can do
sometimes and it's not a necessarily a
positive thing to do but when you feel
like you're a level above someone and
they're trying to do a certain tactic
with you say for example they're walking
you down trying to fight with you and
you know you're better on the back foot
against them you sometimes think come on
in let's have it your way let's have it
at your game it's a macho thing it's the
J though TR KSI wasn't able to do
anything he needs to use that jab the
reason was though is KSI got caught in
the corner right um he needs to he KSI
needs to make sure he's not stuck there
I feel like when he throws that second
jab rather than actually aiming it he
needs to throw it in anticipation down
cuz he knows K head's going going to be
there yeah he also kind of stepped in
too deep and he smothered himself he
couldn't get anything else off Tommy
seems to be coming back into it more in
in this fight not that he hasn't been in
it but but but he seems to be landing a
bit more in this round okay I breathing
very heavy now as well because that is
the thing well this is the other thing
like as fit as you are no matter what we
we can't doubt that Tommy for a lot of
the times on the front foot here how
long can that last for that bouncing
style I've seen good Pros that can't
keep that up for six Frees I admit the
one thing that always impressed me
throughout all of the the the fight with
kti when he fought Logan it was like
that I'm willing to dig deep I I'm like
and he he has got an amazing natural
engine you know some people are just
born like he just has that um it's that
desire to win isn't it yeah oh oh oh oh
nice okay high up yeah through that low
that time so KSI went in and and threw a
low um right hand and Tommy did catch
him afterwards but not not enough and
right now team KSI must be thrilled with
how this is going all right you're not
guaranteed the win so far but it's very
competitive yes it's a tricky fight it's
awkward it's uncomfortable Tommy can't
be happy with that there ain't no boxing
Clinic going on right now John Fury must
be [__] in these kegs yeah he said he
would have him within within two rounds
within three rounds at the most it
changed a few times but the bottom line
is is Tommy Fury again is is in there
with an influencer and to court Big John
if we get to a decision even if we win
we've lost he said that before the Jake
fight he swept that under the cover uh
under under the carpet quickly but he's
doing it again like Tommy Fury level is
um to be fair is is a professional
boxer's level but he can't be happy with
being in there with influence us
multiple times now in struggling at
times 100% and you've got to give it to
KSI here I can't like emphasize enough
like this a Giza that's gone from being
like realistically a fat idiot on a
couch that plays fif like being [__]
who [__] real that's what he I me now
you've got him against one of the fury
clown from Tomy and he's absolutely like
M he's he could win this fight 100% from
what I've seen so far for so apparently
the audience uh watching had round three
for Tommy yeah um so going off our
audience shout out to them hit that like
button it's 21 potentially to KSI or it
may be 2-1 to Fury there's a points
deduction though oh that jab is so two1
to KSI but a point deduction that means
KSI is up by two
points yeah potentially um I must admit
like if we go to the judges it'll be
very interesting how that goes I mean
we've still got a few rounds left so you
know good job from
JJ that jab starting to stop him in his
track now yeah I think JJ's tiredness is
catching up with the highly athletic
style he's he's relied on a lot of
acceleration you can see why he only
wanted six rounds because I think if
this was eight I think it would get to a
point where he the longer goes on the
left athleticism matter um that that M
that was but to be fair to JJ he gave up
the you know a lot of experience size
like there is no way JJ should even be
in there with in a professional none of
these influencers technically should be
in there with professionals you know but
[__] that's what's so amazing about
this really I'm just worried that KSI
looks a little more tired um
now but he's still hanging in there um
yeah and there's a lot of clinching a
lot of clinching yeah a bit too much
actually yeah like if if you're wanting
a beautiful boxing match you're not
getting it but obviously team KSI will
be delighted because it's there's no
thunderous Jabs um yeah it kind of looks
like all yeah if
yeah the referee is tapping them on the
shoulders separating
them oh oh a little bit of a hook there
did that land it's hard to tell it's so
scruffy and Scrappy isn't
it yeah and this is what KSI had to do
really not make it a boxing oh he had
Anthony Taylor the [__] out of without a
doubt and he's doing that yeah man
it he's still managing to stay on his
right who doesn't land Tommy looked like
he might have heard JJ a little bit and
he
yes Tommy stepping in with that jab
every single time he needs to either
throw that jab or faint that jab take a
step back and he'll have a bit of room
to work but he's front foot heavy and
he's going in every time with it there
oh yeah he's smothering himself it's
like every time you know what I mean
it's because he's he's wary of that
right hand I'd like to see JJ throw the
left hook though because Jake Paul had a
lot of success with that left hook over
and over again and he's only been
throwing the the the the big right when
he's coming in and it just might be
worth switching it up um a little bit
there what I have seen from KSI when he
throws that left hookies he does Square
his hips up uh he squares his hips up
after the right hand a little bit
whereas Jake Paul's a bit more Tommy's
getting a lot of [__] from the KSI
coaches for throwing after the Bell
there just a word i' who would you say
wins that round I would Tommy I think
he's too all but i' have KSI a point up
because of the points imagine if he KSI
wins again because of a points deduction
you know like against Logan there was
that I'll take that right now but yeah
but but is there an element dring within
him that's like I'd like i' like to win
convincingly where it's like there's no
there's no you got point you know what I
mean is the worry though that the
knockout punch it's less and less likely
now given the fact that you're seeing
that so much of the game plan in the
early rounds was the of KSI covering
that distance that acceleration it's
calming down and I'm not saying you
won't get another wind and you can't do
it but it becomes less lately right if
we take away the points deduction and if
we take away the fact that we know that
one man has had a wealth of experience
in terms of being in and around boxing
gyms come from a boxing family and we
just looked at it for what it is are we
all agreeing that right now four rounds
in it's even isn't it absolutely yeah
and the audience is saying that at home
as well they're saying it's two My worry
is is the last two rounds have both went
to Tommy um and you just you don't want
the tie to turn completely this is where
you want to win one back and
KSI from KSI nice inside right hand from
KSI and it's a dirty fight but that's
what we want yeah I've just had in my
group chat so this fight is so bad KSI
is luning in like it's rugby KSI ain't a
boxer this is embarrassing for boxing
what do we think I don't think so I
think he's he's showing boxing up if
anything if that's what you want to say
I mean Tommy's the boxer the all hus is
on him to deliver there's no expectation
on KSI Tommy is in there and it's like
go on then you're the pro show Tommy
said he was going to give a master class
I mean oh man this is even if Tommy wins
by knockout now this ain't a master
class bro no way not at
all oh [__] Al I'm panicking every
time I think I think if Tommy was to win
by knockout now it shows adaptability
and it shows that he's able to come
through styles that maybe he didn't
anticipate CU this KSI style like it is
very awkward for even the most like
season like boxer like cuz it's kind of
not really boxing it's it's fighting and
it's like I'm either going to you know
he's tying him up and wrestling or he's
way out of distance like there's no
actual like let's let's box do you know
what I mean shout out to everyone
watching if you could hit that like
button and subscribe we're in 1 minute
30 seconds of KSI versus Fury they're
clinched up right now and uh it it's
been a scrappy fight and this is a the
game plan of KSI is working to a degree
right now for sure for sure not it's not
a skill uh based fight right now it's a
who wants it more and that's what he
needed to do and that's what Jake Paul
didn't do Jake Paul fight to box him and
it was obvious how that fight was going
whereas at least in this fight I think I
mean I I I think Jake had Great Moments
don't get me wrong but I I prefer this
game plan right now the only I think for
the fans what's quite frustrating is
that we like isn't it interesting how
the whole of the undercard was so
entertaining and then the two main
events have been quite Scrappy it's you
know what I mean yeah I hear it's quite
frustrating actually that's when there's
the level of pressure for a fight you
know what I mean sometimes it does
there's pressure on Tommy to turn it
into a boxing match though and he's not
doing that right now it's quite it's
like the Anthony Taylor fight against
Kenny it's difficult to make it a boxing
match when you've got a guy that just
wants to lean on your chest the whole
time you know mean yeah KSI looks tired
man yeah I mean he should be right but
the thing is for this if it stays
Scrappy like this what Tommy needs to do
to swing it in his favor is even if it's
Scrappy he needs to land one or two eye
catching shots per round not doing that
yeah g yeah and then then ksi's brought
him down to his level you know what I
mean that's exactly what's happened I
love that that's actually this as you
know that's very common though oh it
does when you're fighting on or are more
go on
JJ that wasy actually say there though
that Tommy might have had the better of
that exchange yeah yeah yeah but they
were both throwing windmills there
weren't
they one round left Lads final round
like I Tommy Tommy's probably on top but
there was a pointed deduction it's it's
been
close I don't know where this goes man
like cuz realistically you know the
beauty of this last round you're like
one more round son go out there and give
us 1 million per and make this fight
yours both camps will be saying that to
this guys you've got one round to prove
you won this make it a clear round um
and because so much energy has been
taken from JJ he doesn't have to worry
about like going another few rounds it's
just one
more the problem is Tommy has adapted I
would say he's adapted over the rounds
cuz he probably did lose the first two
but it's still not enough it's he's just
it's not good enough it's he needs that
little bit more to make sure it's
convincing I don't think Tommy has
really caught JJ with one single
eye-catching wow shot not really no like
there's a few um left hooks in close but
not nothing that we've gone whoa not one
reaction yet so for him he can't be
happy with this and the Happ of the two
will be KSI and generally speaking when
the rounds are close you do need that
eye catch and punch to either
way I mean there's if this round goes
the way that the others have gone this
is probably a draw
yeah be good if they could box do you
know what I mean yeah St it's meant to
be boxing mate do you know it's just
quite frustrating and imagine is a
draw that's that's a win for KSA oh
massively immediate rematch though if
it's a draw right yeah surely straight
away just [__] like just actual box
do know what I mean Tommy's adapted to
the what's coming back but he hasn't
adapted what he's actually doing he
hasn't adapted to a point where he's
inflicting damage no yeah he's doing no
damage in there from round one when he
has punched he smothered himself he
hasn't why is his Corner not to just
yeah take a half a step
back he connected there JJ yeah I both
both kind of grazed each other there but
again it wasn't the most KSI landed and
then Tommy kind of replied with a
similar shot
interested to see what Big John makes of
this nice job from JJ another job from
JJ Come On
Son oh man I mean this round who's
winning it it's very hard it's very even
so even there's an argument for either
way it's going to be a draw isn't it
it's it's going well I just don't know
if that that the whole the the point
getting taken away man you think of
tommmy Fury right let's you know the
level we're talking about KSI whenever
Tommy Fury comes close k side dips his
head to the same side every time yeah
Tommy Fury is is all the experience he
has hasn't timed that yet six [__]
rounds like for all like for all Tommy
is the experienced Pro it's the
opportunities have been there for him to
work out what's going on and has he made
some adjustments a little bit but it's
not been great from him like and and
there is no pressure on JJ to come out
there and put on a boxing clinic or a
master class he just has to be in there
and be competitive all the pressure is
on Tommy he had he said I will do this
to you I will do that to you and uh it
ain't happened so far like man he's
still saying he's got Ambitions to
become a world champion no is is it
looking that way is it bollocks is it
bollocks mate honestly welcome to
Misfits you better make it your home bro
cuz you ain't got anywhere else to be
imagine Vidal Riley in there with Tommy
Fury [__] hell Jesus we have your
body bag ready yeah that's an
assassination yeah 20 seconds left of
this fight
oh tomm Tommy's tired isn't he yeah and
and actually oh good right hand by JJ
but Tommy aners good right hand by both
K has kept up That Bouncy style it yeah
man he's got he's got engine like yeah
he's like [__] ke you know CH he just
never stops and it's all over not the
sh oh I mean there's not a conclusive
winner um it's probably a draw uh
what are you thinking Brian if you had
to say call it I mean was was Tommy the
one who was a little bit better yeah
Tommy was probably initi in most of the
exchanges he was probably Landing more
more of the shots but none of which were
very there was no meaningful shots glans
and blows um it's but then but then also
like we again like the fact we know the
context behind the fight plays into this
massive true if you're just looking at
it a fight you go that's a draw because
of the point deduction because you
actually go okay that fell in terms of
Tommy he edged it ever so slightly you
got a point taken off it's a draw and
I'll tell you what now i' I'd put and I
know it's very hard to do this of a draw
but I put a lot of money on it we see a
draw here but would you say Tommy lost
the first two potentially and then won
the next four so he lost the points he's
still Tech W don't know if he won that
last round I don't know if he I don't
know if he even lost a second but this
is I think he lost the second I don't
know if he lost the first but I don't
even know if he won the last one people
are automatically saying he won the last
one I didn't see there was nothing in
that last one apart from one good
exchange when when when rightly so we we
all gave a reaction when KSI landed that
right hand but not not all of us give
the biggest reaction was straight away
Tommy landed a right little screw shot
uppercut there so are we all are we in
agreeance and correct me if I'm wrong
words in a fight like this it's kind of
difficult to know what the [__] the
judges are going to think and I bet you
those judges deep down are thinking
[__] hell they're going to going to
give hard I would I think I think the
draw is a very fair outcome yeah and
really that's a JJ win then if they draw
if they're drawing this fight that's a
do you know what the goal from JJ was I
want to be better than Jake Paul well if
you get a draw against Tommy Fury and he
lost yeah mission accomplished yeah yeah
yeah and then all of a sudden [__] off
Tommy get Jake in here and let's get the
fight everyone actually wanted cuz we no
offense Tommy you're lovely but no one
[__] wanted you in this scene we
wanted Jake Paul versus KSI that
performance is good enough for them too
to fight he wanted I wanted I wanted
that win or lose he's he's put on a good
performance he's competitive with Tommy
so as Jake we've got answer you're
around the similar level so let's see
who the better man is now let's get the
fight a proper 10 rounder or something
like that yeah cuz this is the thing the
six round bollocks like it enables it
enables the wrestling and all that [__]
we need a box match 10 to 12 [__]
rounds mate 100% I won 10 Rounds even
though that was six rounds though Tommy
looked just as tired as agreed I don't
think there was much that last round was
really close in my opinion that's why
I'm not like oh it was 24 can someone
tell me what's happening yeah how do we
know who wins Alex did they
give all right they're teing it up now
and in the buildup we were told that
Tommy has gone way harder in this than
he than he had in the Jak he did eight
rounds against Jake Paul he looked just
as tired if not more in this fight Ty's
not looking confident there does he at
all Tyson don't care I think T Tyson
Tyson's very nervous when he's his
family are fighting he doesn't look
happy he's only confident when he's
fighting it's cuz kind of it's out of
your hand it's out of your control and
you can tell he's a control freak you
know what I
mean Logan's in the ring with KSI as
well put the prime chain on
him all right just waiting to hear
what's being
said scores coming
now like And subscribe if you haven't
already everyone call it I'm I'm going
to go draw I'm going to go draw I mean I
think the fair result is a draw I think
no fighter deserves the win if I'm
honest sorry see that
g 5757 first judge we might have a
majority 5756 to who Fury Tommy Fury
Fury Fury W they give it to him Fury
Fury win Fury W look at him oh my God he
he's won the lottery again what Tomy
Fury the winner no to be honest I was
going edging that way but it was like
it's it was I
wasn't we got we got we got another uh
like Split
Decision um or a majority win rather
it's almost identical to the Jake Paul
fight yeah yeah yeah so now can we get
Tommy Fury the [__] out of here because
we didn't want you here anyway let's get
Jake Paul KSI the fight everyone really
wanted the the the Jake Paul fight was a
much much clearer win for Tommy Fury
than that I watched that Jake Paul fight
earlier I was having a little watch and
I was thinking it's a much clearer win
but I would say I feel like a bit of a
SN say now decision's been announced but
exactly like say even man was going to
win can ask question though to be fair
to Jake Paul no slight on
KSI Jake Paul landed possibly more
meaningful punches on Tommy though it
was more of a real a back and forward it
wasn't anywhere near as much clinching
and it was more of a boxing match
so as as much as Jake was taking more
punishment it's cuz the he was trying to
punch more and trying to engage more in
an actual you know the ironic thing here
is Tommy's took the win there ksi's took
the loss if there's either fighter out
of the two of them now you're saying
where do they go from here is Tommy
what's what is The Logical fight Tommy
can [__] off man I've got no interest in
watching him fight again after that like
with all due respect you fought two
YouTubers and scraped the decision I
don't care what last name is you w't
needed here mate you were here for
personality big game uh big names and
all of that you don't bring that man
thing is I'll be I'll be real I think
against
KSI almost any professional boxer not
any I won't say any but the style in
which he fought then I feel like any
traditional boxer would struggle to box
and it would be and it would be a scrap
page of a win because KSI nullified the
game plan of Tommy very very well there
and I feel like yeah Tommy you know but
the point with Tommy is you've shown
that you're not a level above these guys
you are you are the same level you've g
a split decision with one and a draw and
you've edged it on on the judg of
scorecards you haven't shown anything
that says you're any like pro boxer that
you've made out to be it's bollock I do
disagree with that because I think
there's a lot of pro boxers who would
make light work of KSI on that like you
disagree with Joel yeah like I think
he's a one trick prony like he's got
that leap in right hand I don't think
he's got much else really and I think
there's a lot of pro boxers who would
have dealt with that a lot to me all it
does is confirm the level at which Tommy
Fury's at that's all it does for me KSI
is right where he should be really he's
an influencer an influencer boxing yeah
whereas Tommy Fury is not what he's
claiming to be in my eyes the thing is
now as well right so you can see KSI is
completely rejecting that what's just
happened he's not accepting it which is
fair I mean you could the decision
without a doubt but where now do do like
do you think KSI will go with with this
it's got to be Jake Paul man Tommy you
go do the dishes for Molly and we want
to see a real fight now we want to see
the one everyone really wanted we never
wanted Tommy [__] him but do you not
think K want to get back yeah but do you
not think so much money off of being a
fraud yes but irrelevant he's taken
something from KSI now he's going to
want to get that back I think you think
you think I
would I'd love to hear saying you didn't
win how many how many jobs did you land
how many jobs did he land you mean it's
got rematch all over it yeah definitely
I want the Jake Paul fight man is a
rematch I don't need to see Tommy Fury
ever again I want to go to the pro runs
and make a switch off from him and I
never want to watch him again because
you're only here because you're the pro
you've shown you're not that much better
than them what the [__] are you doing
can I say something though like we we've
said it time and time again that context
is everything here right if Tommy Fury
wasn't Tyson Fury's little brother we'd
look at it and we'd go you've come into
the influence boxing scene you beat
Anthony Taylor who we all know is a
bogey man of influencer boxing very
dangerous you beat Jake Paul you've beat
KSI were they all very close fights yeah
fair enough but he has beat these guys
so because the fact that he said I aim
for World titles and because the fact
his last name is Fury we're obviously
you know you know feeling this way about
him but if you just judge him in the
industry he's in right now which is
influen of boxing I don't think you'd
actually say that I think you'd actually
go all right let's see you against dgo I
mean if meand had B should be me Uncle
as the old saying this man has been
boxing since he was 6 years old KSI took
this up fought Jo well had a couple more
fights with Logan Paul a year later took
three years off come back I'll have a
few more fights then fought Tommy Fury
in no way shape or form on any Planet
should he be able to go that close with
Tommy Fury if you're if if John Fury
sips his little whiskey at night and he
looks at he'd go [__] me you're not all
you're not you're not made for this like
you're like not what your talk World
titles forget it if Prince Nassim was
watching this he go he should quit over
for him sometimes in in fights like I
remember FR V Groves once that no matter
who gets uh the result in the fight and
who's the winner there is a person that
will come away with a moral victory in
those fights and obviously in this one
KSI is the one that not only Has Come
Away with a moral Victory here he's the
one that's Come Away with more options
here that that has more possibilities of
different avenues we' like to see him go
down whereas for Tommy Fury the
disappointing fre thing for him here is
the only fight I really want to see him
in is Idris Virgo and that don't pay
and you know you're you're in the
minority and that like would other
people watch it yeah I mean they'd tune
in but they a paying pay-per-view money
that you've been getting so I hope you
saved what you made off the last two cuz
they they should just [__] him off the
whole point of Misfits was like we W
Jake Paul KSI this guy was just brought
in because Jake Paul thought yeah [__]
it I I'll I'll have a fight with him
like I don't know why we need him again
I will say one thing I remember I had a
fight with someone I actually won it it
was a close decision and I was desperate
to rematch him knowing a fighter
mentality Jake Paul and Tommy uh Jake
Paul and KSI sorry both now sit there
knowing that Tommy Fury has got a win
over both of them and that means there's
two real legitimate options out there
for him for a next
fight and they are Jake Paul and KSI I
think they should just fight each other
yeah they should they should that is
what every mind yeah yeah that is the
thing it's like there's going to be he's
going to he's got got to go to sleep
every single night knowing this man beat
me and KSI being KSI he's going to want
to [__] avenge that before anything
and I think he's going to look at what
Jake Paul did Jake Paul he he gave the
opportunity to fight Jake Paul after
Jake Paul lost to Tommy Fury and Jake
Paul was like now I want to do some
comeback fights and get my confidence up
and KSI there's going to be Ane element
where he's like well I've just lost I I
now want to [__] get back and get
back on my you know on the horse in in
that sense so I wouldn't be surprised if
you see that Tommy rematch you know the
reason I'm I'm and I know I'm I'm drunk
and all of that right but I'm actually
thinking like so the whole point of
Tommy Fury and the context of it was is
he's a fury he's a pro he is the gold
standard we've seen he ain't the gold
standard yeah the the cloak of deception
has been revealed and we now know you're
just a decent boxer who should be way
better than you are for all the years
that you've been getting coached by your
family and you've turned up you're
marginally better than the best guys we
have but you should be way better yes
correct but this actually lays into the
rematch happening more because it gives
KSI the feeling that he could actually
beat him more if it was a schooling he'd
probably go you know what I got beat
fair and square he's the better man let
me now go to Jake Paul but because it
was quite close KSI is going to feel he
can get him back and I think that's what
he's going to do yeah do you know what I
mean as much as we think all of this and
that's what we want this is the facts I
think you know what the other option is
here the other option is we get what we
want in terms of KSI and Jake Paul
fighting each other Logan Paul like I
said before looks at that and goes Tommy
limped over the line I'm going to be the
man that beats him yeah so you have Jake
Paul KSI Main Event Tommy Fury Logan
Paul co-main of the next that is
Pay-per-view [__] hell guys yes boys
yes it was a great night I mean look
protect this house the
last we [__] hate this outfit um
shout out to everyone uh who watched big
love to all of you lot out there don't
forget to hit that like button and big
luck to all of the boys um it was a
great night uh what was your fight of
the night Lads let me know oh I think
slim doing what he did I thought that
was
phenomenal joint with what walled sharks
did with de the great I thought that was
fantastic what are you saying
Loza probably P probably the What Slim
did it' be fair stopping cuz I even
though I did was probably the only one
who predicted the win was but I wasn't
expecting to stop him I wasn't expecting
that so I'd probably go to him I'd go W
shots against de the great de great did
very very well and I'm very much looking
forward to going through him like a hot
knife through
buty we got it we got it Joshua is your
favorite one I think the salt papy fight
was a really really good one I enjoyed
that a lot what about
you uh do you know what early on in the
night the heavyweight boys um we haven't
mentioned it so I'm going to mention it
because obviously the the te the great w
was [__] box office uh but the
heavyweight Lads early on I got to give
them respect I mean it wasn't the most
pretty but man were they digging deep
and they like you know getting the [__]
beating out with them the pair of them
um so yeah we're going to wrap this up
here big love to all of you lck don't
forget to keep it locked on the true J
YouTube channel shout out to Joel
well shout out to Loza oy shout out to
my boy Joey and Josh we'll see you on
the next one thanks a
lot